BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE
ON EDUCATION FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO ARE WONDERING.
WE'RE GOING TO BE COVERING --
SINGLE BUDGET ITEM TODAY IT'S
ITEM SIXTY FOUR FORTY IT'S THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WE'RE GONNA SHAKE UP THE
ORDER OF THE AGENDA JUST A
LITTLEBIT BECAUSE WE HAVE SOME
PANELISTS --
THAT NEED TO LEAVE EARLY TO
CATCH FLIGHTS SO WE'RE GONNA
TAKE ISSUE NUMBER.
SIX UC MEDICAL EDUCATION FIRST
[inaudible]
FOLLOWING OF THE PRESENTATION OF
ISSUE SIX I WILL TAKE A PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE ISSUES THAT THESE
PANELISTS COVERS SO THAT THEY
CAN HEAR.
THE PUBLIC COMMENT BEFORE THEY
NEED TO LEAVE AND THEN WE WILL
GO BACK TO ISSUE NUMBER.
ONE AND TAKE CARE OF THE REST OF
THE AGENDA IN ORDER WITH PUBLIC
COMMENT FOLLOWING.
AT THE END OF ISSUE NUMBER.
NINE SO THAT'S THE OF BATTING
ORDER TODAY.
AND WE'LL START WITH OUR ISSUE
NUMBER SIX PANEL.
ONCE EVERYBODY --
FINDS A CHAIR IN THE MUSIC STOPS.
LET'S --
HAVE YOU INTRODUCE YOURSELVES
FOR THE RECORD STARTING TO MY
LEFT YOU'RE RIGHT SIR.
GOOD MORNING JAX WALLS FROM A
FINANCE THANK YOU.
WALT DISNEY CONCENTRATORS
LEGENDS OFFICE. TO ROSE.
ANGELA GILYARD DIRECTOR OF GOOD
TO SEE YOU MA'AM BECAUSE OUR
NATION ASSOCIATE VICE PRESIDENT --
IN THE OFFICE OF PRESIDENT.
NICE TO HAVE YOU HERE MA'AM I'M
DEPUTIES THEM THE DAY AND AT THE
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE AT UC
RIVERSIDE.
THANKS FOR JOINING US OKAY WHO
WANTS TO START ON ISSUE NUMBER.
SIX GOOD MORNING --
SO THIS IN PREVIOUS YEARS THE
ADMINISTRATION SHIFTED GENERAL
FUND OUT OF USES BASED BUDGET --
AND BACK FILL THOSE FUNDS OF
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX SPONSORS
FOR GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION.
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT
PROVIDED FORTY MILLION ONE TIME --
TO OFFSET THAT BACK FILL IN THE
IN THIS CURRENT YEAR --
THAT MAY PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX
FUNDS AVAILABLE FOR STATEWIDE
GRANT PROGRAM OPERATED BY
PHYSICIANS FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA TO EXPAND RESIDENCY
SLOTS STATEWIDE.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROVIDES
FORTY MILLION ONGOING GENERAL
FUND TO ADD TO THE SIDE AND THE
THE THIS OFF THAT I IN THE LONG
RUN SO THAT --
THIS PROGRAM HAVE LONG TERM
FUNDING.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
YES SIR.
THIS ISN'T AN ISSUE WHERE OUR
OFFICE HAS A HARD RECOMMENDATION --
BUT TO BUILD OFF OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PRESENTATION.
I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO
DIRECT YOUR ATTENTION TO PAGE
TWENTY SEVEN OF YOUR AGENDA.
THAT PAGE ARE THE TABLE ON THAT
PAGE SHOWS HOW THE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN ONE TIME FUNDS WERE
WERE SPENT ON THE PROPOSITION.
FIFTY SIX I MEAN YOU CAN SEE
THAT.
I'M A LITTLE MORE THAN HALF OF
THE FUNDS WORK TO SUPPORT.
NEW RESIDENCY SLOTS AND WHAT
THAT MEANS OUR IS SLOTS --
THE KIND OF GROWTH IN EXISTING
PROGRAMS --
AND THEN THE OTHER REMAINING
PORTION WAS.
FOR THE KIND OF SUSTAINED
EXISTING SLOTS AND AN EXISTING
PROGRAM SO THAT WASN'T THAT
DOESN'T REFLECT GROWTH THAT'S
KIND OF SUSTAINING THE SLOTS
THAT THE THAT MIGHT GIVE YOU
SOME SENSE --
AS TO HOW THE FUNDS MIGHT BE
SPENT ON AN ONGOING BASIS.
I'M SO I THOUGHT THAT
INFORMATION MIGHT BE HELPFUL AND
I'M HAPPY TO HELP ANSWER ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE
ON THIS ITEM DO YOU FIND A
PROBLEM WITH THAT [inaudible]
BREAKDOWN.
WHAT?
IN WITH REGARD TO THE EXISTING
SLOT SO I THINK THE THE KEY
QUESTION IS WHAT WHAT IS THE
PURPOSE --
SOME PROGRAMS MIGHT HAVE A HARD
TIME SUSTAINING SLOTS IF THEY
RUN OUT OF FUNDING OR IF THEY
DON'T.
QUALIFY FOR FEDERAL FUNDING SAY
FOR EXAMPLE IF THEY DON'T --
PROVIDE INPATIENT SERVICES OR IF
THEY DON'T SERVE AND AN OLDER
POPULATION THAT'S GENERALLY
SERVED BY MEDICARE.
THEN EXISTING THOUGHTS MIGHT
HELP SUSTAIN SOME OF THOSE --
RESIDENCY BASS LOTS BUT TO THE
EXTENT THAT THERE JUST HOLDING A
FLAT IT MIGHT NOT BE ADDRESSING --
SHORTAGES THAT EXIST IN THE
STATE SO THATTHAT'S KIND OF A A
KEY QUESTION TO CONSIDER IF
YOU'RE THAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT
THIS DATA.
WELL MAYBE AS WE MOVE THROUGH
THE THE PANEL THIS CAN CAN
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE AS WELL.
I I CERTAINLY UNDERSTOOD I CAN
UNDERSTAND COVERING EXISTING
RESIDENCIES WHEN [inaudible]
ADMINISTRATION PULLED. FOURTEEN
AS I RECALL PULLED FORTY MILLION
OUT OF THE BACK AND AND THEN.
AND THEN SO WE HAD A WE HAD AND
YOU WOULDN'T HAVE A NET INCREASE
IN MONEY I GUESS IS WHAT I'M
SAYING.
BUT NOW WITH THE MONEY RESTORED
I THINK TO UC.
AND THEN FORTY MILLION ON TOP
MAYBE SOMEONE COULD ADDRESS THE
USE OF THAT MONEY FOR EXISTING
RESIDENCY PROGRAM JUST OPPOSED
TO GROWTH IN THE PROGRAM AS WE
MOVE.
AS WE MOVE DOWN THE LINE.
AND THEN ONE OF MY OTHER --
CONCERTS CONCERNS AND IT IT
MAYBE IT'S BECAUSE OF PROP FIFTY
SIX IN THE LANGUAGE OF
PSYCHIATRY IS NOT IN THE LIST IN
TERMS OF OF RESIDENCY PROGRAMS
AND MY RECOLLECTION IS IT'S NOT.
SO LONG BROWN EITHER.
AND PSYCHIATRY --
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OF COURSE
ARE A BIG ISSUE OF FOR MOST AND
IF NOT ALL IN THIS BUILDING AT
LEAST IN THE LEGISLATURE.
AND HOW WE INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS AND
CERTAINLY IN THE UNDERSERVED
AREAS OF THE STATE SO.
JUST SOME COMMENTS [inaudible]
REFINISH HER [inaudible]
OKAY.
GOOD MORNING HI MISTER CHAIR --
I'D FIRST LIKE TO JUST START BY
SAYING --
AND BUILDING ON THE COMMENTS OF
THE AT A PREVIOUS SPEAKERS --
THE UNIVERSITY ENTERED INTO A
PARTNERSHIP THROUGH M. O. U.
WITH PHYSICIANS FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA --
IT THE THROUGH THE M. AUDIO
ESTABLISHED ABOARD A FIVE MEMBER
BOARD A FIFTEEN MEMBER ADVISORY
COUNCIL TO HELP MAKE DECSIONS
ABOUT I THE PROGRAM THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE PROGRAM IN
THE GIVING OF THE GRANTS AND
WITH THE IDEA THAT THIS WOULD BE
A STATE WIDE.
ADEQUATE --
BALLOT INITIATIVE AND SO TO
ANSWER YOUR SECOND QUESTION THE
BALLOT INITIATIVE PROVIDES
SPECIFICALLY FOR THESE FIVE
CATEGORIES LISTED --
IN THE ANALYSIS AND SO SINCE
THIS WAS YEAR TWO OF PROP FIFTY
SIX WE WANTED TO STAY.
AS CLOSE AS AND NOT EVEN BECAUSE
WE WANTED TO EXACT.
WITH A BALLOT INITIATIVE
LANGUAGE --
WE THOUGHT IT WOULD IT WAS THAT
WE WOULD BE ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE.
NEEDED --
THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
DEMONSTRATE THE THE THE THE THE
VARIOUS KICK OUT OF THE NEED
WITHIN THE VARIOUS CATEGORIES
AND THEN ALSO BE ABLE TO
DEMONSTRATE THE DISTRIBUTION IN
THE STATE --
THAT ALIGN WITH THE BALLOT
INITIATIVE YOU KNOW TO SEARCH
FOR ACTIVE PROGRAMS IN
UNDERSERVED AREAS AND SO FORTH
WELL WE MAY BE RESTRICTED TO THE
LANGUAGE OF THE OF THE BALLOT
INITIATIVE I DON'T KNOW SO WELL
YOU'RE PROBABLY SAFE SAFE IS
DOING NOT NOT EXACTLY THAT SIR
SO I WILL.
SAY THIS YES AND YOU'RE ONE
ABSOLUTELY THE BALLOT INITIATIVE
DOES REQUIRE THAT --
THAT THEY THE THE DISTRIBUTION
HOWEVER THERE IS A PROVISION IN
THE BALLOT INITIATIVE THAT
ALLOWS FOR STUDY.
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
WILL PERFORM FORCE AND IT IS
POSSIBLE THAT IN FUTURE YEARS
THE DISTRIBUTION OR THE
CATEGORIES COULD BE SHIFTED BUT
INITIALLY GIVEN THE HISTORY OF
THE FIRST YEAR OF THE FUNDS
BEING REDIRECTED --
AND THE SECOND YEAR THIS IS THE
FIRST AND THE FIRST YEAR OF THE
OPPOSITION FOR HAVE A CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION WE FELT
IT MADE.
THE AND AND AND A LONG WITH THE
FIFTEEN MEMBER ADVISORY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FELT THAT IT
WAS ADVISABLE TO STICK WITH THE
BALLOT INITIATIVE LANGUAGE AS
WRITTEN --
WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT PSYCHIATRY
IS IN NEED --
AND BUT THERE ARE NUMBER OF
ISSUES THAT WE MIGHT HAVE TO BE
ADDRESSED IN IN FUTURE YEARS WE
DO STILL HAVE QUITE A DEMAND.
ON THE CATEGORIES LISTED THERE
ARE THIRTY EIGHT MILLION THERE'S
THIRTY MILLION AVAILABLE FOR
GRANTS.
AND IT WITH A VERY SHORT TIME
LINE -- FOR
ADVERTISING TO GRANTEES AND HAVE
THEM --
RESPOND IN THIS ACTUALLY OVER
THAT OF THAT I'VE CHRISTMAS
HOLIDAY SEASON WE GOT A HUNDRED
AND FORTY SEVEN MILLION.
IN RICK --
GRANT REQUESTS RESPONSES I NEED
IN RESPONSE --
TO THEY THEY JUST THEY THEY THEY
WERE TAUGHT THIRTY EIGHT MILLION
WHICH I THINK.
BODES WELL FOR SAYING THIS MONEY
NEEDS TO CONTINUE TO BE
ALLOCATED EVERY YEAR --
TO THIS PROGRAM SO THAT --
YOU KNOW WE CAN BEGIN TO TO TO
HAVE A STEADY WAY OF OF MEETING
SOME OF IT THE DEMAND OF THAT
STATE.
OF GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION --
ALSO SAY THAT PART OF THE
DECISION --
TO AND YOU LOOK AT THE
DISTRIBUTION OR SOME NEW
PROGRAMS AND SOME EXISTING
PROGRAMS.
EXISTING --
GRADUATE GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS CAN BE --
FUNDED THROUGH A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT SOURCES IT'S NOT JUST
ONE SOURCE MANY MANY EXISTING
PROGRAMS RUN THROUGH GRANTS FROM
FROM PRIVATE FOUNDATIONS THERE
MAYBE FEDERAL GRANTS ARE USED SO
GO.
AND MAYBE SOME INSTITUTIONAL
MONEY -- THE
SERVICE --
FUNDED SO WE THOUGHT THAT.
WELL THE GOAL TO EXPAND IS OUT
OF A GOAL AND TO ADD NEW SLOT WE
DIDN'T WANT TO HAVE SLOTS THAT
COULD POTENTIALLY BE IN JEOPARDY
OR NOT FIND IT SO THAT'S WHY YOU
SEE THAT MIX.
ALSO SO SO THE EXISTING
RESIDENCY SLOTS WERE AT RISK OF
LOSING FUNDING.
FROM SOME PROGRAM PERHAPS OTHER
THAN SOME ROUND OR RIGHT RIGHT.
I SEE RIGHT EXACTLY SIR SO I
THINK THAT THAT OVERALL THE THE
TAKE AWAY WITH A LOT OF WORK TO
DO.
IN YEAR TWO GOING FORWARD YOU
IDENTIFIED YOU KNOW A GREAT NEED
IN IN IN TERMS OF PSYCHIATRY --
WE WE DO KNOW THAT THE GOVERNOR
HAS PUT SOME MONEY IN THE BUDGET
FOR PSYCHIATRY I DON'T THINK I
KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS.
MAYBE THIS COMMITTEE WILL OFFER
INTEREST FOR PSYCHIATRY --
WORK FORCE MAYBE --
THAT'S A SOURCE BUT I I DO THINK
THAT THIS PROGRAM THE INTEGRITY
OF THE ADVISORY GROUP IN AND THE
THE BOARD IN UNIVERSITY OF
REALLY WORKED HARD. TO ESTABLISH
AT AT A GOOD PROGRAM AND
HOPEFULLY FROM YEAR TO YEAR TO
YEAR WILL BE ABLE TO BUILD ON
THE SUCCESSES I'M VERY PLEASED
WITH WHAT --
WITH THE PROGRESS THAT YOU MADE
AND YOU I MEAN.
THERE IS A NEED UP INTO A
TREMENDOUS NEED UP AND DOWN THE
STATE FOR PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIANS AND AND THOSE.
PRACTICE AREAS THAT ARE RELATED
TO THAT --
AND THERE'S NEVER ENOUGH MONEY
SO WE JUST.
NEED TO CONTINUE TO FIND
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES. TO FUND
ADDITIONAL RESIDENCY SLOTS
BECAUSE WHILE WE WILL HEAR ABOUT.
AN INITIATIVE OF MINE A LITTLE
BIT LATER HAVING TO DO WITH THE
MEDICAL SCHOOL BUILDING --
TURNING OUT --
TO THOSE WITH THROUGH TO
GRADUATE WITH A DOCTOR OF
MEDICINE DEGREE --
IS ONLY HALF OF THE SOLUTION AND
IF THEY DON'T FIND A RESIDENCY
PROGRAM AND HOPEFULLY THE THEY
FIND ONE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT IF THEY DON'T WE
MAY HAVE LOST THEM --
IN IN IN THIS STATE AND
CERTAINLY IN THE UNDERSERVED
AREAS SO.
THANK YOU FOR WHAT YOU DO
ABSOLUTELY NO YOU'LL TO MIGHT
HAVE.
OTHER PANELS --
OKAY ALL ALL ALL ALL BE BRIEF --
BUT IT IS PART OF MY
INTRODUCTION AND AN ADDITION TO
SERVING AS THE ASSOCIATE VICE
PRESIDENT FOR HEALTH SCIENCES.
SYSTEM WIDE THAT THAT INCLUDES
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ME TO WORK
CLOSELY WITH ALL OF OUR MEDICAL
SCHOOL DEANS AND WITH THE
LEADERSHIP IN OUR GMT PROGRAMS.
YOU SEE OPERATES ROUGHLY HALF OF
THE GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION
AND IN THE STATE.
I ALSO HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF
SERVING AS A GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEE ON THE SONG BROWN
COMMISSION I JUST WANT TO
UNDERSCORE ANGELUS COMMENT TO
THAT.
IN A VERY SHORT TIME LINE FROM
THE NORTH OF THE STATE TO THE
SOUTH FROM THE INLAND EMPIRE TO
THE COAST THOUGHT THIS FUNDING --
AND WE FELL A HUNDRED AND TEN
MILLION DOLLARS SHORT --
OF NEED I THINK WITH ANOTHER
YEAR OF AWARENESS ABOUT THESE
FUNDS THE VOLUME WILL WILL
DOUBLE.
I'M A SECOND POINT IS THAT --
CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY LEADS THE
NATION IN TERMS OF THE RETURN ON
THE INVESTMENT FOR PHYSICIANS TO
COMPLETE RESIDENCY TRAINING HERE
ACCORDING TO IT AMC STATS.
SO NOW LARGELY CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL.
SCHOOL APPLICANTS LIKE. TO SEEK
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MEDICAL
EDUCATION HERE WE EXPORT --
SO MANY STUDENTS FROM MANY
LISTINGS COME BACK HERE TO
COMPLETE THE RESIDENCY TRAINING
AND WHEN WE DO CALIFORNIA'S VERY
SUCCESSFUL IN RETAINING THESE
FOLKS AS PART OF OUR WORK FORCE
SO.
CLEAR NEED CLEAR RETURN ON
INVESTMENT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IN THE MORNING I'M MRS SHARE.
HERE TO SPEAK ON THE CHAIRS FOR
A CLASS IS ALLOCATED DISH NO
FUNDING DID YOU SEE OUR MEDICINE.
WE HAVE TO WAIT FOR THAT ISSUE
THAT WORKS I THINK WE'RE STILL
ON PROPOSITION.
FIFTY SIX RIGHT NOW OKAY I THINK
WHAT AS I'M LOOKING AT THE
AGENDA SO YOU TELL ME BUT IT
LOOKS TO ME LIKE.
WE'RE GONNA TALK --
WE'RE GONNA FINISH TALKING ABOUT
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE INTO THE PROGRAMS
IN MEDICAL EDUCATION PROGRAM THE
PRIME PROGRAM HOPEFULLY SOMEBODY
WILL TALK TO THAT --
HOPEFULLY SOMEBODY WILL TALK TO
THE PSYCHIATRY AT USE YOUR
TELEMEDICINE.
INITIATIVE AND THEN WE'LL GET --
TO BY --
INITIATIVE HAVING TO DO WITH THE
YOU SEE ARE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
SO OKAY SO I DO HAVE A COMMENT
ON HOW FIFTY SIX FIFTY SIX THANK
YOU.
AND I JUST WANT --
TO UNDERSCORE WHAT MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE ALREADY SAID [inaudible]
I THE SIDE AND AND THE DEAN AT
UC RIVERSIDE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE.
AND AS SHIA NARROW AND THE
INLAND EMPIRE THERE REALLY IS A
DIRE NEED. FOR PHYSICIANS AS
WELL AS FOR RESIDENCY TRAINING
PROGRAMS.
AS KATHERINE --
SO ELOQUENTLY STATED.
WHEN WE?
EDUCATE THESE PHYSICIANS AND
KEEP THEM IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THEY'RE MORE LIKELY TO REMAIN.
AND I'LL GOAL IS.
TO EDUCATE.
HAVE TRAINING PROGRAMS FOR THEM.
IN THE INLAND EMPIRE.
SO THAT THEY WOULD LIKELY REMAIN
IN THE INLAND EMPIRE WHERE THERE
IS A DIRE NEED FOR POSITION.
I HOPE THEY DO.
WE DO NEED THEM.
OKAY IS THAT FINISH PROP
[inaudible]
FIFTY SIX ABOUT [inaudible]
OKAY -- LET
ME BEFORE I BEGAN ASK.
WHETHER.
YOU BY CHANCE WE HAVE COPIES.
I I'M.
FIVE WE'LL REFER TO THIS --
AS I PROVIDE A FEW HIGHLIGHTS A
AND I THINK I'D LIKE TO MAKE --
FIVE THE IMPETUS FOR OUR UC
PRIME PROGRAMS.
BEGAN ABOUT FIFTEEN YEARS AGO
AND IT WAS A STRATEGY --
FOR EXPANDING MEDICAL SCHOOL IN
ROMAN OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN DECADES SO THIS.
PREDATES THE TRANSITION MEDICINE
AND OUR OUR THINKING REALLY WAS
THAT WE COULD ACCOMMODATE SOME
GROWTH WITHIN EXISTING MEDICAL
SCHOOLS.
BECAUSE WE HAVE THE FULL
COMPLEMENT OF BASIC SCIENCES AND
CLINICAL SCIENCES AND
ACCREDITATION OF THOSE SCHOOLS.
BUT ONLY A LIMITED AMOUNT OF
GROWTH WOULD BE POSSIBLE BASED
UPON SPACING CAPITAL NEEDS --
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT THERE WAS
AN IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY FOR YOU
SEE -- TATE
DEVELOPED SOME INNOVATIVE
PROGRAMS THAT WE FELT --
WOULD SPEAK DIRECTLY TO THE
NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA'S MEDICALLY
WAS A STRATEGIC DECISION SYSTEM
WIDE DECISION.
WITH LOCA AUTHORITY BY THE
DEANS AND BY THE FACULTY AND WE
HAD SOME GRANT SUPPORT EARLY ON
TO ASSIST WITH PLANNING WE
VETTED THIS WITH OUR UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA LEADERSHIP AT THAT
TIME WITH WITH STATE LEADERSHIP
AT THAT TIME AND AGAIN THIS IS.
PRE RECESSION BUT IT WAS A
STRATEGIC AN INITIATIVE AGAIN
TAKE INCREASE CLASS SIZE BUT TO
DO IT IN A VERY DIFFERENT WAY --
WE WERE POST PROPOSITION TWO OH
NINE WE THOUGHT ABOUT THE
DIVERSITY OF THE STATE AND WE
THOUGHT ABOUT --
ELEMENTS OF PROGRAMS THAT WOULD
SEEK TO RECRUIT STUDENTS AND
THEN RETURN STUDENTS TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES OF GREATEST NEED.
SO WE IDENTIFIED --
SIX CORE ELEMENTS FOR EACH OF
OUR PRIME PROGRAMS YOU SEE THEM.
YOU SEE THEM LISTED IN TERMS OF
THEIR SPACE AND IN TERMS OF
THEIR NAME --
BUT WE ASK --
WITH THE PLANNING MONIES THAT
WERE PROVIDED FOR EACH DEAN'S
OFFICE. TO IDENTIFY A UNIQUE
AREA OF FOCUS THE STUDENTS TO
FACULTY TO OTHERS.
WE ASK EACH CAMPUS TO PLANT A
STUDENT OUTREACH --
AND RECRUITMENT STRATEGY TO SEEK
TO IDENTIFY STUDENTS --
LIKELY. TO WANT TO RETURN TO THE
COMMUNITY TO THE AREA OF FOCUS
THAT WE WERE LOOKING TO ADVANCE.
WE ASK -- I
DO A LOT OF WORK IN MEDICAL
SCHOOL ADMISSIONS AND KNOW THE
COMPLEXITY AND THE VOLUME.
SO WE ASK EACH PROGRAM TO
IDENTIFY SUPPLEMENTAL CRITERIA
MOST OF OUR PRIME STUDENTS HAVE
TO BE ADMITTED TO A UC MEDICAL
SCHOOL --
AND THEN THEIRSUPPLEMENTAL
CRITERIA TO ASSESS
QUALIFICATIONS TO BE ADMITTED TO
R. PRIME PROGRAMS I'M SO THIS IS
ABOUT STUDENT FIT.
ON WE WE ASK AND MINDFUL OF HOW
IMPACTED THE MEDICAL SCHOOL
CURRICULUM IS THERE ARE
INTENSIVE REQUIREMENTS AND WANT
TO STUDENTS TO SUCCEED.
I'M SO THIS IS NOT A REWRITE OF
THE CURRICULUM IT'S IT'S
INCREMENTAL ENHANCEMENT --
SO WE ASK --
THAT. FOR EACH PROGRAM HAND SMIT
IN THE PRECLINICAL YEARS THIS IS
ONE STUDENTS COMPLETE THEIR
BASIC SCIENCES SO EXAMPLES MIGHT
BE INSTRUCTION OR LECTURES ON
DISPARITIES IN HEALTH STATUS --
THERE IS AN EXAMPLE. FOR IRVINE
PROGRAM THAT FOCUSES ON THE
LATINO COMMUNITY THIS IF THIS
INCLUDED ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES IN IN MEDICAL
SPANISH --
IN THE CLINICAL CLERKSHIP HERE'S
THE THIRD AND FOURTH YEAR WE ASK
THAT SPECIAL ATTENTION BE MADE
TO PLACE OUR PRIME STUDENTS.
IN THOSE AREAS THAT WOULD END.
CREATE THEIR SKILL SET FOR
FUTURE PRACTICE IN THOSE
SETTINGS AND THEN WE ASK FOR
CLEAR FACULTY MENTOR SHIP THE
DECISION MAKING WAS LOCAL --
YOU'LL SEE EXAMPLES THAT ARE
LISTED THAT ARE HERE --
WE HAVE SIX PRIME PROGRAMS IN
THE UC SYSTEMNOW WITH A TOTAL
ENROLLMENT OF THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FOUR STUDENTS THIS IS OVER.
ALL PROGRAMS AND OVER ALL YEARS
OF THE PROGRAM SO MEDICAL
SCHOOLS A FOUR YEAR PROGRAM BY
AND LARGE.
AMONG THOSE.
STUDENTS 64% I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT --
THIS MOSTLY BECAUSE I LIVE IN
THIS SPACE BUT 64% OF THE
STUDENTS ARE UNDER REPRESENTED
IN MEDICINE.
SO THIS LOOKS LIKE --
A LEVEL OF DIVERSITY THAT IS
MUCH NEEDED IN A STATE LIKE
CALIFORNIA BUT IT BUT THAT IS
REALLY HE SELDOM SEEN.
AMONG U. S. MEDICAL SCHOOLS AND
WE ATTRIBUTE THIS TO THE
IDENTITY OF THE PROGRAM AND WE I
ATTRIBUTED.
TO OUTREACH AND TO THE ELEMENTS
THAT I'VE DESCRIBED FOR EACH SO
I I WON'T GO INTO DETAILS FOR
EACH.
BUT OUR ROLE PRIME PROGRAMS AT
DAVIS IS ALIGNED WITH THE
MISSION OF THE DAVIS MEDICAL
SCHOOL STUDENTS ARE RECRUITED
FROM RURAL NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
PROGRAMS AS AN OUTREACH STRATEGY.
STUDENTS GET TAUGHT ABOUT
DISPARITIES FACING RURAL
COMMUNITIES STUDENTS GET
PREFERENTIAL --
INSTRUCTION IN TELEMEDICINE IS A
STRATEGY FOR INCREASING THEIR
SKILL SET --
WE HAVE A PRIME LC PROGRAM DOWN
AT UCI THE FIRST IN THE SYSTEM --
TOP OPEN WHERE --
STUDENTS ARE ADMITTED TO THE
MEDICAL SCHOOL.
BUT THEN HAVE SOME TYPE OF
INTERVIEW IN SPANISH TO ASSESS
BASIC PROFICIENCY STUDENTS DO
THEIR CLERKSHIPS IN MONO OR
BILINGUAL SPANISH SPEAKING
SETTINGS.
ON OUR MOST RECENT PRIME PROGRAM
IS A GEOGRAPHICALLY NAME PROGRAM --
FOR THE FAN WALKING VALLEY ON
THAT PROGRAM HAPPENS TO HAVE
BENEFITED BY THE LEADERSHIP OF
ITS MEMBER GRAY WHO SECURED
FUNDING FOR THAT PARTICULAR
PROGRAM IN THE FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
YEAR. FOR THE FOR THE FUNDING
PREDICAMENT --
PROBLEM IS --
IS SHOWN HERE ON PAGE
[inaudible]
TWO AND SO.
AS WE BEGAN. TO LAUNCH AN ENROLL
STUDENTS WE WE HAVE TO TELL OUR
ACCREDITING BODY WE HAVE TO TELL
THE LCM YOU WERE PLANNING TO
INCREASE CLASS SIZE.
WE HAD -- TO
BEGIN TO RECRUIT THERE WAS A LOT
OF INVESTMENT IN THE TWO OR
THREE YEARS LEADING TO THE
ENROLLMENT OF THE FIRST CLASS.
AND THEN THE STATE'S ECONOMY
BEGAN TO UNRAVEL ON SO THAT THE
MISSION WAS GOOD THE AIM WAS
GREAT THE ENTHUSIASM WAS HIDE
THE ECONOMIC CIRCUMSTANCES.
DID NOT ALIGN EIGHT IN ANY
FAVORABLY WAY SO OUR SCHOOL'S
MOVE FORWARD KID MET THEIR FIRST
CLASSES OF PRIME AS THEY WERE
READY AS THEY NOTICED THE
CREDITORS AS THEIR FACULTY WERE
PREPARED AS THEY WERE READY TO
ADMIT -- AND
AND WHAT.
HAPPENED AGAIN IS SORT OF SHOWN
HERE THE FIRST PRIME PROGRAM IN
TWO THOUSAND ON AND SOMEBODY --
WAS A SEVEN I THINK IT'S SEVEN
MAYBE IT WAS SIX WITH IT WAS THE
FIRST THAT WE HAD DAVIS SAN
FRANCISCO AND SAN DIEGO IN
ROLLING THEIR FIRST CLASSES.
AND WE HAD THREE YEARS OF PLAN
FUNDING SO WE WE CAME TO THE
STATE.
FUNDING AS OUR CLASS SIZES
INCREASED THESE WERE INTENDED TO
BE TWELVE STUDENTS TO FIFTEEN
STUDENTS PER CLASS IN PRIME.
WE MOVE FORWARD WITH THAT
MISSION AND AND THEN YOU SEE THE
EFFECTS OF OF THE STATE BUDGET
AND MULTI YEAR CUTS IN UC
FUNDING FOR HIGHER ED OVERALL SO
WE'VE BEEN FROZEN WE RECOGNIZE
THE NEED TO COME BACK TO SECURE
THIS FUNDING --
AND THEY'RE OF SIMPLY BAN.
AN ENSUING NUMBER OF DIFFICULT
BUDGET YEARS AND COMPETING
PRIORITIES --
FOR FOR THE STATE AND FOR THE
SYSTEM -- SO
WE HAVE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
REGULAR SLOTS THE THESE ARE
ESTABLISHED PROGRAMS --
WE'VE GRADUATED FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY STUDENTS --
TO DATE BUT ONLY SEVENTY EIGHT
OF OUR TOTAL COMPLEMENT OF PRIME
POSITIONS ACROSS.
OUR SYSTEM --
HAVE THE BENEFIT OF GENERAL FUND
SUPPORT SO THIS IS MARGINAL
GENERAL FUND SUPPORT FOR MEDICAL
STUDENTS WHICH IS A HIGHER RATE.
THAN FOR UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS
IT DOES NOT COVER THE COST OF
INSTRUCTION THE STUDENTS STILL
PAY TUITION.
PROFESSIONAL GRADE SUPPLEMENTAL
TUITION AND MANY STILL END UP
WITH SUBSTANTIAL DEBT TO HELP SO
THE FUNDING RIGHT NOW GIVEN THE
STATE OF THE BUDGET IN THE PAST
AND WITH THEM THE FUNDING LEVELS
THAT YOU RECEIVED.
HOW ARE ALL OF THE PRIME SO IT'S
FUN IS IT DOES IT COME OUT OF
THE WHOLE SYSTEM?
NOW MONEY ON IT YOU KNOW IT
COMES FROM YOU KNOW WE WE
INVESTED --
POLITICAL CAPITAL WITH
FOUNDATIONS AS THESE PROGRAMS
WERE LAUNCHED.
THERE WITH LOCAL ENTHUSIASM
THERE WAS DEAN'S LEVEL
COMMITMENT TO TO MOVE FORWARD
THERE WAS THE HOPE OF RETURNING
ANNA.
I DON'T THINK ANY NEAR TERM
OPTIMISM IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
THAT THE RECESSION WAS ABOUT TO
END -- BUT
WE FELT IT WAS IMPORTANT TO KEEP
A CRITICAL MASS OF IDENTITY.
SO.
SOME MEDICAL SCHOOLS HAVE --
PHILANTHROPIC SUPPORT
CALIFORNIAN DOWNS MINUTES FOR
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION IS NOT A SUPPORTER
SOME HAVE HAD --
DEAN'S RESERVES.
SOME SCHOOLS DECREASE THEIR CORE
CLASS SIZE TO ACCOMMODATE A
CRITICAL MASS OF PRIME STUDENTS
IT'S BEEN A COMBINATION.
AND IT'S BEEN A I YOU KNOW IT'S
BEEN A NEGOTIATION I WILL SAY.
AT TIMES OF LEADERSHIP CHANGE AT
TIMES OF ECONOMIC STRESS ARMS
WHAT'S IN NEEDED IS TO SUSTAIN
THE PROMINENT INCREASING CLASS
SIZE THAT WE THOUGHT.
WHICH IS VERY SIMILAR TO THE
ISSUE THAT WILL BE TALKING ABOUT
WITH WITH YOU SEE OUR AND TO NOT
HAVE THE FUNDS AT RISK OF
COMPETING PRIORITIES.
JUST AS A AS A AS A DEDICATED --
PART OF USING ICLOUD WAS SEEMS
LIKE AN ESSENTIAL PROGRAM OF THE
THE EIGHT POINT EIGHT MILLION
THAT'S REFERENCED IN THE AGENDA
WILL THAT FULLY FUND THE IT IT
WILL FORM THE TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SLOT SYSTEM WIDE THAT HAVE
NO GENERAL FUND SUPPORT.
IT'LL FIND THOSE SLOTS AT A
LEVEL OF THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER STUDENT WHICH DOES
NOT COVER THE COST OF MEDICAL
EDUCATION.
THIS WAS THE LAST RECOGNIZED
FIGURE -- BY
THE STATE THEY CAME IN
CONNECTION WITH THE FUNDING FOR
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY PRIME PROGRAM.
SO OUR SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY PRIME
PROGRAM BENEFITS --
THROUGH A STATE BUDGET
AUGMENTATION FOR TWELVE STUDENTS
PER YEAR WHICH IS THE SIZE OF
MOST OF OUR PRIME PROGRAMS
ACROSS FOUR YEARS MAKING IT.
FORTY EIGHT SO THERE'S THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND SO WE USE THAT AS
A BASELINE FOR MARGINAL COST
INCREASES.
SO THIS WILL SECURE THE PROGRAMS
IN PERPETUITY IN ADDITION TO
THOSE FUNDS STUDENTS PAY --
PROFESSIONAL DEGREE SUPPLEMENTAL
TUITION TWO THIRDS OF WHICH IS
USED TO SUPPORT INSTRUCTION IN
THIS PROGRAM IT'S THE SAME
AMOUNT PAID BY ALL YOU SEE
MEDICAL STUDENTS IN THE RANGE OF
EIGHTEEN TO NINETEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR.
A THIRD OF WHICH IS RETURNED TO
AID.
SEEMS LIKE A MODEST REQUEST TO
ME.
IT'S A MODEST REQUEST BY ANY
MEANS AND MIGHT BE USED YOUR
STRATEGIC PLANS TO THEY INCLUDE --
AN EXPANSION OF MAYBE REFERENCES.
BLOW THROUGH MY HEAD THE NEXT.
EXPANSION THE PRIME PROGRAM IN
THE FUTURE SO THERE ARE A COUPLE
OF THINGS AND I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION I WANT I WANT TO BE
MINDFUL OF TIME --
ARE THE FUNDING REQUEST OF EIGHT
THAT CORRESPONDS TO THE TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY ON FUNDED
SLOTS WAS INCLUDED IN THE
UNIVERSITY'S FORMAL FUNDING
REQUEST WAS INCLUDED IN THE
REGION'S BUDGET --
UNFORTUNATELY IT WAS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BUDGET --
OUR HOPE TODAY IS FOR THIS
COMMITTEE SUPPORT TO INCLUDE
THAT FUNDING REQUEST AS THE
REGIONS HAVE REQUESTED IT.
THERE IS --
CONSIDERABLE INTEREST I WILL SAY
MY MANY STAKEHOLDERS IN SEEING
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
EXPAND --
I'M OPPORTUNITIES THROUGH EITHER --
INCREASES EXISTING PROGRAMS FOR
DEVELOPMENT OF NEW PROGRAMS SO
YOU'LL YOU'LL NOTICE ON THE
FRONT PAGE OF THIS THAT WE DON'T
HAVE A PRIME FOR EVERY NEED AND
THERE'S CONSIDERABLE NEED IN THE
STATE.
AND IT WAS A FUNCTION OF OF OF
DECISION MAKING OUT THAT SIDE AT
THAT TIME SO WE HAVE ONE THAT'S
REGIONALLY IDENTIFIED WE COULD
CERTAINLY HAVE MORE THAN.
ONE WORLD PRIME MORE THAN ONE
URBAN PRIME WE DON'T HAVE ALL
PRIME --
THERE HAVE BEEN DISCUSSIONS --
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
ABOUT A PRIME PROGRAM FOR UC
RIVERSIDE UC RIVERSIDE BEFORE IT
BECAME AN INDEPENDENT MEDICAL
SCHOOL HAD A VERY SMALL PRIME
PROGRAM IN CONJUNCTION WITH UCLA.
HI HOW ARE YOU FEELING SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE WITH THE LAST PROGRAM
TO OPEN ITS PRIME PROGRAM AND
THEREFORE HAS NO FUNDING FOR ITS
PRIME PROGRAM IN ENTIRETY --
WHEN THE RIVERSIDE PROGRAM
OPENED THE MISSION WAS CLEARLY
ALL ALIGNED WITH THE MISSION OF
PRIME SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED ON
THE MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED NEEDS
OF THE INLAND EMPIRE?
AND I THINK THE DECISION AT THAT
TIME WAS TO NOT SUSTAIN A SMALL
FOR STUDENT PROGRAM TIME THE
SCHOOL WAS ATTEMPTING TO
ESTABLISH ITSELF INDEPENDENTLY.
SO WE HAVE HAD OPPORTUNITIES TO
TALK ABOUT A PRIME PROGRAM
INCLUDING AN AREA OF FOCUS AND
HOW THAT MIGHT WORK --
I I SPENT A HALF A DAY A COUPLE
OF WEEKS AGO WITH THE DEAN AND
HER SENIOR TEAM TALKING ABOUT
THAT.
THERE IS INTEREST IN A POSSIBLE
EXPANSION OF PRIME PROGRAM IN
CONNECTION WITH THE JOINT
MEDICAL PROGRAM --
THEY COULD HAVE SOME EXPANSION
AND COULD BE A UNIQUE --
ADDITION SO THIS WOULD BE A TWO
YEAR THIS WITH AND FOLLOW --
IF IF THERE WERE THE WISHES AND
I THINK THE CALIFORNIA FUTURE
HEALTH COMMISSION WAS A ON
ANOTHER AMONG THOSE ENTITIES
THAT WANTED TO SEE.
SOME CAPABILITY TO GROW BEYOND
THE CURRENT ENROLLMENT IN OUR
PRIME PROGRAM AND OUR OUR VIEW
REALLY WAS.
AT THE CAMPUS LEADERSHIP LEVEL
AND IN OAKLAND AND WITH THE
PRESIDENT'S SUPPORT THAT OUR
FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS NEEDED
TO SECURE AND NEEDED TO BE TO
SECURE AND TO SUSTAIN THE SPOTS.
AND THEN TO TAKE A YEAR TO TO
SEE WHAT NUMBER OF POSITIONS AND
AREAS MAY BE POSSIBLE --
SO THAT COULD THAT COULD BE MET
WITH THE YEAR TWO FUNDING
REQUEST THAT WE BE HAPPY TO
ENTERTAIN BUT PARTICULARLY
FOCUSED ON RIVERSIDE DRIVE
MEDICAL PROGRAMS SOME
INCREMENTAL EXPANSION WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
HAVE THESE CONVERSATIONSBECAUSE
OF THE NEED IS BEYOND GREAT.
AND IT'S BEYOND GREAT UP AND
DOWN THE STATE AND I KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATION REALIZES THAT AND
AS THE PRIOR ADMINISTRATION --
DID -- WE'RE
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO AT SOME
POINT -- AS
THE EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY END --
BUILD THE BASIC SCIENCE AND AND
RESEARCH CAPABILITY WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW.
TO DEAL WITH THE THE THE THE
MEDICAL SCHOOL NEEDS OF OF THAT
REGION AND I KNOW.
MY COLLEAGUES IS CERTAINLY IN IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND NOW IN THE IN
THE SENATOR INTERESTED IN
EXPLORING THAT AND I DO THINK
THAT'S AN ISSUE THAT WE WILL
HAVE.
TO EXPLORE A BABY STEPS FIRST
AND PERHAPS THE EXPANSION OF THE
PRIME PROGRAM IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY -- AS
IT APPEARS APPROPRIATE --
WOULD BE THE ONE OF THE FIRST
STEPS ALONG WITH MAYBE A A
BIOMEDICAL SCIENCE PROGRAM AND
IN THE UC INSTITUTION UP THERE
AS THE AS THE FACILITY IN THE
FACULTY CAN PERMIT THAT BUT
FIRST THINGS FIRST --
I'M CLEARLY --
INTERESTED IN THIS REQUEST AND
CLEARLY INTERESTED IN THE PRIME
PROGRAM AND WE WILL.
TAKE THAT UP AT THE APPROPRIATE
POINT TIME.
ANYTHING ELSE ON PRIME --
FINANCE ILIO YOU'LL SPEAK UP IF
YOU HAVE SOMETHING TO SAY.
OKAY PERFECT CAN I ADD ONE THING --
THE CALIFORNIA FUTURE HEALTH
WORKFORCE COMMISSION WHICH IS
NOT THE FOCUS OF OUR DISCUSSION
TODAY.
ISSUED ITS FINAL REPORT --
IN FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR IT
CENTERS ON THE WORKFORCE NEEDS
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
MY SERVED AS THE PRESIDENT PAUL
CAMAS EXECUTIVE ADVISER FLOYD
DEAN WHO IS THE CEO AND
PRESIDENT OF COMMON SPIRIT
HEALTH NOW PREVIOUSLY DIGNITY ON
I'M.
THE NEW NAMES ON IT IT'S NOT
THAT IS FLUENT YET BUT THIS WAS
TWO YEARS OF DELIBERATION
INCLUDED HIGHER ED LEADERSHIP
FROM THE ISSUE.
FROM THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
INCLUDED HEALTH WORKFORCE
EXPERTISE.
WITH A TECHNICAL ADVISORY
COUNCILS --
AT AND WORKING COMMITTEES
SUPPLEMENTED WITH A LOT OF
EXPERTISE.
IN THE TOP TEN RECOMMENDATIONS
ON THAT COMMISSION --
AND NOTEWORTHY AND I'M CERTAINLY
HAPPY FOR IT WAS SUPPORTED THIS
FUNDING REQUEST FOR PRIME JUST.
AND THIS COMES FROM THE
STANDPOINT OF COMMUNITY LEADERS
REGIONALLY WHO HAVE KNOWN THE
COME THROUGH TRAINING RETURN TO
THESE AREAS --
SO HEART WARMING FOR ME TO SEE
THIS IN THE TOP --
TEN RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
COMMISSION NOT IN THE TOP --
TEN BUT BUNDLED TOGETHER WERE
RECOMMENDATIONS RELATED TO
FURTHER EXPANSION OF PRIME
PROGRAMS AS YOU NOTED THIS
MORNING --
SECURING THE SUCCESS OF THE AND
LOOKING TO BUILD THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR MEDICAL
EDUCATION IN THE VALLEY WHICH
YOU ALSO JUST MENTIONED SO
THAT'S NOTED IN THE COMMISSION --
AND ALSO A TOPIC OF INTEREST
RESEARCH AND AND I'M SURE WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS AND HOPEFULLY
THEY'LL BE.
PRODUCTIVE FROM A BUDGET
STANDPOINT --
AS WE MOVE FORWARD --
PSYCHIATRY GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION IN TELEMEDICINE.
WHO HAS THAT [inaudible]
I GUESS.
WATCH TORNADO WATCH TO MY RIGHT.
AND BY THE WAY THANK YOU.
I DON'T HEAR THAT VERY OFTEN.
THAT VERY WELL MAY BE --
REGARDING --
PSYCHIATRY IN TELEMEDICINE --
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT
INCLUDED FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL PHONE ONE TIME --
TO SUPPORTS --
POST GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION
AT UC RIVERSIDE TO ENSURE THAT --
UNDER SERVED EGIONS OF THE
STATE ROLE AREAS WERE ABLE TO
RECEIVE --
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTED TOGETHER A
HEALTH WERE FORCED TO ADDRESS
THOSE --
PLACARD TREE AND MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS.
ALL YOU WANT TO WANT TO LEAVE.
SO -- I
WOULD JUST LIKE --
TO ADD TO THAT AGAIN THANKS SO
MUCH FOR THE FUNDING THAT WENT
TO UC OUR SCHOOL OF MEDICINE FOR
TELEMEDICINE.
WE RECOGNIZE AND OF COURSE HE
DID HIS THAT IT WAS SUCH A DIRE
NEED.
AND AS SUCH ONCE WE RECEIVE THE
FUNDING WE WASTED NO TIME TO
BEGIN TO IMPLEMENT --
THE PROPOSAL THAT WE SUBMIT IT.
AND I'M PLEASED TO INFORM YOU
TODAY THAT AS OF JULY ONE THIS
YEAR WE WILL --
HAVE THE ADDITIONAL RESIDENTS TO
ADDITIONAL RESIDENTS IN THE
PSYCH HI SHERRY.
PROGRAM.
APRIL OF THIS YEAR --
WE WILL HAVE RESIDENTS WHO WILL
BEGAN TO ROTATE AND THE U. C. R.
I. PSYCH HI SHAY SWEET FOR
TELEMEDICINE.
WHERE THOSE RESIDENTS HAVE WILL
BE TRAINED AND TELEMEDICINE
UNDER THE SUPERVISION OF
ATTENDING PHYSICIANS WE THOUGHT --
INITIATED AN AFFILIATION
AGREEMENT WITH EISENHOWER IN
RANCHO MOAMMAR MIRAGE.
AND THAT WILL LIKELY LEAD TO
SOME HELLO PSYCH HI SHERRY IN
THE AREA AS WELL.
IN OUR PSYCH HIGH SHE SWEET WE
HAVE -- A
HIGH UP.
THAT WE CALL THE TELEMEDICINE
HOW ODD AND WE HAVE ALREADY
BEGUN TO OPERATE AND WE ARE
PROVIDING CARE TO PLAN A KERR --
STAYS SALUTE DAY --
PLATT BLOW.
AND THEY'RE RECEIVING CARE
THROUGHS TELL PSYCH HYPHAE
ALREADY.
WE'VE ALSO ENGAGED IN HEALTH
CENTERS.
IN THE COACHELLA VALLEY AS WELL
AS AN AERIAL COUNTY AND THEY
WILL BE RECEIVING TELEMEDICINE.
YOU CAN SAY THAT WE WERE EXCITED
ABOUT THIS AND BECAUSE WE WASTED
NO TIME.
AND WE HAVE A TRAINING
AFFILIATION THAT'S IN PROGRESS
WITH -- SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY WHERE WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE AN AFFILIATION
WITH INDIAN HEALTH.
AGAIN TO PROVIDE --
TELEMEDICINE.
WHERE ALSO IN DISCUSSIONS WITH A
RIVERSIDE BASE TIME OLIVE CREST
WHICH IS A NON PROFIT DEDICATED
TO PREVENTING CHALABI'S?
AND TREATING ADDRESS.
NOT ONLY WILL WE PROVIDE
SERVICES ON THE GROUND BUT WE'LL
HAVE HELEN PSYCH HI FI SERVICES
THERE AS WELL.
SO THE RESOURCES THAT HAVE BEEN --
GIVEN.
I BEANS USED AND USED IN A VERY --
WEISS WAY AND PROVIDING FOR THE
NEEDS THAT WE EXPLICITLY
DELINEATE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK YOU FOR
STEPPING OUT SO SMARTLY WITH --
YOUR EFFORTS --
WITH THIS FUNDING IN THE
PROGRAMS I MEAN THE I'M NOT A
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER NO.
A BUT MY UNDERSTANDING IS --
THE THE NEED FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES PARTICULARLY IN THE
DESERT AREAS OF IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EASTERN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY IN.
SAN BERNADINO COUNTY AND
CERTAINLY IMPERIAL COUNTY --
IS IS EXTRAORDINARY AND DOES
THIS TELL US I CRIED REPROGRAM --
AND MOBILE UNITS AND THE LIKE
REALLY.
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO BE A GAME
CHANGER. FOR YOUNG AND OLD TOO
BADLY NEED --
THOSE SERVICES IN THOSE AREAS SO
SECOND FIRST.
THANK YOU FOR STEPPING OUT MA'AM.
NO ALL OF JUST --
TO UNDERSCORE OUR EARLIER
CONVERSATION THAT.
IN ORDER FOR THE RIVERSIDE
PSYCHIATRY PROGRAM TO DOUBLE IN
SIZE WHICH IS IN AN IMPRESSIVE
CHANGE ONE YEAR TO THE NEXT.
ON WE HAVE NATIONAL CREDITORS
THERE WERE NO FIRE A LOT OF
EVIDENCE AND SO FOR THIS
EXPANSION TO OCCUR --
ALL AND ALONG WITH THAT GROWTH
AND PSYCHIATRIC FELLOWSHIP
PROGRAMS WHICH ARE PLANNED.
CHILD ADOLESCENT HEALTH
GERIATRICS --
PSYCHIATRIC HELP THE DESIGNATED
SUBSPECIALTIES THE ACGME WHICH
ACCREDITS ACCREDITS US RESIDENCY
TRAINING PROGRAMS.
REQUIRES DEMONSTRATION OF
CLINICAL NIDA AND SENATOR ROBB
YOU SPOKE TO THAT THERE'S HUGE
NEED IN THE REGION --
BROADLY ALSO REQUIRE PROOF OF
ADEQUATE RESOURCES TO FIND --
RESIDENTS TO PAY SALARIES TO PAY
BENEFITS TO SUPPORT FACULTY FOR
TEACHING WITHOUT THESE DOLLARS
THAT GROWTH --
IN THE SIZE OF THESE PROGRAMS
WHICH WILL ADD TO NEW PROVIDERS
WOULD NOT AT ALL THE POSSIBLE.
WELL I I LOOK I KNOW I SPEAK FOR
MY COLLEAGUES --
IN SAYING WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
COURT -- AND
THE OUTCOMES --
I KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO BE
SUCCESSFUL BUT I LOOK FORWARD TO
TO THAT REPORT I THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE SPECTACULAR.
ANYTHING FURTHER ON PSYCHIATRY
UNTIL PSYCHIATRY JIMMY.
OKAY.
I THINK DEAN EURON.
THANKS TO TALK ABOUT.
MY INITIATIVE.
FIRST AND FOREMOST UC RIVERSIDE
IS SUPPORTIVE OF THE CHAIRS
REQUESTS TO ALLOCATE THAT DISH
NO FUNDING TO YOU SEE ARE SCHOOL
OF MEDICINE.
THIS FUNDING WILL POSITION THE
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE TO NEARLY
DOUBLE ITS CAPACITY FROM TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TO FIVE
HUNDRED MEDICAL STUDENTS.
BY INCREASING THE ONGOING
OPERATING REVENUE BY TWENTY FIVE
MILLION AND PROVIDING EIGHTY
MILLION TO HELP THE SCHOOL MAKE
THE NECESSARY INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS. TO MEET THE
CAPACITY DEMANDS THE YOU SEE ARE
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE IS
ESSENTIALLY CAPPED AT SEVEN P.
INCOMING MEDICAL STUDENTS EACH
YEAR.
DUE TO OUR UNDER FUNDED STATUS
AND SMALL EDUCATION FACILITY.
MOST MEDICAL SCHOOLS AND ROLL
MORE THAN A HUNDRED MEDICAL
STUDENTS EACH YEAR.
THE MEDICAL SCHOOL THAT I CAME
FROM AND ROLLED A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FIVE MEDICAL STUDENTS
EVERY.
THE YOU SEE ARE SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE NEEDS TO GROW IN ORDER
TO MEET THE PHYSICIAN WORKFORCE
NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA AND INLAND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ARE THE
INLAND EMPIRE.
THE ASSOCIATION OF AMERICAN
MEDICAL COLLEGES WHICH HAS.
THE ADMINISTRATION OVER ALL OF
THE US MEDICAL SCHOOLS AS WELL
AS CANADIAN MEDICAL SCHOOLS.
PLACES YOU SEE ARE SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE IN THE BOTTOM TWENTY
FIRST PERCENTILE AMONG PUBLIC
MEDICAL SCHOOLS IN TERMS THAT
ESTIMATED STATE FUNDING.
WE EXPAND SIXTY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER STUDENT FROM STATE
GENERAL FUND.
WHICH IS SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER
THAN THE NATIONAL AVERAGE OF A
HUNDRED THOUSAND FOR COMMUNITY
BASED MEDICAL SCHOOL.
THE FUNDING NEEDS OUTLINED IN SP
FIFTY SIX ALIGN WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
CALIFORNIA FUTURE HEALTH
WORKFORCE COMMISSION.
THE COMMISSION IN PART CALLED
FOR INCREASED.
PERMANENT OPERATION RED BRAIDING
RESOURCES TO EXPAND THE UC OUR
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE SO IN ROLE
MEN AND A CAPITAL INVESTMENT TO
AN ABLE TO GROW.
THIS COMMISSION AS CATHERINE
STATED ALREADY WAS CO CHAIRED BY
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
PRESIDENT JANET NOT POLISHED
HONDA.
AND MISS THE LLOYD DEAN AND THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF DIGNITY
HEALTH.
AND INCLUDED EXPERTS IN HELL
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND
EDUCATION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
SP FIFTY SIX THANK YOU DEAN FOR
YOUR SUPPORT I ALSO WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE SENATOR
CONNIE LEIVA WHO --
SURE THE EDUCATION POLICY
COMMITTEE THAT HEARD THIS BILL
YESTERDAY AND WITH HER SUPPORT
WE MADE IT OUT AND I ALSO WANT
TO THANK --
USE UPN YOU SEE I KNOW THIS IS
NOT.
A YOU'RE A UC INITIATIVE BUT YOU
HAVE BEEN SUPPORTIVE AND AND DO
YOUR SUPPORT TO ENABLE THE NAVAL
MY TEAM TO PUT TOGETHER OF THE
INITIATIVE AND I APPRECIATE THAT.
ANY FURTHER COMMENTS ON ISSUE
NUMBER SIX FROM THE PANEL.
JUST CLOSE WITH ONE YES MA'AM --
SO WE JUST --
APPRECIATIVE --
TO YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
AGAIN ECHOING THE WORK CONNECTED
WITH THE COMMISSION JUST
RECOGNIZING THE SUCCESS AND
OUTCOMES OF THE RIVERSIDE SCHOOL
OF MEDICINE TO DATE.
AND BEGIN DURING VALUE FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA OF INVESTING
IN SCALING THIS MEDICAL SCHOOL --
THE REASON US MEDICAL SCHOOLS
DON'T HAVE SEVENTY STUDENTS PER
CLASS IS IS BECAUSE THE COST OF
MEDICAL EDUCATION IS HI.
AND YOU HAVE FIXED COSTS THAT
ARE SPREAD OVER TWO SMALL IN A
MOMENT SO THE REASON US MEDICAL
SCHOOLS LOOK LIKE ONE TWENTY
FIVE TO TWO HUNDRED STUDENTS.
ON IS TO LEVERAGE AND TO TEACH
AND AND TO SUSTAIN ARE YOU SEE
GRADUATION RATES AND RETENTION
RATES ARE ABOUT 99% WE HAVE SUCH
SMART STUDENTS THEY SUCCEED WHEN
THEY COME.
WITH A WORTHY ON IT'S A WORTHY
INVESTMENT --
PRIME WAS THE FIRST STRATEGY YOU
SEE OUR WAS A NEXT STRATEGY AND
HE TURNED DIRE NEED OF YOU TURN
DIRE NEED OF FUNDING SO WE ARE --
WORKING ON A FORMAL LETTER OF OF
SUPPORT THROUGH THAT PROCESS --
AND IT WILL COME WITH OUR
REQUEST THE FUNDING FOR THE
RIVERSIDE SCHOOL MEDICINE IN
ADDITION TO THE FORMAL FUNDING
REQUEST ALREADY SUBMITTED BY THE
BORDER REGIONS THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT I DID NOT
KNOW THAT.
THANK YOU.
ANYTHING FURTHER FOR THE PANEL
YES MA'AM.
I'M.
AGAIN M. MISTER CHAIR I AM BACK
ON THE GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION ISSUE PROP FIFTY SIX I
WAS REMISS IN MENTIONING THAT
THE PHYSICIANS FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA MAY BE REPRESENTED
HERE IN THE AUDIENCE BT I DO
HAVE.
FACTSHEETS ATTITUDE TO HAVE THE
SERGEANT DISTRIBUTE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
AND SO.
THANK YOU SO THAT WAS THAT WAS
THAT WAS MY ACCOUNT THANKS FOR
YOUR COMMENT LET'S OPEN IT UP TO
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ISSUE IN
CASE ANYONE IS IN THE ROOM WHO
NEEDS TO LEAVE AND I CERTAINLY
WANT THE PANELISTS TO HAVE THE
BENEFIT OF ANY PUBLIC COMMENT
PRO.
OR CON SO PLEASE COME ON DOWN.
STATE YOUR NAME SIR MAX PERRY
WITH CITY OF RIVERSIDE SHOWING
OUR SUPPORT FOR S. B..
FIFTY SIX THANK YOU SIR.
YES MA'AM --
CARE MEMBERS AT JEAN HEARST HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF TWO CLIENTS
RIVERSIDE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
DISTRICTS.
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
EXPANSION THE USE YOUR MEDICAL
SCHOOL TO IMPROVE OUR MEDICAL
WORKFORCE IN CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU THANKS FOR
COMING.
BARBER GLASER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
ALSO HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY
SIX WE'RE SO PLEASED TO EXCEED.
TO SEE THIS EXPANSION OF THE
MEDICAL SCHOOL IN AN UNDERSERVED
AREA IT WILL GO A LONG WAY
TOWARDS ADDRESSING THAT THE
NEEDED WORK FORCE THERE.
AND ALSO IF I MIGHT SENATOR I'D
LIKE TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR
THE GMAT PROPOSAL THE PROP FIFTY
SIX DOLLARS GOING TO GRADUATE
MEDICAL EDUCATION WE WERE VERY
PLEASED TO SEE THAT IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY
SIR.
A GOOD MORNING VICTOR CHRISTY
WITH CALIFORNIA HELPLESS
ADVOCATES ADVOCATING ON BEHALF
OF CALVERT CALIFORNIA'S THIRTEEN
HUNDRED COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS
YOU WERE IN SUPPORT OF YOUR S.
B. FIFTY SIX THANK YOU SIR.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BOB ZERO AND
WE HAVE THE NATIONAL UNION
HEALTHCARE WORKERS ANY
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF PAINTERS
AND ALLIED TRADES.
WE SUPPORT THE REQUEST I WANT TO
SAY ON A PERSONAL NOTE SENATOR --
I'VE KNOWN YOU SINCE YOU WERE
CITIZEN ROT FOR THIRTY YEARS AND
THIS IS BEEN A LABOR OF LOVE FOR
YOU AND A LOT OF YOUR
CONTEMPORARIES IN RIVERSIDE AND
IT'S REALLY NICE TO SEE A DREAM
STARTED WITH YOUR PREDECESSOR
SENATOR PRESLEY AND THIS IS
REALLY A GREAT THING THAT.
YOU'RE DOING.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT SIR
YES MA'AM.
GOOD MORNING LOW BALANCE OF THE
S. PRESIDENCY --
PHYSICIANS FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA OBVIOUSLY VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE GOP PROPOSAL
AND WANTED TO I PERSONALLY THINK
THAT LEADERSHIP OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTNER WITH THEM.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
RUNNING A STRUCTURED MEMBERS
MEGAN ALL RIGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
JUST WANTED TO STATE THAT WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATORS COMMITMENT AND
ALLOCATING THE PROP FIFTY SIX
FUNDING FOR ITS INTENDED PURPOSE.
I AM TO SUSTAIN RETAIN AND
EXPAND GME IS LOTS AND MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED AREAS.
AND IN FURTHER AT PROMOTING THE
EXPANSION OF JIMMY INTO
UNDERSERVED AREAS WE LIKE TO
ALSO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR
YOUR INITIATIVE. TO ALLOCATE
FUNDING TO THE UC RIVERSIDE
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE WHICH WILL
BRING CRITICALLY NEEDED
RESOURCES TO THE SCHOOL AND THE
REGION.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND FOR THE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THIS ISSUE
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH FOR AN
EXCELLENT PANEL PANEL
PRESENTATION I APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME.
SAFE TRAVELS.
WHAT'S THE RETURN TO THE AGENDA
ORDER AND IT ISSUE NUMBER ONE IS
BUDGET OPERATIONS --
AS WE DISCUSSED IN A PREVIOUS
HEARING --
THE COVERS WHICH INCLUDES THREE
HUNDRED NINETY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND. FOR THE
UNIVERSE CALIFORNIA TWO INTERN
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS OF WHICH
IS ON GING. ONE HUNDRED
NINETEEN POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS OF THOSE FUNDS ARE FOR
CONTRACTUALLY OBLIGATED
COMPENSATION NON SELLER PRICE
INCREASES AND OTHER OPERATIONAL
COSTS.
THESE FINDINGS --
THIS FUNDING IS GOING TO ALLOW
YOU SEE TO MAKE TO MAKE
DECISIONS --
WITH ITS OTHER FUNDING SOURCES --
HOW TO BEST MEET ITS NEEDS AND
AND THE CHIEF STAPLES THANK YOU?
I'LL SPEAK TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AT THAT'S IN THIS ITEM --
REGARDING BUDGET OPERATIONS IF
YOU TURN TO PAGE SIX OF YOUR
AGENDA.
BY THAT PROVIDES THE BREAK OUT
OF THE HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING IS
THAT A HUNDRED NINETEEN HERE I
THINK THAT'S JUST AROUND IN YOUR
IN TRMS OF AND IT LOOKING AT
THIS TABLE YOU CAN SEE THAT.
A MOST OF THE FUNDING IS FOR
WHAT YOU MIGHT THINK OF OUR
BASIC COST INCREASES INCURRED BY
OF VARIOUS OF BENEFIT COST
INCREASES ALSO SOME.
EQUIPMENT AND UTILITY COSTS.
WE DON'T TAKE ISSUE WITH THOSE
ONE THING WE WOULD POINT OUT TO
THE COMMITTEE AS YOU'LL SEE THAT
THERE ARE SALARY INCREASES FOR
REPRESENTED EMPLOYEES.
THAT'S THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
AND IN THE UNIVERSITY EVER
INDICATES THAT THIS IS A MIX OF
SOME CONTRACTS THAT HAVE BEEN.
NEGOTIATED AND SOME CONTRACTS
ARE STILL UNDER NEGOTIATION SO
THIS IS AN ESTIMATE AND IN SOME
CASES --
WHAT YOU DON'T SEE HERE OUR
SALARY INCREASES FOR NON
REPRESENTED EMPLOYEES AND FOR
CONTEXT ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF CORE
FUNDED EMPLOYEES THAT YOU SEE
ARE?
NOT REPRESENTED AND THAT
INCLUDES ALL LATTER RAIN COULD
FACULTY THE TEN YEAR AND TENURE
TRACK.
AND MANY ADMINISTRATIVE STUFF.
ACCORDING TO THE MINISTRATION UC
HAS IDENTIFIED SOME NON STATE
RESOURCES THAT IT COULD BE USED
TO SUPPORT ADDITIONAL
COMPENSATION INCREASES AS IF IT
WOULD LIKE --
BUT THEY AREN'T EXPLICITLY
INCLUDING THAT IN THERE AND IT'S
IN THEIR BUDGET PROPOSAL.
AND YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL --
WE RECOMMEND YOU THINK ABOUT IT
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION ISSUES
ON THE MOTHER NOT THE UNIVERSITY
IS IS COMPETITIVE AND ATTRACTING
EMPLOYEES AND BASED ON THE DATA
YOU MIGHT.
AGREE WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
APPROACH OR THE COMMITTEE MIGHT
WANT TO TAKE A DIFFERENT
APPROACH AND AND FIND DIFFERENT
EMPLOYEE GROUPS ARE FUN MORE
EMPLOYEE GROUPS --
WE WOULD NOTE THAT THE
UNIVERSITY ARE NO LONGER.
COLLECTS --
A LOT OF THE RECORD TENSION DATA
CENTRALLY AND SO THE LEGISLATURE
DOESN'T HAVE ACCESS TO A LOT OF
THAT DATA UNFORTUNATELY WE DO
HAVE SOME DATA ON SALARY
COMPARISON SO FOR EXAMPLE WE
KNOW THAT.
YOU SEE FACULTY SALARIES ARE --
HIGHER ON AVERAGE THAN OTHER
PUBLIC HIGH RESEARCH
UNIVERSITIES DOESN'T THAT
SUGGEST THAT THEIR SALARIES
MIGHT BE.
SOMEWHAT COMPETITIVE BUT WITHOUT
MORE FURTHER IN FROM DATA ON HOW
WELL THE RECRUITING FACULTY HOW
ALL THE RETAINING THEM.
WE CAN'T UP OUR OFFICE CAN
PROVIDE FURTHER ANALYSIS ON THAT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MORNING YOU SEE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR ROTH AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE I AM SAY
OF IT THEN I'LL BE SPEAKING FOR
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TODAY --
I'VE BEEN ASKED BY THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT TO GIVE A VERY BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE UNIVERSITY'S
BUDGET YOU SHOULD HAVE IN FRONT
OF YOU THIS --
QUITE A STICK COLORFUL DAK AND
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THERE
ARE EXTRAS HERE ON THE ON THIS
STAND OVER HERE --
LET ME KNOW IF YOU WANT ME TO
SKIP OVER SOME OF THE OVERVIEW
BUT ON SLIDE.
TO SEE IF SOME BASICS OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA --
WE ARE TEN CAMPUS SYSTEM WITH
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS GOVERNED BY A BOARD OF
REGENTS AND A SYSTEM WIDE
PRESIDENT --
AND WE ALSO HAVE OUR ACADEMIC
SENATE MAKING WITH THE OF
ACADEMIC POLICIES FOR THE
UNIVERSITY.
ON SLIDE THREE YOU'LL SEE THE
YOU'LL SEE THE MISSION OF THE
UNIVERSITY WE ARE DRIVEN BY
QUALITY ACCESS AND AFFORDABILITY
THESE ARE THE FOUNDATIONAL
PRINCIPLES BASED ON WHICH THE
UNIVERSITY.
SEEKS TO MAKE OFF OF DECISIONS
TO ENROLL AND OUR POLICIES TO
GET STUDENTS THROUGH OUR SYSTEM --
ON SLIDE.
FOR YOU SEE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE UNIVERSITY'S IMPACT ON THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY AND ONE OF
THE THINGS I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
FOR YOU.
IS THAT OUR FACULTY BRING IN
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS AN EXTERNAL
GRANTS FOR BILLION OF THESE COME
FROM OUTSIDE OF THE STATE.
THAT OUR FACULTY BRING IN AND
THAT'S TO HELP STIMULATE THE
ECONOMY IS NEAR THE UC CAMPUSES.
AND ALSO OUR FACULTIES
INNOVATIONS AND PATENTS GO INTO
THE COMMUNITY AND HELP OUR
CREATE COMPANIES AND CREATE
ADDITIONAL JOB GROWTH JUST
BEYOND THE UNIVERSITY.
SO WE ARE A BIG A DRIVER OF THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY ON OUR OWN
FOR THOSE THE NON STATE FUNDS
THAT -- ARE
USED TO DEAL WITH SALARIES.
FOR TENURE TRACK CONTINUED
FACULTY.
A TENURE TRACK FACULTY SALARIES
COME LARGELY FROM STATE GENERAL
FUND BUT ARE THE GRANT FUNDING
ENDS UP PAYING FOR THEIR
RESEARCH AND UP SUPPORTING
GRADUATE STUDENTS AND ENDS UP
SUPPORTING POSTDOCS AND OUR LABS.
AND ALSO SOME OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S STAFF WHO HELPED
THE FACULTY IN APPLYING FOR
GRANTS.
AND MANAGING THE FUNDS RELATED
TO THOSE.
ON SLIDE FIVE YOU SEE THE TOTAL
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA BUDGET --
UC'S BUDGET THE TOTAL BUDGET FOR
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN IS ABOUT
THIRTY SIX AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS WONDERED IF THIS IS FOR
OUR MEDICAL CENTERS WHICH WE
WON'T BE DISCUSSING DOC MUCH
TODAY WE ARE WE'VE ALREADY HAD
THAT DISCUSSION WITH THE
PANELISTS WHO LEFT --
ANOTHER FOUR POINT FOUR BILLION
AS FOR THOSE CONTRACTS AND
GRANTS FOR THE RESEARCH.
AND THEN ANOTHER EIGHT BILLION
IS FOR OUR AXILLARIS THESE ARE
OUR SALES AND SERVICES WHAT WE
WOULD CALL THE DORMITORIES THE
PARKING TO FOOD SERVICES.
ON OUR CAMPUSES AND TODAY OUR
CONVERSATION WILL FOCUS ON WHAT
WE CALL OUR CORE FUNDS.
AND ON THE RIGHT HAND SIDE OF
THE PAGE TO SEE WHAT THOSE CORE
FUNDS ARE MADE UP OF IT'S ABOUT
NINE POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS.
OF ABOUT 40% OF THAT IS STATE
FUNDING --
ANOTHER THREE POINT EIGHT
BILLION IF COMES FROM STUDENT
TUITION AND FEES.
WE GET ALMOST ONE POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS FROM NON
RESIDENT SUPPLEMENTAL TUITION
PAID BY OUR NON RESIDENT
STUDENTS.
AND ANOTHER THREE HUNDRED
MILLION FROM A MISCELLANEOUS
REVENUES INCLUDING PATENT
REVENUE --
SOME CHARGES ON THE FEDERAL
CONTRACTS AND GRANTS THAT GETS
FUNNELED BACK FOR CAMPUS
SERVICES.
THE NON RESIDENT STUDENT PIECE
WAS ONE POINT ONE POINT THREE
BILLION [inaudible]
YEAH.
AND THEN WE'LL BE COVERING A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE STUDENT
FEES LATER ALL ALSO GOING TO
TALK MORE DETAIL --
YOU C. O. P. BUDGET IS ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED FORTY MILLION OUT
OF THAT A NINE POINT THREE
BILLION.
AND THEN THERE'S ANOTHER LARGE
CHUNK OUT OF THE ONE NINE POINT
THREE THAT IS NOT REALLY USABLE
FOR THE CAMPUSES.
THE UC PAYS OUT OF OUR OWN
BUDGET WE PAY GEO FONT DEBT
SERVICE AND WE CAN'T REDIRECT
THAT FOR OTHER PURPOSES.
WE ALSO --
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR STUDENT
FINANCIAL AID.
OF AND WE HAVE ANOTHER LARGE
COMPONENT THAT GOES TO OUR YOU
SEE RETIREMENT PROGRAM WHICH IS
OUR SELF CONTAINED RETIREMENT
PROGRAM FOR ALL YOU SEE
EMPLOYEES.
AND THOSE THREE COMPONENTS
TOGETHER TAKE UP ABOUT ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS OUT OF
THAT CORE FUNDS PIE. FOR USE ON
UP ACTUAL CAMPUS OPERATIONS.
ALL RIGHT SO.
I'D LIKE TO REVIEW ON SLIDE SIX
WITH YOU.
CAN YOU MEET.
THANKS FOR TOMORROW AS WELL YES
SIR JUST THOUGHT OF SOMETHING
HERE RIGHT RIGHT I NOTICED THAT --
WE HAVE SOME MINIMUM INFORMATION
THE CONCERNS ME YOU SEE HAS
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY BILLION
UNFUNDED PENSION RETIREE HEALTH --
LIABILITY SO IS THEIR WAY --
YOU GUYS HAVE SOMETHING TO
ADDRESS THAT.
WORKING TOWARDS THAT.
YES SIR YOUR CORRECT WE HAVE
ABOUT THIRTY BILLION DOLLARS IN
UNFUNDED LIABILITIES AT THE
MOMENT TEN BILLION OF THAT IS
FOR TO TRADITIONAL RETIREMENT
PROGRAM.
AND WE ARE CURRENTLY CHARGING OF
THE 6% OF ALL SALARIES OF FROM
THE CAMPUSES AND THAT 6% CHARGE
IS PLACED INTO THE USE THE R. P..
TOWARD THAT UNFUNDED LIABILITY
IN ORDER --
TO BUILD IT BUILD IT UP --
WE ARE MAKING PROGRESS ON THAT
WE'RE NOW IT'S 85% FUNDED SO WE
STILL HAVE THAT TEN BILLION
DOLLAR GAP WITH WHERE WE'RE
DOING FAIRLY WELL. 85% FUNDED --
WE THE LEGISLATURE WE HAVE
FORMED A WORKING GROUP --
INTERNALLY TO ADDRESS THE YOU
SEE -- THE
MEDICAL A RETIREMENT COMPONENT
OF STOCK WHICH IS ABOUT NINETEEN
BILLION AT THIS TIME --
WE WE HAVE NOT WE DON'T HAVE THE
SAME KIND OF SAVINGS SET ASIDE
TO PAY FOR RETIREE HEALTH WE PAY
FOR RETIREE HEALTH KIND OF ON A
PAY AS YOU GO BASIS --
HOWEVER WE ARE FACING THE PASTA
THE THE UPCOMING RETIREMENT OF A
LOT OF BABY BOOMERS.
WHO WILL BE RETIRING AND THEN
COLLECTING --
MEDICAL CARE FROM THROUGH THE
UNIVERSITY SO.
IT'LL TAKE YOU TO GET CAUGHT UP.
I DO NOT HAVE THAT NUMBER IN
FRONT OF ME I WILL GET THAT FOR
YOU -- THE
WORKING GROUP AS FAR AS I KNOW
IS STILL DEBATING OPTIONS.
OPTIONS TO CHANGE.
THE MEDICAL BENEFIT PROGRAM FOR
A PAY AS YOU GO TO SOMETHING
ELSE.
OUR E. BUT TOOK TO CREATE SOME
KIND OF SAVINGS SO THAT WE WE
HAVE A QUESTION AS AS EMPLOYEES
RETIRED THAT WE WE DON'T SEE A
RAPID INCREASE IN THE PAY AS YOU
GO.
LOOK YOU'RE MAKING GOOD PROGRESS.
YES WHAT WHAT WE'RE ON PENSIONS
MAY I MAKE A COMMENT.
WE'LL KEEP WILL KEEP YOU ON THE
SAME SUBJECT MATTER --
SO I REMAIN CONCERNED ABOUT THE
FOUR OH THREE B. PLAN WHICH IS
SIMILAR TO A FOUR OH ONE K. PLAN.
THAT YOU'RE OFFERING TO NEW
EMPLOYEES --
I REMAIN CONCERNED FOR TWO
REASONS. ONE IS A FOUR OH THREE
B. OR FOUR ONE K. PLAN PUTS ALL
THE RISK ON THE FUTURE RETIREE
BECAUSE IT'S DEPENDENT UPON THE
STOCK MARKET.
AND THEN SECONDLY WHAT I WORRY
ABOUT IS WHEN YOU HAVE NEW
PEOPLE COMING IN AND THEY DO NOT
THEY ARE PART OF A DEFINED
BENEFIT CONTRIBUTION.
IT HARMS THOSE THAT ARE IN THE
CONTRIBUTION.
BECAUSE THERE'S NO NEW REVENUE
BEING GENERATED AND AND BEING
PUT INTO THAT FUND.
NOW I UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S A
CHOICE BUT I JUST WORRY THAT THE
UC IS TRYING TO PHASE OUT THE
DEFINED BENEFIT PLAN.
AND WORK MORE WITH A FOUR OH
THREE B. R. FOUR ONE K. PLAN.
YES SENATOR I UNDERSTAND YOUR
CONCERNS --
CURRENTLY EMPLOYEES IF THEY DO
NOT MAKE A SELECTION TO A
DEFAULT THE TRADITIONAL PLAN.
OF ALSO WE ARE CHARGING ALL OUR
CAMPUSES THAT 6% OF EXTRA FEE ON
ALSO THOSE EMPLOYEE WHO GO INTO
THE FOR ONE CASE STYLE PLAN.
THAT GETS PUT INTO TO A
TRADITIONAL. TO THE DOOR I'M
BENEFIT TO THE DEFINED BENEFIT
PLAN. TO KEEP THAT PLAN HEALTHY
AND MAKE UP THAT SHORTFALL IN
FUNDING THERE CURRENTLY OKAY
THAT MAKES ME FEEL A LITTLE BIT
BETTER.
THANK YOU Q..
SORRY FOR THE INTERRUPTION BUT
THAT IT'S GOOD DAY SOMETIMES
IT'S GOOD TO BE ABLE TO ASK
QUESTIONS WHILE WE'RE ON THE
PARTICULAR SUBJECT BECAUSE IF
YOU'RE MY AGE YOU FORGET YOUR
QUESTIONS SO.
PLEASE ASK AT ANY POINT MY
PRESENTATION IS QUITE LONG AND
I'M GOING TO TRY TO GO THROUGH
IT PRETTY FAST TO KEEP US MOVING --
SO AS NOT TO KEEP YOU HERE ALL
pDAY BUT PLEASE ASK QUESTIONS AT
ANY TIME --
IS WHERE I SHOW THE R. REGIONS
HAVE BEEN CONTEMPLATING A NEW
BROAD FRAMEWORK OF OF A VISION
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OVER THE NEXT
TEN YEARS.
AND THE EMPHASIS OF THIS MISSION
IS TO MOVE AWAY FROM A YEAR TO
YOUR ENROLLMENT MANAGEMENT TO
OUTCOMES BASED APPROACH.
UP AND AT THE HEART OF THIS
VISION IS A DEEP COMMITMENT TO
THE CALIFORNIA DREAM AND
ENSURING THAT YOU SEE BOTH
MAINTAINS ACCESS.
AND PROVIDES THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SUCCEED TO ALL OF OUR STUDENTS
THIS VERSION INCLUDES AN
INVESTMENT IN OUR FACULTY WHO
MENTOR TO NEXT GENERATION OF
THOUGHT LEADERS.
AND GENERATE ECONOMIC GROWTH FOR
CALIFORNIA THROUGH THEIR
INVENTIONS AND THE GRANTS THEY
BRING TO THE STATE.
OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS THE
REGION'S MULTI YEAR PLAN WILL
INCREASE ENROLLMENT MODESTLY.
AND PRIMARILY FOCUS ON CLOSING-GRADUATION GAPS SHORTENING TIME
TO DEGREE AND BRING IN THOSE WHO
LEFT WITHOUT A DEGREE BACK FOR
COMPLETION.
YOU'LL SEE THEM THREE MAIN
ELEMENTS OF THE PLAN THERE.
AND THEN NEXT --
I THINK FINANCE COVERED SLIDE
SEVEN OF WHAT I WAS GOING TO
COVER ON SLIDE SEVEN QUITE WELL
BUT JUST TO MENTION THAT THE
CALIFORNIA.
THE GOVERNOR STANTON BUDGET
PROVIDES YOU SEE WITH A TOTAL OF
THREE HUNDRED NINETY THREE
MILLION OF WHICH TWO HUNDRED
FORTY IS ONGOING.
AND ON SLIDE EIGHT YOU'LL SEE
THE ONE TIME LATER ON THAT
COVERS BOTH OF THESE SO I WANT
WELL ON THEM BUT IT'S THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND THE
DEGREE COMPLETION OF ARTS
FUNDING IS ONE TIME.
ON SLIDE NINE IS WHERE I START
DISCUSSING.
THE UNIVERSITY'S BUDGET REQUEST
IN ADDITION TO THE GOVERNOR
STANTON BUDGET.
OF WE ARE REQUESTING A TOTAL OF
A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TWO POINT
SIX MILLION IN ADDITION TO THE
FUNDS PROVIDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
JANTAN BUDGET.
AND I'VE TRIED TO BREAK THESE
DOWN HERE FOR YOU FOR TH INTO.
THREE MAIN CATEGORIES ONE OF
THESE IS A NINETY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE CURRENT HERE.
THAT A GO AWAY ON JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY NINETEEN AT THE END OF
THIS FISCAL YEAR THAT WE'RE
REQUESTING BE MADE PERMANENT.
BOB AND THE REASON WE WE WANT
THESE FUNDS PERMANENTLY AS THEY
ARE CURRENTLY SUPPORTING
STUDENTS AND WE RECEIVED THEM IN
LIEU OF A TUITION BY OUT AND
I'LL GO INTO THAT MORE A LITTLE
BIT LATER.
WE ALSO HAVE A REQUEST ON
RELATED TO ENROLLMENT AND
GROWING ACCESS.
AND ALSO FOR OUR CAPITAL OUTLAY
DEBT SERVICE FOR PROJECTS THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN COMPLETED FOR
WHICH THAT THAT SERVICE IS NOW
COMING.
TO A HEAD AND I STILL RECALL WE
PAY FOR THAT SERVICE OUT OF OUR
OWN BUDGET.
OUT OF OUR OWN OPERATING BUDGET.
ON SLIDE TEN I WANTED TO TALK TO
YOU MORE ABOUT THE ELEMENTS OF
THIS NINETY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
UP WE'VE GOT AS ONE TIME MONEY
IN THE CURRENT YEAR.
LAST LAST YEAR DURING DEBATES ON
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE.
VOTED TO GIVE THESE FUNDS TO THE
UNIVERSITY PERMANENTLY SEEING
THAT THERE WAS A DEFINITE NEED
FOR THEM IT WAS DURING THE LAST
PHASES OF THE BUDGET.
NEGOTIATION PROCESS THAT SOME TO
PROVIDED THAT THE UNIVERSITY AS
ONE TIME.
BUT I'D LIKE TO EMPHASIZE THEIR
SUPPORTING TWO THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED UNDERGRADUATES
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS WHO ARE
HERE CURRENTLY AND WHO HAVE NOT
YET GRADUATED THESE CONTINUE TO
NEED OUR SUPPORT.
THEY CONTINUE TO NEED US --
TO PROVIDE THEM WITH COURSES
STUDENT SERVICES AND ACADEMIC
ADVISING.
ALSO WERE PART OF HIS NINETY
FIVE MILLION WAS A SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLAR --
IN LIEU OF IN LIEU OF A TUITION
AND STUDENT SERVICES BEING
CREASE WE RECEIVED SOME STATE
FUNDING.
AND IF WE HAD HAD A TUITION
INCREASE THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN AN
ONGOING FUND SOURCE.
THIS WASINTENDED TO ALSO BE AN
ONGOING FUNDING SOURCE UT IT
WAS MADE ONE TIME SO WE ARE
REQUESTING THAT THOSE FUNDS BE
MADE PERMANENT.
I WANTED TO GET THE HELL OVER
THE TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
UNDERGRADUATE SUPPORTED NOW I
MEAN WHERE DOES THE MONEY COME
FROM.
WELL IN THE CURRENT YEAR WE
RECEIVED ONE COMPANY I KNOW YEAH.
AND MURDER THAT.
BECAUSE THEY WERE --
IT WAS AN OVER AND ROLL IT
WASN'T IT WASN'T OVER
INVOLVEMENT YES THAT TOOK PLACE
IN SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN SO THAT.
THE CHANCELLORS OF THE
INDIVIDUAL CAMPUSES JUST SORT OF
TAKE IT OUT OF HIDE TO COVER THE
COST OF THE EDUCATION UNTIL WE
GOT THE ONE TIME FUNDS YES.
THAT'S THAT'S CORRECT WE USE THE
ONE TIME FUNDS --
TO HIRE OVER THIRTY TWO MILLION
HAS TO OFFER COURSES FOR THE
STUDENTS.
AND IF THOSE FUNDS GO AWAY --
LECTURES ARE TEMPORARY EMPLOYEES
WE'D LIKE TO RETAIN THEM THEY'RE
VERY GOOD QUALITY INSTRUCTORS.
OF AND WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
OFFER THE STUDENT COURSES BUT IF
WE DON'T GET THE FUNDING.
ONGOING --
THE CAMPUSES WILL HAVE TO MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS AND DECISIONS THAT
WILL NEGATIVELY IMPACT THE
QUALITY OF THE EDUCATION FOR THE
STUDENTS PRIMARILY IN THAT
CLASSES WILL BE LARGER IN SIZE
OR STUDENTS CAN'T GET INTO A
CLASS THEY MIGHT NEED FOR THEIR
MAJOR.
WHERE THE --
WERE THE OVER ENROLLED STUDENTS
DISTRIBUTED AMONG THE CAMPUS
[inaudible]
NO -- I DO
NOT HAVE THE LIST RIGHT THAT'S
FINE YES I WILL SEND THAT TO
YOUR STAFF WAS JUST CURIOUS.
THEY ARE THEY ARE THROUGHOUT THE
SYSTEM A LARGE CHUNK OF THE
MARKET --
MINE YES --
SO AND OTHER THINGS THAT WERE
DONE WITH THESE FUNDS WERE THAT
UC RIVERSIDE HIGHER FOURTEEN NEW
LOTTERING FACULTY LETTERING
FACULTY.
OF WE ARE PART WITH US
PERMANENTLY SO IF THEY DO NOT
RECEIVE ONGOING FUN STILL HAVE
TO MAKE OTHER ADJUSTMENTS WITHIN
THEIR BUDGET.
WHICH WOULD --
INVOLVE STAFF WHO ARE WHO DON'T
HAVE SECURITY OF EMPLOYMENT --
ON SLIDE ELEVEN I'D LIKE TO
CONTINUE ON AND I DO WANT TO
ALSO MENTION THAT OF FOUR POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS OF THE
NINETY FIVE MILLION.
WAS SPENT ON MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR STUDENTS ON CAMPUS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
UP ON SLIDE.
ELEVEN I YOU SEE THE MAJOR
COMPONENTS OF OUR HUNDRED
NINETEEN POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS YOU MANDATORY COSTS FOR
THE UNIVERSITY.
OF THIS THE THE HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION THAT YOU HEARD ABOUT
EARLIER AND THIS IS ONLY TO
MAINTAIN OUR EXISTING OPERATIONS
SO THESE ARE INCREASES TO THE
RETIREMENT INCREASES TO OUR
LABOR CONTRACTS AND INCREASES TO
THE HEALTH BENEFITS --
NOW WHILE THIS MAY SEEM LIKE A
LARGE INCREASE FOR OTHER STATE
AGENCIES --
PLEASE REMEMBER THAT THIS
INCREASE IS ON THE U. SEES A
THREE POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS STATE GENERAL FUND
BUDGET AND DOC REPRESENTS ABOUT
3% OF OUR COSTS SO IT'S ABOUT.
IT'S ABOUT IN KEEPING WITH A
COLA -- AND
IF WE DON'T RECEIVE THAT NINETY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OF ONE TIME
THAT I JUST DISCUSSED --
THAT WILL EAT INTO THESE FUNDS
THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED.
FOR US.
IN THE IN THE CURRENT YEAR THE
NEW FUNDING SO WE DO THINK THAT
THAT'S NECESSARY AT THE NINETY
FIVE MILLION MUST BE COVERED
FIRST AND THEN THE TWO HUNDRED
FORTY THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
PROPOSED FOR US.
FOR A NEW AND EXPANDED USES.
OF OTHER HIGH PRIORITY COST THAT
YOU SEE THERE INCLUDE FACULTY
COMPENSATION STAFF COMPENSATION
AND CAPITAL OUTLAY DEBT SERVICE.
I'M GOING TO DISCUSS CAPITAL
OUTLAY LATER IN THE AGENDA BUT
FOR STAFF COMPENSATION THE
PROPOSAL IS FOR FORTY TWO POINT
SIX MILLION IS A 3% INCREASE IN
SALARY FOR NON REPRESENTED STAFF.
FOR THE PAST TEN YEARS YOU SEE
HAS BEEN UNABLE TO HAVE A SYSTEM
WIDE SALARY PROGRAM TO INCREASE
NON REPRESENTED STAFF SALARIES --
AND IN THE PAST TEN YEARS OUR
AVERAGE ANNUAL BUDGET INCREASE
FOR STAFF SALARIES WAS ONE POINT
8% UNIVERSITY WIDE.
COMPARED TO OTHER STATE AGENCIES
WHICH ARE GETTING ABOUT YOU KNOW
BETWEEN TWO AND 5%.
WE'RE A LITTLE BIT LESS --
ON FACULTY COMPENSATION
COMPONENT IS A NINETY FOUR POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS AND
INCLUDES THREE PARTS --
THESE COMPONENTS ARE THIRTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
FACULTY MERITS.
FACULTY MERITS AS THE PROGRAM
WHERE AN ASSOCIATE --
ASSISTANT PROFESSOR BECOMES AN
ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR ASSOCIATE
PROFESSOR BECOMES A FULL
PROFESSOR.
IT'S A REVIEW THAT EACH FACULTY
MEMBER GETS EVERY THREE YEARS
AND THEY HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
MOVE UP EITHER IN PAY OR THE
JUMP -- IN
TITLE.
OF WE WERE SUED IN A CLASS
ACTION SUIT --
IN NOVEMBER OF NINETEEN NINETY
THREE IN SAN FRANCISCO SUPERIOR
COURT RULED AGAINST YOU SEE IN
THE CASE CALLED ANDERSON VERSUS
REGIONS.
OF THAT STATED THAT WE CANNOT
SKIP PROVIDING FACULTY MERITS IN
ANY YEAR OF DUE TO BUDGETARY
REASONS --
AND BECAUSE OF THAT WE'VE YOU
FACULTY MERITS AS A MANDATORY
COST IF WE WILL COVER IN SOME
MANNER SO THAT'S THIRTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS WE HAVE TO COVER
FOR THAT.
THE SECOND COMPONENT OF THE
FACULTY COMPENSATION PIECES
FORTY SEVEN POINT THREE MILLION
TO FUNDAN AVERAGE FACULTY
SALARY INCREASE OF 3% OF OUR
FACULTY.
AND THEN WE HAVE A FOURTEEN
MILLION DOLLAR SEPARATE SALARY
PROGRAM AS PART OF A MULTI YEAR
EFFORT TO TRY AND CLOSE OUR
FACULTY SALARY CAPS.
WITH OUR COMPARISON INSTITUTES --
ON THE NEXT SLIDE SLIDE OF
TWELVE I HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF
INFORMATION ABOUT OUR FACULTY
SALARIES OF MAY ILLUSTRATE SOME
OF THESE POINTS --
WE HAVE FOUND THAT FIFTEEN OUT
OF THE TOP TWENTY INSTITUTIONS
THE QC LOSES FACULTY TO WHEN WE
HAVE FACULTY LEAVE US FOR OTHER
INSTITUTIONS.
WE LOSE TEM TO PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS NOT THE PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS --
AND IN OUR COMPARISON INSTITUTES
OF WERE SELECTED AFTER EXTENSIVE
DISCUSSION WITH --
THIS IS YEARS AND YEARS AGO BACK
IN EIGHTIES OR NINETIES.
WITH OF LA --
AND THE NOW DEFUNCT C. PACK
SELECTED OUR COMPARISON
INSTITUTES SO THIS WASN'T THAT
WE WERE CHERRY PICKING WHO WE
FELT THAT YOU KNOW.
WE WE FELT.
WE WERE LIKE --
IN OUR COMPARISON INSTITUTES ARE
LISTED THERE.
ARE STILL RELEVANT.
YES I DO YES I DO BECAUSE THE WE
COMPARE OURSELVES TO TOP PUBLICS
WHO THAT PUB HAVE --
COMPETITIVE RESEARCH THAT ALSO
PULL IN A LOT OF FEDERAL GRANTS
AND WE COMPARE OURSELVES --
TO EXCELLENT PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS THAT WE WE STRIVE
TO BE LIKE.
AND SIX OF THE UCS ARE NOW IN
THE TOP TEN PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES
IN THE COUNTRY.
WHICH GIVES SUPPORT TO YOU THE
CONTINUED USE OF YOUR LIST I
SUPPOSE YES --
SO WE HAD WE HAD A SURVEY OUR
OUR FACULTY --
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE FOUND THAT
SALARY WAS MOVED THE MOST OFTEN
CITED REASON WHY OUR FACULTY
LEFT FOR OTHER UNIVERSITIES.
AND WE ARE STILL SIX POINT 7%
BELOW ARE COMPARISON INSTITUTES
AVERAGE AVERAGE OF THOSE EIGHT
COMPARISON INSTITUTE DID YOU SEE
LIST THAT THEY'RE ON THE RIGHT
HAND SIDE.
OF THE SLIDE.
TWELVE ALL RIGHT IN THAT
CONCLUDES THE OPERATIONAL
COMPONENT OF MY DISCUSSION THE
NEXT DISCUSSION IS --
ON RESIDENT AND NONRESIDENT ROLE
MENTAL PAUSE HERE FOR QUESTIONS
OR SEE.
YEAH SURVEYS OF THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR.
VERY COMPREHENSIVE REPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH --
THIS WEK OUT THOUSANDS OF UC
EMPLOYEES --
INCLUDING HEALTH CARE WORKERS
ARE ON STRIKE FOR WAGE IMPROVE
WAGES AND BENEFITS.
HOW YOU ALIGN STRONG REVENUE
GROWTH INCLUDING A 7% INCREASE
IN HOSPITAL REVENUES AND OVERALL
SYSTEM FUNDING INCREASE? TO
SUPPORT THESE REPRESENTED
EMPLOYEES.
THE INCREASE IN OF REPRESENT
EMPLOYEE SALARY WOULD BE
PROVIDED --
THE FUNDING SOURCE AT THEIR BASE
SALARIES CURRENTLY --
FUNDED OUT OF WE HAVE AS PART OF
OUR OPERATIONAL REQUESTS.
AN AVERAGE OF THREE POINT 6%
INCREASE.
TO ARE REPRESENTED EMPLOYEES'
SALARIES --
THAT [inaudible]
WE ARE.
THAT WILL BE DISTRIBUTED
SOMEWHAT DIFFERENTLY BASED ON
THE NEGOTIATION PROCESS WHICH
EACH OF UNION AND AS YOU KNOW WE
ARE IN THE NEGOTIATION PROCESS
WITH TWO OF OUR UNIONS CURRENTLY.
OF AND HAVE MADE AN OFFER AND
HAVE A STATE APPOINTED MEDIATOR
FOR THOSE NEGOTIATIONS AND WE
ARE HOPING THAT --
THEY WILL RETURN TO THE
BARGAINING TABLE AND MOVED TO
THE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
PROCESS WITH US SO WE CAN
NEGOTIATE WITH THEM A CONTRACT
THAT THEIR EMPLOYEES DESERVE SO
THEY CAN BE PAID.
HIGHER WAGES BECAUSE COSTS IN
THE STATE ARE GOING UP AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO PAY THE MAHR.
I THINK THAT THAT THAT SOUNDS
GOOD -- BUT
I WOULD ALSO THINK THAT IT MAKES
SENSE -- TO
TO SUPPORT GOVERNORS PRIOR --
PROPOSAL TO PRIMARY PREY TO
PRIORITIZE FUNDING FOR THE
REPRESENTED EMPLOYEES I THINK HE
IS SET TO MAKE THAT A PRIORITY.
AND I HOPE THAT THE UC COME FIND
A RESOLUTION --
QUICKLY UNDERSTAND THE SAY THAT
THERE'S A PROPOSAL ON THE TABLE
BUT CLEARLY IF THEY'RE ON STRIKE
IT'S NOT WHAT THEY'RE THINKING
THEY DESERVE.
SO.
AS SOMEONE WHO NEGOTIATED FOR AS
IN THE MIDDLE AND I I HOPE THAT
YOU CAN DO THAT I URGE THE SHEET
THAT YOU SEE AND MAKE THAT A
PRIORITY.
THANK YOU SENATOR AND WE DO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
THANK YOU. FOR THE QUESTIONS.
KAY SO WHAT WHAT ARE WE ON
ISSUE TO RESIDENT AND
NONRESIDENT ROLAND IS THAT WE'RE
DOING [inaudible]
OKAY.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
TEN MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT ROMAN
GROWTH CURRENTLY PAID FOR BY ONE
TIME FUNDS IN --
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AS WE
DISCUSSED IN PREVIOUS HEARINGS
THE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PER OF
FUNDS THE MOST CRITICAL PIECES
OF THE USES WHEN A REQUEST
FUNDING ARE ALREADY NEGOTIATED
SALARY INCREASES WHICH WE JUST
DISCUSSED.
ENSURING THAT STUDENTS ARE FED
AND HOUSED IN PROVIDING NEEDED
MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES THANK
YOU [inaudible]
HELLO.
SO THERE ARE. THREE ISSUES
BEFORE YOU WHEN THIS ITEM THE
FIRST IS A RESIDENT ROMAN IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THE
SECOND IS RESIDENT ROLE MEANT IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND IN
FUTURE YEARS.
ON THE THIRD ISSUE IS NON
RESIDENT ROMANCE ALL TOUCH ON
EACH ISSUE.
WITH REGARD TO THE FIRST ISSUE
ENROLLMENT IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN ON YOUR
AGENDA PROVIDES A PRETTY LENGTHY
ANALYSIS OF OF WHAT HAPPENED
THAT YEAR AND IT'S A SOMEWHAT
COMPLICATED BACKSTORY BUT
EFFECTIVELY WHAT HAPPENED IS THE
STATE SAID IN A MORE PROVIDED
SOME ADDITIONAL ONE TIME FUNDING.
AND AN INTENT LANGUAGE STATED
THAT ONE OF THE PART OF THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT WAS TO GROW
MORE RESIDENT UNDERGRADUATES.
WITH A REAL RESIDENT AND
WRENCHED UNDERGRADUATE ALONG AND
BEYOND THAT TARGET.
THE ISSUE HERE IS THAT IN
PROVIDING THOSE FUNDS THE BUDGET
DIDN'T SET AT THE EXPLICIT
TARGET AND HOW MANY STUDENTS
THAT.
INITIAL TARGET.
AND IT DIDN'T CLARIFY HOW YOU
SEE WOULD CONTINUE TO SUSTAIN
THAT ENROLLMENT --
AND AND LATER YEARS BECAUSE IT
WAS ONETIME FUNDING.
YOU SEE CURRENTLY ESTIMATES THAT
IT AND ROLLED ABOUT NINETEEN
HUNDRED MORE STUDENTS THAN WHAT
WAS EXPLICITLY BUDGETED AND THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING TEN
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING TO
SUPPORT A THOUSAND STUDENTS SO
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT ABOUT.
LITTLE MORE THAN HALF OF THE
OVER BUDGET OF THE OVER BUDGET
STUDENTS.
AND GIVEN THE AMBIGUITIES IN
THIS LANGUAGE WE THINK THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING ONE
REASONABLE APPROACH --
BUT ULTIMATELY WITH A QUESTION
FOR THE COMMITTEE IS WHAT DID
THE LEGISLATURE INTEND WHEN IT --
PROVIDED THESE ONE TIME FUNDS.
WITH REGARD TO THE SECOND ISSUE
ENROLLMENT IN LATER YEARS.
WHAT IS AN AREA WHERE YOU DON'T
HAVE A GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THE
GOVERNORS IN PROPOSING?
AN ENROLLMENT TARGET FOR IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY OR EVER
EVER LATER YEARS.
AND ISN'T OUT ISN'T --
APPROPRIATING ANY ADDITIONAL
FUNDING ABOVE THAT TEN MILLION
FOR A MOMENT IN.
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WE RECOMMEND
AS WE DO EVERY YEAR THAT YOU
SAID IN A ROMAN TARGET FOR YOU
SEE AND CLARIFIED THAT INSURES
THAT YOU SEE IS MEETING YOUR
MOMENT THEIR LEGISLATURES IN
ROMANS EXPECTATIONS. ONE THING
WE WOULD RECOMMEND IS INSTEAD OF
SITTING AT FOR TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY WE RECOMMEND YOU SET THAT
TARGET.
FOR TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
THE REASONING FOR THAT IS THAT
BY THE TIME THE LEGISLATURE NEXT
THE BUDGET YOU SEE WILL HAVE
MADE ITS ADMISSION DECISIONS.
FOR FALL TWENTY NINETEEN SETTLED
WOULD HAVE BEEN TOO LATE TO
INFLUENCE THEIR DECISIONS OF THE
LEGISLATURE HAS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SET ITS PRIORITIES FOR THE
FOR THE BUDGET YEAR PLUS ONE AND
AS IN PREVIOUS BUDGET FOR THAT
AND IN PREVIOUS BUDGETS.
AND THEN THE QUESTION IS WELL IF
FOR THAT TARGET BE GROWTH.
MARINE FLAT WHAT WHAT SHOULD
THAT TARGET THE AND WE OFFER
SOME FACTORS FOR YOU TO CONSIDER
A MEASURE AS YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT THIS AND WEIGHING THIS
AGAINST.
YOUR OTHER BUDGET PRIORITIES FOR
THE SYSTEM.
ON THE ONE HAND THE UNIVERSITY.
IS -- IN A
DRAWING FROM IT LIKELY DRAWING
FROM BEYOND ITS FRESHMAN
ELIGIBILITY.
FOR AND HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES
ARE PROJECTED TO DECLINE SO MUCH
OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS NOT THAT
MIGHT SUGGEST THAT THAT THIS
MIGHT BE A LOWER PRIORITY FOR
THE LEGISLATURE.
ON THE OTHER HAND MANY ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS ARE NOT ACCOMMODATED TO
THEIR CAMPUS OF CHOICE AND ARE
REDIRECTED TO MERCED AND AND
MOST STUDENTS ARE RE REFERRED TO
MERCED ON DON'T TAKE UP THE
ADDITION OFFER DON'T ENROLL IN
THE SYSTEM.
AND SO THAT MIGHT SUGGEST THAT
IT COULD STILL BE A HIGH
PRIORITY FOR THE COMMITTEE.
AND WITH REGARD TO THE FIRST
ISSUE THE THIRD ISSUE
NONRESIDENT ROMANCE JUST A NOTE
HERE -- WE'D
WRITTEN IN OUR ANALYSIS THAT USE
HE'S PLANNING TO ENROLL ABOUT
EIGHT HUNDRED MORE RESIDENT
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS AND
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY ON THE
ONE AREA OF UNCERTAINTY HERE IS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS.
REQUESTED THAT --
YOU SEEK TO DEVELOP A REPORT AND
SUBMIT TO IT AND IN APRIL OF
THIS YEAR.
A PLAN TO REDUCE NONRESIDENT
ROMAN BY YOU SEE TO UNDERTAKE
THAT PLAN OBVIOUSLY THE EIGHT
HUNDRED STUDENTS MIGHT NOT.
IN THAT GROWTH MIGHT NOT IT
HAPPENED IN NINETEEN TWENTY
DEPENDING ON WHETHER OR NOT THE
LEGISLATURE --
INTENDS FOR USING A KERRY FOR
KERRY OUT OF THAT PLAN
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DID YOU SAY THAT THE YOU SEE
HEAD.
EXPECTS THERE HAS NINETEEN
HUNDRED MORE F. T. STUDENTS AND
THEN WE BUDGETED FOR THAT'S
RIGHT IT THEY'RE THEY'RE
ANTICIPATING --
ENROLLMENT IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
GREW BY ABOUT THIRTY NINE
HUNDRED RESIDENT UNDERGRADUATES
AND WE HAD EXPLICITLY BUDGETED
FOR TWO THOUSAND SO THAT'S
THAT'S WHERE THAT ADDITIONAL
NINETEEN HUNDRED GRAND AND IN
THIS BUDGET WE'RE FUNDING HOW
MANY OF THOSE.
NINETEEN HUNDRED THOUSAND WHY
WOULDN'T WE FUND.
NINETEEN HUNDRED THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION FOR THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE UNIVERSITY.
IS WE HAVE TO TAKE IT FROM
SOMEPLACE ELSE IS AT THE
UNIVERSITY INDICATED --
IN ITS REQUEST THAT IT HAD A ONE
THOUSAND ADDITIONAL STUDENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN ROLLED AND THAT
WAS.
THE TARGET THAT IS IT SET FOR
ITSELF.
THERE ARE OTHER MULTIPLE REVENUE
SOURCES FOR UNIVERSITIES COVER
THIS OVER ROMAN --
SO WE DECIDED TO FIND THE THE
TARGET.
IS WHAT WE CAN HAVE A DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE UC.
THANK YOU --
ON SLIDE THIRTEEN OF MY
PRESENTATION I HAVE A SUMMARY OF
OUR ENROLLMENT FUNDING REQUESTS
THAT MIGHT BE HELPFUL --
AS WE WORK THROUGH THIS.
WE ARE SEEKING TO GROW
CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATE
ENROLLMENT FOR NEXT YEAR --
BY TWO THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED NEW
A CALIFORNIA RESIDENT UNDERGRADS
AND BY A THOUSAND NEW GRADUATE
STUDENTS AND THIS WOULD COST A
TOTAL OF FORTY POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL
FUNDING.
THE REST OF OUR FUNDING REQUEST
IS RELATED TO EXISTING --
ENROLLMENT THAT WE HAVE TO
RECEIVE FUNDING FOR WE OFTEN
REFERRED TO THIS AS OVER
ENROLLMENT --
STUDENTS FOR WHICH THERE IS NO
STATE MARGINAL COST OF
INSTRUCTION RESEARCH RECEIVED
CURRENTLY --
SO IN FALL TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE
OVER AND ROLLED BY NEARLY
NINETEEN HUNDRED CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS STUDENTS AS YOU HEARD
WE WERE.
WAS FUNDING IDENTIFIED FOR TWO
THOUSAND OF FIVE MILLION WHICH
CAME FROM THE STATE AND FIFTEEN
MILLION CAME FROM YOU CEASE
INTERNAL RESOURCES.
AND THEN THERE'S THIS OTHER
NINETEEN HUNDRED STUDENTS WHO
ARRIVED --
SOME OF THE REASONS WE ENDED UP
OVER AND ROLLING IS THAT --
ADMISSIONS IS VERY MUCH OF AN
ART MORE THAN NECESSARILY A
SCIENCE THIS IS LESS THAN A
PERCENTAGE POINT OFF.
WILL CREATE THIS KIND OF A LARGE
SWING --
THOUGH A THOUSAND OF THE
STUDENTS WERE IN SAN DIEGO WHERE --
I'D LOCAL DECISION WAS MADE TO
MAKE MORE OFFERS TO LOCAL
STUDENTS AND HIGH SCHOOLS WHO
HAD EXCELLED --
AND THOSE STUDENTS TOOK UP THOSE
OFFERS IN FAR GREATER NUMBERS
THAN WE THOUGHT THEY WERE GOING.
TO ANOTHER FIVE HUNDRED WORDS LA
WHO ARE NOT ANTICIPATING --
LARGE JUMP IN THERE --
IN THEIR ACCEPTANCE AS BUT THEY
HAD MOVED UP IN RANKINGS --
FROM SECOND OF PUBLIC UNIVERSITY
THE FIRST PUBLIC AND I CREATED A
LITTLE --
ADDITIONAL BUMP FOR THEM
[inaudible]
SO.
WE HAVE THESE NINETEEN HUNDRED
NEW STUDENTS THAT WE WERE NOT
NECESSARILY ANTICIPATING AND WE
ARE REQUESTING TWENTY ONE POINT%
NINE MILLION DOLLARS. TO PROVIDE
THEM WITH --
INSTRUCTION COURSES SUPPORT
SERVICES.
AND SO FORTH YOU'VE ALREADY
HEARD ABOUT OUR EIGHT POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR PRIME
REQUEST SO I WON'T GO INTO THAT.
A VERY MUCH NEEDED FUNDING.
OF AND WE ALREADY DISCUSSED THIS
PART OF THE PRIOR ITEM.
THE TWENTY SIXTEEN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN OVER ENROLLMENT FOR
THE TWENTY FIVE MILLION THAT WAS
PROVIDED TO US ONE TIME FUNDING.
SO ALL TOGETHER THESE REQUESTS
ARE -- ARE
QUITE LARGE.
UP ON THE NEXT SLIDE I PROVIDE A
REPRESENTATION ON SLIDE --
FOURTEEN OF HOW QUICKLY OUR
RESIDENT ENROLLMENT HAS GROWN.
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS.
OF AFTER THE GREAT RECESSION WE
SLOW DOWN OUR RESIDENT
ENROLLMENT --
THEN WE RECEIVED A LOUD AND
CLEAR MESSAGE FROM THE
LEGISLATURE THAT RESIDENT
INVOLVEMENT WAS VERY MUCH WANTED
AT THE YOU SEE AND YOU WANTEDUS
TO ENROLL MORE STUDENTS.
AND WE WENT FOR IT AND WE HAVE --
AND ROLLED.
UP WELL OVER FOURTEEN THOUSAND
NEW NEW FTE STUDENTS IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS.
OFBUT WHAT THIS DOES FOR OUR
CAMPUSES THERE'S AN ADDITIONAL
NEED ON FINANCIAL AID NOT JUST
ON THE FINANCIAL AID DOLLARS BUT
ON THE ADVISING.
OF THERE'S A NEED FOR NEW
SERVICES WE'RE FINDING A LOT OF
REQUESTS FOR APPOINTMENTS.
OF THE STUDENT TO FACULTY RATIO
IS SUFFERING.
OF AND WE HAVE --
WE'RE HEARING FROM STUDENTS THAT
THE CLASSROOM CONDITIONS ARE NOT
WHAT THEY WOULD ANTICIPATE IN A
TOP UNIVERSITY.
AND WE'RE HAVING A LOT OF
PROBLEMS WITH OUR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE.
ON THE NEXT SLIDE SLIDE FIFTEEN
IS WHERE I GO INTO WHERE WAS
THIS UNFUNDED AND ROMAN I REALLY
TRY TO ILLUSTRATE A BREAK IT
DOWN FOR YOU.
YOU SEE A CHART THERE ON THE
PAGE WITH THE YEAR IN THE FAR
LEFT.
OF AND THEN OUR TOTAL CALIFORNIA
UNDERGRADUATE THIS OUR RESIDENT
INVOLVEMENT THERE.
AND THE GROWTH AND DECLINE THAT
OCCURRED EACH YEAR --
AND YOU'LL SEE WHAT KIND OF WENT
DOWN 414-152-1516 AND THEN BEGAN
A RAPID GROWTH UP.
OF THE BUDGET ACT MANDATED
CERTAIN GROSS FROM THE UC --
FOR WHICH I FUNDING WAS
IDENTIFIED WITHIN THE BUDGET ACT
ARE NOT ALWAYS AT THE MARGINAL
COST OF INSTRUCTION SOMETIMES
LESS BUT IT WAS IDENTIFIED AND
THAT WAS OUR AGREEMENT.
OF AND THEN THE UNFUNDED GROWTH
IS THERE ON THE FAR RIGHT OF THE
CHART YOU'LL SEE WE'VE OVER AND
ROLLED IN THE LAST FEW YEARS BY
FOUR THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
STUDENTS. FOR WHOM WE ARE NOT
RECEIVING ANY STATE FUNDING.
I WAS AT AN INTENTIONAL.
OVER IN ROMAN OR WAS IT THE
RESULTS OF THE ISSUES THAT YOU
JUST INDICATED WHERE WHERE
PEOPLE.
ACCEPTED MISSION OFFERS THEM
PROGRAMMED.
IT WAS NOT INTENTIONAL IT WAS --
IT WAS VERY MUCH ACCIDENTAL SO
IN SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN THE BUDGET
ACT LANGUAGE ACTUALLY SAID THAT
UNLESS WE ENROLLED THOSE FIVE
THOUSAND IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED STUDENTS WE WOULD NOT
RECEIVE ANY.
FUNDING FOR ANY OF THE NEW
ENROLLMENT.
SO THERE WAS A LOT OF
ENCOURAGEMENT FROM YOU CYCLE GO
BIG.
IN ROLLED A LITTLE BIT MORE SO
WE'RE WE'RE CERTAIN TO MAKE OUR
MAKE A FEW MORE OFFERS SO WE
TURN TO GET ALL THE STUDENTS WE
NEED -- AND
WE PUSH THEM A LITTLE TOO HARD
THE PERSON VERY VERY MUCH TO
HEART WE OVER INVOLVED BY A LOT
OF STUDENTS.
A AND THEN THE LANGUAGE WAS
REMOVED OUT OF THIS CURRENT YEAR
BUDGET ACT CURRENT YOUR BUDGET
ACTS OF HAD MORE FOR GIVEN
LANGUAGE THAT SAID IF WE DON'T
ENROLL THE STUDENTS THEN WE'LL
LOOSE.
A PROPORTIONAL AMOUNT OF STATE
MONEY WILL LIKE THAT WE
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU TO YOUR
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT.
FOR HELPING TO WRITE THAT --
AND BUT WE HAD WE STILL END UP
OVER AND ROLLING BECAUSE OF
THESE ISSUES.
SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES WOULD
THINK THAT'S A GOOD THING.
WHAT WE'RE ALL ABOUT ACCESS
WE'RE ALL ABOUT AXIS BUT WE'RE
ALSO ABOUT QUALITY AND WE
PROMISE TO STUDENTS THAT THEY
CAN ACTUALLY GET INTO THE
CLASSES ONCE THEY'RE IN THE
UNIVERSITY?
AND THAT'S WHY WE NEED TO HIRE
MORE MORE INSTRUCTOR SUPPORTED
HIM AND I'M I'M SURE FINANCE
WOULD SAY WELL YOU KNOW WE NEED
BUDGET INTEGRITY TO SO.
THAT'S WHY I ASK MY QUESTION AS
TO WHETHER IT WAS AN INTENTIONAL
ACT.
WHICH IS.
THIS SORT OF HAPPENSTANCE BUT WE
STILL NEED TO ADDRESS.
AND WE ARE.
NOW IN THE PROCESS USE YOUR P.
IS HELPING THE CAMPUSES EVALUATE
THEIR FORMULAS. FOR HOW THEY HOW
THEY MAKE OFFERS BECAUSE THIS
LAST OF FALL TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE
DID NOT NEED TO GO.
ON OUR WAITLIST ALMOST AT ALL.
MOST CAMPUSES NEVER WENT ON THE
WAIT LIST AND YET THERE ARE --
WE'RE EXAMINING HOW MANY OFFERS
DO WE MAKE ON THAT FIRST ROUND.
BECAUSE WERE ABLE TO FILL ALL
OUR SEATS --
FOR FALL TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE HAVE
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
APPLICATIONS.
SYSTEM WIDE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF APPLICATIONS
[inaudible]
OF ON SLIDE. SIXTEEN I WANTED TO
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHO ARE
THE STUDENTS THAT WE'VE BEEN AND
ROLLING --
OVER THE LAST EIGHTEEN YEARS THE
ETHNIC MIX OF THE UC STUDENT
POPULATION HAS BEEN CHANGING.
OF THE LATINO LATINO STUDENT
POPULATION IS THE FASTEST
GROWING AMONG ALL OF OUR
CALIFORNIA AND RESIDENT
UNDERGRADUATES --
AND WE NOW HAVE MULTIPLE
CAMPUSES THAT ARE.
CONSIDERED HISPANIC SERVING
INSTITUTIONS WE'RE VERY PROUD OF
THOSE DESIGNATIONS.
I USE THESE FACULTY HIRING --
IS.
IMPROVING TO REFLECT THE STUDENT
BODY THAT WE SERVE.
OF BOTH DEFINITELY MORE WORK
NEEDS TO BE DONE THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE AMONG THE PUBLIC
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITIES IS 8% UNDER
REPRESENTED MINORITY FACULTY AND
YOU SEE IS A 10% SO WE'RE DOING
A LITTLE BIT BETTER.
THAN THE OTHER PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES IN HIRING FACULTY
WHO LOOK LIKE THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS STUFF WHERE AND ROLLING --
FOR THE PAST THREE YEARS THE
LEGISLATURE VERY GENEROUSLY
PROVIDED US WITH ONE TIME MONEY
TWO MILLION A YEAR ONE TIME FOR
THREE YEARS. TO DO FACULTY --
DIVERSITY HIRING PROGRAMS PILOT
PROGRAMS AND WE LEARNED A LOT
FROM THOSE PROGRAMS.
OF WERE NOW INSTITUTING FOR
HIRING SYSTEM WIDE FACULTY
DIVERSITY STATEMENTS SO THE
CANDIDATES FOR JOBS WILL TALK
ABOUT.
HOW DO THEY HOW DO HOW DO THEY
PERCEIVE IT THAT THAT --
AND WHAT WHAT CONTRIBUTION TO
MAKE TO THE CAMPUS --
AND ALSO WE'VE LEARNED A LOT
ABOUT WHERE TO ADVERTISE FOR
FACULTY POSITIONS IN ORDER TO
GET A MITE MORE DIVERSE GROUP OF
CANDIDATES FOR FACULTY POSITIONS
SO.
WHERE --
WE'RE MAKING SOME PROGRESS AND
WE HOPE TO CONTINUE ON THAT.
ON SLIDE.
SEVENTEEN THE NEXT SLIDE UP INTO
SPEAKING PRIMARILY ABOUT OUR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT ROMAN SO FAR
I KNOW THAT --
THE LEGISLATURE'S VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT --
BUT ARE YOU CEASE.
ENROLLMENT OF NON RESIDENTS HAS
ALSO BEEN GROWING IN RECENT
YEARS.
IN THIS CHART ON FLIGHT
SEVENTEEN YOU WILL SEE THAT ARE --
HOW THE NON RESIDENTS
REPRESENTED BY DARK YELLOW BAR
HAVE BEEN INCREASING OVER THE
LAST DECADE?
THE NON RESIDENT ROMAN HAS
BECOME A SIGNIFICANT SOURCE OF
CORE FUND REVENUES FOR THE
UNIVERSITY --
YOU WILL RECALL AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE PRESENTATION THAT I
STAYED AT THAT NON RESIDENT
TUITION IS NOW OF ONE POINT
THREE BILLION IN ANNUAL REVENUES
FOR THE UNIVERSITY THAT'S BEING
PAID BY THOSE THAT YELLOW BAR
THERE.
OF THE REGIONS ON MARCH
FOURTEENTH DECIDED TO DELAY A
VOTE TO INCREASE NONRESIDENTS
SUPPLEMENTAL TUITION BY TWO
POINT 6%.
OF THAT INCREASE WOULD HAVE
YIELDED --
ANOTHER ALMOST TWENTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS OF REVENUE THAT
THE UNIVERSITY BUT THE VOTE HAS
BEEN DELAYED.
ON THAT --
AN ON SLIDE.
EIGHTEEN I WANTED TO SHOW YOU
THE FOUR FUNDS OF THE UNIVERSITY.
OVER THE LAST --
TWO DECADES.
OR WE'VE MOVING AWAY FROM NON
RESIN -- WE
CAN TALK ABOUT NON REST I WAS
GOING TO TALK ABOUT THE CORE
FUNDS FOR STUDENT NUMBER HOW WE
WOULD SPEND THE ENROLLMENT MONEY
THAT WE'RE REQUESTING.
WELL I HAVE A COUPLE MAY ASK A
QUESTION YES OF COURSE SO I
NOTICED THAT --
THE APPARENTLY A COUPLE OF THE
CAMPUSES EXCEEDED THEIR CAP ON
NON RESIDENT [inaudible]
ESTIMATION.
I I HAVE A GENERAL CONCERN AND
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY --
RESTRICTED TO THE UC CAMPUS IT
HAPPENS TO BE IN THE SENATE
DISTRICT I'M PRIVILEGED TO
REPRESENT ITS ITS ITS ITS OTHER
UC CAMPUSES AS WELL.
THAT ARE NOT AS ATTRACTIVE
APPARENTLY TO THE NON RESIDENT
STUDENT AS SOME OF THE MORE --
SOME CAMPUSES COULD IF YOU
WOULDN'T HAVE A CAP COULD
PROBABLY FLOAT TO NON RESIDENT
STUDENT POPULATION MUCH HIGHER
THAN THE CAP I WOULD ASSUME.
I BELIEVE SO --
AND WHAT THAT DOES WHEN WE HAVE --
RESIDENT TUITION SORT OF LEVEL
OR FLAT.
IT'LL ALLOW SOME CAMPUSES --
TO TO GENERATE SIGNIFICANT.
ON CAMPUS REVENUES THROUGH NON
RESIDENT TUITION AND IF WE HAVE
WON THE NON RESIDENT TUITION
INCREASE.
HOW DO YOU HOW HOW CAN WE DESIGN
A PLAN TO SORT OF SPREAD THAT?
EXTRA MONEY.
ACROSS ALL OF THE UC CAMPUSES
THOSE THAT HAVE NO TROUBLE
ATTRACTING NONRESIDENT STUDENTS
AND THOSE THAT HAVE TROUBLE.
SO THAT WE BOATS FLOAT TO THE
SAME LEVEL.
ANY CHANGE IN THE FUNDING
DISTRIBUTION FORMULA WOULD HAVE
TO GO TO BE APPROVED BY THE
REGENTS --
CURRENTLY THERE IS NO PROPOSED
CHANGE TO OUR OF FORMULA IN
FRONT OF THE REGIONS.
OF THE CAMPUS THAT IN ROLES TO
STUDENT GETS TO KEEP THE REVENUE
FROM THAT STUDENT --
PARTLY IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
SERVICES THAT STUDENT AND IN
ORDER TO GROW SERVICES FOR THE
RESIDENT STUDENTS THROUGH THE
EXTRA REVENUE THAT THEY GOT FROM
THOSE NON RESIDENTS --
I I HEAR WHAT YOU'RE SAYING SIR
THAT YOU WOULD LIKE US TO
CONSIDER SOME KIND OF A
DIFFERENTIAL REVENUE SHARE WITH
JUST IT IT CREATES OF CERTAIN
INEQUITY IN THE IN THE IN THE
SYSTEM AND I REALIZE YOU KNOW
THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL.
SEPARATIONS AND ALL THAT BUT IT
DOES CREATE SORT OF IT SEEMS TO
ME AN INEQUITY IN THE SYSTEM.
BUT HAVE CAMPUSES AND THEY HAVE
NOT CAMPUSES AS IT PERTAINS.
TO NON RESIDENT STUDENT TUITION
AND THE COST OF EDUCATING THE
STUDENT.
THE NON RESIDENT STUDENT
PROBABLY IS THE SAME AS THE COST
OF EDUCATING THE RESIDENT
STUDENT TO THE MOST YES.
AND SO THERE'S A DELTA THERE
THAT IS ABLE TO BE USED BY THE
HAVE CAMPUSES.
THAT THOSE THAT DON'T HAVE THAT.
DO WITHOUT AND AND WHAT PIQUED
MY CURIOSITY WAS MY
UNDERSTANDING OF THE PLAN.
TO DEAL WITH THE NET REVENUE
GENERATED BY --
THE OVER AND ROLL BUT OF NON
RESIDENT STUDENTS ABOVE THE
CAPTAIN IS MY UNDERSTANDING.
THAT THAT'S GOING TO SORT OF BE
DISTRIBUTED THROUGH THE THROUGH
THE SYSTEM THAT'S CORRECT SIR
AND AND I WAS WHEN I READ THAT I
THOUGHT WELL WHAT WHY IS THAT
MONEY.
IF IF NOTHING ELSE NOT BEING
DISTRIBUTED TO THE CAMPUSES THAT
DON'T HAVE THE ADVANTAGE OF
RECRUITING AND RETAINING NON.
STUDENTS IF FOR NO OTHER REASON
THAN -- TO
THIS INCENTIVIZE.
THIS NON RESIDENT OF STUDENT
ENROLLMENT IF THAT'S THE GOAL --
HERE YOU SAY CORRECTLY THAT YOU
WOULD PREFER THE OVER ENROLLMENT
FUNDING FROM THOSE NON RESIDENTS
BE GIVEN TO THE CAMPUSES TO MAKE
CERTAIN OF ONE TWO CAMPUSES THAT
DID NOT OVER AND ROLL ONLY.
RIGHT OR THE OKAY OKAY OR THOSE
CAMPUSES THAT DO NOT HAVE THE
ABILITY.
TO OF SECURE VERY MANY NON
RESIDENT STUDENTS IN THERE BY
GENERATE THE ADDITIONAL
OPERATING REVENUES AT SOME
CAMPUSES A RIPPLE TO GENERATE.
OF WE WILL TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
AND I MEAN I DON'T HAVE.
MY SAY RIGHT I MEAN I UNDERSTAND
THAT BUT I'M JUST I WAS
EXPRESSING CONCERN WITH THE WAY
THE NON RESIDENT TUITION.
SYSTEM WORKS ACROSS YOU SEE
BECAUSE I'M SURE THERE'S MORE
THAN.
ONE UC CAMPUS.
THAT HAS TROUBLE ATTRACTING
NONRESIDENT STUDENTS --
YES YES WE HAVE WE HAVE A FEW OF
THOSE AND THEN THERE'S SOME ON
THE COAST OF PROBABLY HAVE NO
TROUBLE ATTRACTING NON RESIDENT
STUDENTS THAT'S CORRECT AND THEN
IT SORT OF CREATES AN INEQUITY
IN THE WAY THE THE REVENUE
SYSTEM WORKS AMONG UC CAMPUSES
AND I I'M.
I'M JUST HOPEFUL WOULD YOU ALL
THERE'S A MORE EQUITABLE WAY TO
AT LEAST --
DISTRIBUTE SOME OF THE FUNDS --
HOW ABOVE THE LEVEL NECESSARY TO
EDUCATE?
STUDENTS IN THE UC SYSTEM.
SIR I WILL TAKE YOUR PERSPECTIVE
BACK TO OUR LEADERSHIP THAT'S
ALWAYS WHAT IS THAT I I DIDN'T
MEAN TO BELABOR THE POINT I
THOUGHT IT WAS AN INTERESTING
READ THOUGH SO I WANT TO ASK BUT
PLEASE PROCEED.
ALL RIGHT --
SO ON SLIDE EIGHTEEN I HAVE SOME
INFORMATION ABOUT WHERE ARE WE
IN TERMS OF OUR FUNDING FOR
STUDENTS SYSTEM WIDE FOR THIS IS
LOOKING SYSTEM WIDE.
ON THE LEFT HAND SIDE YOU SEE
OUR TOTAL FUNDS OF FROM
200-022-00018 AND YOU'LL SEE
THAT.
OF IN ACTUAL DOLLARS OUR CORE
FUNDS HAVE BEEN INCREASING A LOT
OF THIS IS BECAUSE THE
LEGISLATURE IN RECENT YEARS HAS
BEEN PROVIDING YOU SEE WITH MORE
FUNDING CONSISTENTLY ESTY
ECONOMY IMPROVED.
THE LEGISLATURE WAS PROVIDING
YOU SEE WITH FUNDING AND WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THAT.
BUT BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN ON THE MIDDLE
CHART THERE.
YOU WILL SEE THAT OUR STUDENT
ENROLLMENT AS A WHOLE INCREASED
BY 59% OVER THE LAST EIGHTEEN
YEARS WE HAVE BEEN TAKING ON A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF STUDENTS.
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE AMOUNT
OF INCREASED ENROLLMENT AND THE
DOLLARS THE DOLLARS AVAILABLE
PER STUDENT SYSTEM WHITE OUR
CAMPUSES HAS ACTUALLY DECREASED
BY.
31% PER STUDENT IS IS IS THERE A
IS THERE A PROBLEM.
BECAUSE WE READ IN THE BUDGET
YOU KNOW GOING TO ENROLL TWO
THOUSAND WERE YOU DOING.
WE'RE GONNA GIVE YOU WHATEVER IT
IS TWENTY HELLO WE USE.
IN DOING OUR BUDGETING.
A NO WE AGREE WITH THE MARGINAL
COST OF INSTRUCTION THAT.
WE USE CURRENTLY --
IT'S JUST THAT.
THE STATE FUNDS HAVEN'T KEPT UP
FULLY WITH THE ENROLLMENT AND WE
WE NEED WE NEED ADDITIONAL
FUNDING.
OKAY I'LL GO TO SCHOOL ON THAT
SO NEXT TIME I'LL BE SMARTER.
SO THE MARGIN WE WE BUDGET TO
THE MARGINAL COST OF INSTRUCTION.
HELP ME FINANCE THAT THAT'S
CORRECT YEAH BUT IT'S EARLY IN
THE PAST WE'VE GIVEN MORE.
WELL HOW DO WE DO THAT WE GET IF
WE BROUGHT BUDGETING TO THE
MARGINAL COST OF INSTRUCTION HOW
DO WE HAVE A 31% DECREASE.
THIRTY ONE ARE A LOT OF THAT HAD
TO DO WITH THE ONE BILLION
DOLLAR CUT THE UNIVERSITY TOOK
IN THE GREAT RECESSION.
WE WERE WE WERE CUT FROM THREE
BILLION TO TWO BILLION AND WHILE
YOU'VE BEEN BUILDING OUR BUDGET
UP I SEE IN HER ROOM AND WE IN
ROMAN GROUP AND WE HAVEN'T
REALLY IT RESTORED.
IN PROPORTION THE MONEY THAT WE
TOOK FROM YOU THAT'S CORRECT SIR
I GET IT TAKES ME AWHILE.
OF THANKS FINE IT'S I THINK I
GOT IT RIGHT.
YOU'RE DEAD YOU GOT IT THANK YOU
SIR -- ON
THE NEXT SLIDE I WANTED TO TALK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT'S BEEN
THE IMPACT OF THIS DECREASE IN
31%.
QUALITY FOR STUDENTS.
EARTH THE IMPACT ON QUALITY OF
THIS 31% DECREASE IN FUNDING FOR
STUDENT.
AND YOU'LL SEE THERE THAT YOU
CEASE STUDENT TO FACULTY RATIO
HAS BEEN INCREASING STEADILY
OVER THE LAST.
OUR SINS ABOUT EIGHTEEN YEARS
BUT EXPRESSLY AND WE'VE BEEN
GOING UP A LITTLE BIT --
OUR COMPARISON PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS ARE WAY
BELOW US.
SO EVEN THOUGH OUR COMPARISON
PUBLIC THEY'VE PAID THEIR
FACULTY ALONG A LITTLE BIT LESS.
THERE ARE --
THERE.
THEY HAVE A LOT MORE STATE
FUNDING AND PLACES LIKE MICHIGAN
QUITE FRANKLY HAVE 40% NON
RESIDENT EMPLOYMENT SO THEY HAVE
A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF REVENUE
COMING INTO THOSE KINDS OF
SOURCES --
AND THEY ARE ABLE TO KEEP THEIR
STUDENT FACULTY RATIOS LOWER --
AND FLIGHT TWENTY IS WHERE I
REALLY WANT TO DRAW YOUR
ATTENTION BUT IS IS VERY FROM
CAMPUS TO CAMPUS OR IS IT
GENERALLY.
THE SAME ACROSS CAMPUS IT VARIES
FROM CAMPUS TO CAMPUS THESE ARE
SYSTEM WIDE AVERAGES AND IT ALSO
VARIES WITH IN.
DISCIPLINES ON CAMPUSES SO BACK
TO THE NON RESIDENT TUITION
CONVERSATION THAT WE HAD.
THOSE CAMPUSES THAT HAVE
SIGNIFICANT NUMBERS OF
COMPARATIVELY SPEAKING NON
RESIDENT STUDENTS WHO PAY NON
RESIDENT TUITION.
WHAT I IF I WERE?
TO DO A DEEP DIVE WHAT I FIND
THAT THEIR STUDENT TO FACULTY
RATIO IS IS LOWER.
THE LET'S SAY.
I HAVE NOT LOOKED AT THOSE
NUMBERS LET ME BRING THEM TO
YOUR OFFICE.
YES IF I DON'T WANT TO SPECULATE.
BUT YOU MAY BE CORRECT ON THAT --
SLIDE.
TWENTY OF OUR OVERALL STUDENT
SATISFACTION AT UC AND THIS IS
REALLY THESE NUMBERS HERE ON
SLIDE TWENTY ARE ASED ON A
SURVEY THAT WE DO OF OUR
UNDERGRADUATE EVERY TWO YEARS
WHERE WE ASK THEM HOWARE YOU
LIKING THE SEE.
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH YOUR
EXPERIENCE HERE.
AND SINCE TWO THOUSAND SIX UNDER
RIGHT ON THE LEFT HAND SIDE
THERE --
STUDENTS WERE UP ASKED KNOWING
WHAT I KNOW NOW WHAT I STILL
CHOOSE TO ENROLL AT MY UC CAMPUS.
AND IN TWO THOUSAND SIX THIRTY
THREE PER ONLY YES ABSOLUTELY I
WOULD COME AGAIN.
OF BY TWENTY SIXTEEN THAT A
STRONG 218%.
SAID STRONGLY YES.
SO THERE'S THERE'S A TREND
OCCURRING THERE WERE STUDENTS
ARE BECOMING LESS SATISFIED.
WITH WHAT THEY'RE RECEIVING A QC.
BUT PERHAPS SOME OF THE MOST
DISTURBING DATA IS THERE ON THE
RIGHT HAND SIDE.
THAT IN THE LAST DECADE FROM
200-062-2016 STUDENTS WHO COULD
NOT GET INTO THEIR FIRST MAJOR.
INCREASE FROM 3% 213%.
THE 13% OF OUR INCOMING FRESHMAN
CLASS CAN'T GET INTO THE MAJOR
THAT THEY WANT TO GET INTO
BECAUSE THEY'RE IMPACTED.
BECAUSE THERE AREN'T ENOUGH
FACULTY TEACHING THEM.
AND WHAT THAT MEANS IS THERE'S A
TREMENDOUS LOSS OF HUMAN
POTENTIAL STUDENTS CAN STUDY THE
THING THEY'RE ACTUALLY
PASSIONATE OR INTERESTED IN --
AND ALSO THERE'S A SENSE OF
DISAPPOINTMENT IN A DAY MAYBE
KICK START FEELING LOST MAYBE
THEY DON'T KNOW.
WHAT ARE THEY DOING WITH OUR
LIVES TO TO MAKE THE RIGHT
CHOICE LOOKS AT HER?
SO WHAT'S THE GATE THERE IS THE
GATE THE FIRST THE ENTRY LEVEL
COURSE INTO A PARTICULAR MAJORS
HAVE POLITICAL SCIENCE ONE A ONE
AND THEY CAN'T GET INTO THAT.
AND IF THE CASTING CAN'T GET
INTO THAT THEN THEY CAN'T BE A
POLITICAL SCIENCE MAJOR.
ALRIGHT YOU TOTAL THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO BE A
POLITICAL SCIENCE MAJOR AND YOU
KNOW THAT YOU HAVE THE CAPACITY
FOR TWENTY FIVE MORE AND SO IF
FIFTY SHOW UP AT THE FRONT GATE.
TWENTY FIVE GET IN AND TWENTY
FIVE LADDER THAT FIFTY SHOW UP
IN TWENTY FIVE DON'T GET IT YEAH
BECAUSE YOU COUNT THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO DECLARE POLITICAL
SCIENCE MAJOR IN YOU KNOW.
BUT YOU CAN ONLY HANDLE A
THOUSAND OF THEM THAT'S CORRECT
OKAY YEAH I DID NOT KNOW THAT'S
INTERESTING --
AND THEN ALSO WE'RE FINDING THAT
OUR STUDENTS ARE FEELING LESS
CONNECTED WITH THEIR FACULTY SO
THERE'S BEEN A 14% OF DROP.
IN STUDENTS WHO SAY THEY KNOW
THEIR FACULTY WELL ENOUGH TO ASK
FOR A LETTER OF RECOMMENDATION.
WHEN OUR FRESHMEN COME INTO UC
39% OF THEM SAY THEY WANT TO GO
TO GRADUATE SCHOOL --
IF YOU GO TO GRADUATE SCHOOL AND
GET A PROFESSIONAL DEGREE OR PHD
ARE MASTERS.
YOU CAN EARN A LOT MORE MONEY IN
YOUR CAREER AND HAVE A DIFFERENT
KIND OF CONTRIBUTION TO THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY.
BUT IF THEY CAN'T ASK FOR A
LETTER OF RECOMMENDATION.
THEY CAN'T GET INTO GRADUATE
SCHOOL.
THAT'S A REQUIREMENT WHY IS THAT
IS THAT BECAUSE THE INCREASED
USE OF LECTURERS OR THE AVERAGE
WITH ASSISTANCE OR TEACHING
COURSES WHAT WHAT BECAUSE THE
WHERE WHERE HAD NOW HAVING OUR
LATERITE FACULTY TEACH VERY
LARGE.
LECTURES WITH THAT --
STUDENT INTERACTION TAKING PLACE
WITH THE GRADUATE STUDENTS
DOCTORS.
AND SO THE STUDENTS HAVE.
IS THAT THE CASE ONCE YOU GET
BEYOND THE THE I FORGET WHAT YOU
CALL THEM.
YOU'RE THE LOWER DIVISION
COURSES IN AS OPPOSED TO THE
UPPER DIVISION.
YEAH THAT'S MORE THE LOWER
DIVISION AND AN UPPER DIVISION
YOU HAVE MORE CONTACT WITH A
FACULTY MEMBER.
BUT NOW WE ARE TEACHING A LOT
MORE OF THE UPPER DIVISION
COURSES WITH LECTURES
[inaudible]
I SEE.
AND WHAT DRIVES THAT ARE NOT
HAVING ENOUGH MONEY TO HIRE
FACULTY.
I WISH I COULD YOU HELLO.
MY EXACT QUESTION THAT I HAD BUT
THE PUBLIC AND GET HOW MANY
STUDENTS ARE.
GRAND UNDERGROUND ARE THERE --
AT I HAVE THE EXACT NUMBERS ARE
SOMEWHAT OF WE HAVE TO HAVE
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS --
I BELIEVE ABOUT. FIFTY SEVEN OF
THEM ARE --
OKAY YEAH IT JUST THAT'S A
PHENOMENAL NUMBER I I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU'RE EVER GOING TO SOLVE
THAT PROBLEM.
EVEN WITH MORE FACTLY I DON'T
KNOW HOW YOU.
HOW YOU DO THAT WE MAY NOT SOLVE
IT BUT WE ARE CERTAINLY HOPE
HOPING TO CLOSE THE GAP
[inaudible]
OKAY YEAH WELL THAT'S A LOT OF
IT DEFINITELY IS YEAH.
WOULD YOU SEE YOUR HAS TWENTY
THREE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY EIGHT IN --
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN YEAH I
SAID SYSTEM MY NUMBER SO NO I
KNOW I THINK I COULD THINK OF SO
ROSE ASKING IN.
YES THE BRAINS ON THE DIS TO MY
RIGHT.
FIGURED OUT THE THE NUMBER MY
THANKS TO THE COMMITTEE TOLD A
DEVICE TO NOT --
WE HAVE THIS I MEAN OBVIOUSLY
THIS ISN'T THIS.
FOCUS OF THE BUDGET HEARING BUT
IT'S INTERESTING TO FACULTY DO
OFFICE HOURS AND CONTACT AND
THEY THEY DO --
OFFICE HOURS BUT IF THEY HAVE
GONE FROM HAVING.
SAY THREE COURSES WITH OF FORTY
STUDENTS IN THEM.
THE THREE COURSES WITH A HUNDRED
STUDENTS IN EACH.
THE OFFICE HOURS ARE ALSO
IMPACTED I SEE YES --
ON SLIDE TWENTY ONE I HAVE ARE --
I PRESENT THE REGION'S PLAN FOR
MONEY THAT THEY ARE HERE
REQUESTING FROM YOU TODAY --
THE REGIONS AS PART OF THE MULTI
YEAR FRAMEWORK WANT TO HIRE
ADDITIONAL LETTERING FACULTY
ABOVE AND BEYOND THEY'RE JUST A
REPLACEMENT OF THOSE WHO RETIRE
AND LEAVE THE UNIVERSITY.
AND IN NINETEEN TWENTY WITH THIS
AND ROMAN CROSS FUNDING THAT WE
ARE REQUESTING THE ENROLLMENT
MONEY THAT WE'RE REQUESTING.
WE WOULD HIRE TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
NEW LETTERING FACULTY ON TOP OF
THE OF LATTER THE FACULTIES OF
WE NEED TO REPLACE THE ONES WERE
LEAVING.
SO THAT'S OUR PLAN. TO THE YOU
SEE OF COURSE HAS A AS A
RESEARCH MISSION AND THAT'S THE
MASTER PLAN AND THAT'S THE WAY
IT SHOULD BE.
DOES THE FACT THAT YOU SEE IS A
RESEARCH INSTITUTION AND THE
FACT THAT THE RESEARCH IS
CONDUCTED BY.
OBVIOUSLY THE MOST.
EXPERIENCED AND SENIOR FACULTY
AT AMONG OTHERS.
DOES THAT IMPACT THE THE FACULTY
TO STUDENT RATIO AND THE ABILITY
OF A STUDENT HAVE CONTACT WITH
THE PROFESSOR FOR EXAMPLE AT
UCLA -- AND
AND DO YOU HAVE DIFFICULTY.
PERSUADING OR FORCING
[inaudible]
FULL TIME.
PROFESSORS THE MORE EXPERIENCED
FACULTY.
OUT OF THE LAB AND INTO THE
CLASSROOM.
MOON MANY QUESTIONS THEY'RE ALL
TRYING TO TAKE THEM ONE AT A
TIME THAT I'VE LOST.
THE THE STUDENT TO FACULTY
RATIOS DISCOUNTED BASED ON
FACULTY F. T. E. REGARDLESS OF
HOW THE FACULTY SPENDING THEIR
TIME SO IT'S HOW MANY FACULTY
ARE EMPLOYED.
VERSUS HOW MANY STUDENTS ARE
ENROLLED.
IN TERMS OF THE EXPERIENCED
FACULTY OF THE SOME OF THEM WHO
BRING IN THE MULTI MILLION
DOLLAR GRANTS THAT SUPPORT
GRADUATE STUDENTS SIX ADDRESS --
ARE ALLOWED --
TO DO WHAT'S CALLED A BUYOUT
THROUGH THEIR GRANT FUNDS OF
THEIR OWN TIME IF THEY PROVIDE
THE UNIVERSITY WITH FUNDS TO
HIRE A LECTURER INSTEAD THEY CAN
BE RELEASED FROM ONE OF THEIR
COURSES THAT THEY NEED TO TEACH.
IN RDER TO DEVOTE MORE OF THEIR
TIME TO TEACH INSISTS THAT THAT
FLATTERING FACULTY MIGHT HAVE
LESS.
OF TEACHING TIME WITH
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS BUT MORE
LABORATORY TIME WITH GRADUATE
AND UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS IN
THEIR ACTUAL OF RESEARCH ROLE.
OF IN TERMS OF FACULTY ENJOYING
TEACHING STUDENTS.
IT DEPENDS ON THE INDIVIDUAL
FACULTY MY FATHER WAS A
PROFESSOR AND HE DID NOT ENJOY
TEACHING UNDERGRADUATES.
AND MY OLDER BROTHERS A
PROFESSOR AND HE SPECIFICALLY
REQUEST TO TEACH UNDERGRADUATES
BECAUSE HE ENJOYS THEM SO.
IT DEPENDS ON THE INDIVIDUAL
FASCINATING ISSUE MAYBE THE BIOS
SHOULD BE INCREASED SO WE CAN
HER TENURE TRACK FACULTY INSTEAD
OF LECTURES AND MAYBE THAT WOULD
HELP SOLVE THE STUDENTS
SATISFACTION.
I'M I'M NOT A 100% CERTAIN ON
THAT BECAUSE THE IT COMES OUT OF
THE GRANT AND IT'S ALSO
DEPENDENT ON THE GRANT A
PROVIDER.
WHAT THEY ALLOW AS PART OF THEIR
GRANTS?
THE AT I WOULD HAVE TO LOOK INTO
WHAT MOST OF OUR GRANTS COME
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
SO I WOULD HAVE TO LOOK AT WHAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PERMITS
ON THAT GRANT YOUR TERM LIMITED
AND SO AND SO WERE LECTURES.
YES THE TENURE TRACK FACULTY OR
NOT SO THAT PROBABLY IS THE
ANSWER BUT IT MAY ALSO CREATE
THE PROBLEM INTERESTING I DON'T
MEAN TO GET YOU OFF TRACK THANK
YOU --
SOMEONE PAGE TWENTY ONE JUST TO
REITERATE THAT IS OUR PLAN
HIRING PLAN WITH THE ENROLLMENT
FUNDS OF WE'RE REQUESTING WE ARE
INTENDING TO USE THESE FUNDS. TO
SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS THROUGH IN
OUR INSTRUCTIONAL MISSION THAT'S
THE TAKEAWAY.
ON THE NEXT DECIDED BY --
THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANT.
WOULD YOU LIKE FINEST AGREEMENT
FIRST THIRTY ONE MAY TWO IF YOU
WANT TO TALK ON FINANCE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO TALK ON ISSUES THREE
IS IT WORKING THANK YOU --
FOR MOVEMENT ISSUE.
THREE AS PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROVIDES
SOONER NINETY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND FOR THE YOU
SEE THIS IS.
GREATER THAN FOUR TIMES WAS
PROPOSED TO THE SEA AT LAST
YEAR'S.
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET --
IN LIGHT OF THIS AND IN EXCHANGE
THESE FUNDS --
THE ADMINISTRATION EXPECTS YOU
SEE TO MAINTAIN CURRENT TUITION
AND FEE LEVELS --
FLAT AND TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
WE ARE HEARTENED BY THE FACT
THAT PRESIDENT OF METROPOLIS
HONDA HAS ANNOUNCED THAT THAT
WILL BE THE CASE --
WE LOOK FORWARD TO A
CONVERSATION ON HOW WE CAN
COLLABORATE ON SHORT AND LONG
TERM INITIATIVES WITH EASY TO
PROVIDE FISCAL CERTAINTY FOR
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
INCREASE ACCESS IMPROVED IN
SUCCESS CREATE A MORE COST
EFFICIENT SYSTEM OF HIGHER
EDUCATION.
AND PROBABLY BETWEEN HIGHER
EDUCATION SKILLS NEEDED FOR THE
ECONOMY NOW AND IN THE FUTURE
THANKS THANK YOU THANKS FOR YOUR
SUPPORT HELLO.
SO THERE ARE THREE ISSUES HERE
IN THIS ITEM --
THE FIRST PERTAINS TO RESIDENT
TUITION AND FEES THE SECOND
PERTAINS TO NON RESIDENT TUITION
AND FEES.
AND THEN THE THIRD ISSUE IS
SOMETHING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS RAISED
REGARDING IMPROVING FISCAL
STABILITY FOR CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS AND THEIR AND THEIR
HOUSEHOLDS.
SOLDIERS EACH ISSUE.
REGARDING RED OUR ANALYSIS --
AT THE TIME THERE WERE STILL
SOME DISCUSSION MOTHER NOT
THERE'D BE A TUITION INCREASE
YOU SEE HAS ANNOUNCED THEY WILL
NOT INCREASE TUITION.
NONE THE LESS I THOUGHT IT MIGHT
BE INTERESTING TO DIRECT YOUR
ATTENTION TO PAGE SIXTEEN YOUR
AGENDA.
WITH WHICH IS A IS A OF THE
FIGURE THAT WE PUT TOGETHER IT
ESTIMATES.
I TRIED TO ESTIMATE THE HOW MUCH
OF THE HOW MUCH CORE FUNDING IS
SHARED BETWEEN.
OF THE STATE HOW MUCH THE BY
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS AND THEIR
SHARED BY NON RESIDENT STUDENTS.
AND THE REASON WHY WE WE THINK
THE FIGURES ROLLED RELEVANT IS
BECAUSE AS THE LEGISLATURES ARE
WAYS TO WHICH INCREASES EVERY
YEAR.
REALLY THE FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION
IS HOW DOES THE LEGISLATURE
WANTED YOUR COST INCREASES EACH
YEAR BETWEEN THE STATE.
BETWEEN STUDENTS AND ALSO
INCREASINGLY BETWEEN NON
RESIDENT STUDENTS.
I'M IN YEARS WHERE THE STATE
DOESN'T INCREASE TUITION
EFFECTIVELY THAT INCREASES THE
STATE FAIR TO COVER COSTS IS THE
STATE'S COVERING THE COST
INCREASES IN THAT YEAR --
IN YEARS WHERE THERE'S NOT
REALLY A RATHER IS A TUITION
HIKE THAT INCREASES THE STUDENTS
SHARE AND YOURS WERE THEY
INCREASE ROUGHLY PROPORTIONATE
THAT KIND OF KEEP THAT SHARON.
AND ON TRACK AND YOU CAN SEE
HERE THE STAY FIND A SOMEWHAT
OVER THE YEARS ESPECIALLY DURING
THE RECESSION WHEN THEY'RE IN
THEIR BUDGET CUTS ENACTED AND
YOU SEE --
COVERED SOME OF THAT WITH A
TUITION INCREASE ON RESIDENT
STUDENTS --
BUT IT'S STILL MORE THAN A HALF
IF YOU IF YOU FACTOR IN --
FINANCIALLY THAT STATE PROVIDES
BOTH THROUGH THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM AND ALSO THAT TUITION
AND FEES ARE WAIVED TO STUDENTS
THREE YOU SEE A AND SO AGAIN THE
KEY QUESTION FOR THE LEGISLATURE
IS.
IS DOES THIS MAKE SENSE IT'S
IT'S A FEATURE TO LOW TO TO HIRE
STUDENTS CONTRIBUTING TO MUCH.
OF THAT'S REALLY THE FUNDAMENTAL
QUESTION BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
EACH YEAR THAT EVALUATES TUITION
INCREASES.
REGARDING THE SECOND ISSUE NON
RESIDENT TUITION I WANTED TO
TOUCH ON THAT OUR ANALYSIS HAD
HAD RECOMMENDED THAT.
THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDER --
THE NON RESIDENT TUITION
INCREASES THAT YOU SEE HAD
PLANNED TO ADOPT AND USE THE
ASSOCIATED REVENUE TO OFFSET
GENERAL FUND COSTS.
OF THE BOARD OF REGENTS RECENTLY
AND REJECTED A TUITION INCREASE
SO THAT ASSOCIATED REVENUE
WOULDN'T BE AVAILABLE TO OFFSET
COSTS AND LESS OF THE REGIONS.
AT A LATER TIME DECIDE TO
INCREASE THAT [inaudible]
TUITION CHARGE.
AND WITH REGARD TO THE FIRST DAY
A TIRD ISSUE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION RAISES. FOR
FISCAL SUSTAINABILITY.
I WOULD DIRECT YOUR ATTENTION TO
PAGE. FOURTEEN FOURTEEN IS
REALLY WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION
IS LOOKING AT WHEN WHEN THAT
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT FISCAL SEE
US THE BILLETING.
AS YOU CAN SEE.
UP IN SOME PERIOD SO THE STATE'S
HISTORY TUITION HAS BEEN FLAT OR
EVEN DECLINED.
AND THEIR OTHER YEARS WERE THERE
HAVE BEEN REALLY REALLY NOTABLE
TUITION HIKES THAT'S LARGELY
DRIVEN BY THE STATE OF THE BY
THE STATE BUDGET AND YEARS WERE
REVENUES ARE STRONG THE STATE
HAS BEEN ABLE TO KEEP TUITION
FLAT.
AND YEARS WERE THEIR BUDGET
REDUCTIONS YOU SEE IS HOW TO
CREASES AND THAT.
CREATES SOME UNPREDICTABILITY
FOR STUDENTS AS THEY'RE GOING
THROUGH THREE YEARS AND IN
COLLEGE.
WE THINK THAT THIS IS THAT
APPROPRIATE --
POLICY ISSUE FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO CONSIDER.
I'M BECAUSE A LOT OF THIS IS
AFFECTED BY THE STATE BUDGET ONE
KEY WAY TO LEGISLATE WHEN HE
TOLD THE LEGISLATURE HAS TO
ENSURE STABILITY IS TO SET ASIDE
FUNDS AND IN THE GENERAL FUND
RESERVE VERY YEAR.
SUCH THAT WHEN THERE IS A
RECESSION IT CAN USE THOSE FUNDS.
TO COVER --
UP A POTENTIAL BUDGET CUTS AND
IF IT IN YEARS WERE REVENUES
DECLINED.
ANOTHER UP ENDED IN TANDEM TO
THAT --
HAVING A CLEAR POLICY ON HOW
MUCH STUDENTS SHOULD CONTRIBUTE
EACH YEAR TO THEIR OUR COSTS
WOULD ALSO HELP.
ENSURE THAT THERE'S A CLEAR
POLICY IN A TRANSPARENT POLICY
GUIDING TUITION INCREASES IN THE
WAY THAT MY WORK.
AS A LEGISLATURE WOULD DECIDE
WHAT WHAT YEAR OF COST SHOULD
STUDENTS CONTRIBUTE TO THEY
CONTRIBUTE 10% SHOULD THEY
CONTRIBUTE 20%.
AND IT WOULD.
BE AN OPERATIONAL POLICY THAT
THE LEGISLATURE WOULD WORK
TOWARDS EVERY YEAR AND WHAT'S
ATTAINING THAT.
PROPORTION IT WOULD THEN SHARE
CO EQUALLY GENTLE FUN TUITION
EACH YEAR AND THAT WOULD BE ONE
WAY TO ADD MORE TRANSPARENCY TO
THE TUITION DISCUSSION WELL
ISN'T THERE OF ISN'T THERE MEAN
THERE'S THERE'S A CLEAR
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN TUITION
TUITION INCREASES IN OUR
KELLGREN EXPENDITURES IN THE
BUDGET OR ISN'T.
THERE.
THAT'S ALSO TRUE WITH EVERY WED
TUITION INCREASE ALSO --
THE CAL GRANT ALSO INCREASES THE
COVER THAT BECAUSE I MEAN I MEAN
I GUESS I COULD.
TAKE THE CHARTS AND SOMEWHERE IN
HERE THIS.
YEAH LOOKS LIKE.
SOMETHING OUT OF GEOLOGY --
IN SORT OF FIGURE THAT OUT BUT I
MEAN THERE IS A RELATIONSHIP SO
IF YOU INCREASE TUITION CALGARY
GOES UP DOESN'T MEAN IT SHOULD
BETTER [inaudible]
RIGHT.
THAT'S RIGHT AND THEN THE OTHER
THING YOU MENTIONED RESERVES AND
I WE'VE HEARD IT IN HERE AND I
WILL ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT IT
BEFORE IN EARLIER SESSIONS YOU
KNOW THE THE SYSTEMS WOULD WOULD
APPRECIATE SOME SORT OF MULTI
YEAR LOOK WITH THE WITH THE SOME
SORT OF QUESTION IN.
A RESERVE DON'T HAVE BUDGETARY
TURBULENCE WHEN THEY'RE TRYING
TO PLAN FOR ENROLLMENT AND PLAN
FOR HIRING AND IF I IF I LISTEN
TO THE BOTH OF THE UC
REPRESENTATIVE AND THE CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY CHANCELLOR THE OTHER
DAY.
YOU KNOW THAT'S ONE OF THE
COMPLAINTS WITH THE WAY WE DO
HIRE READ BUDGETING HERE.
IS IT IT'S IT CAUSES TURBULENCE.
YOU KNOW MID YEAR.
UPS AND DOWNS AND IF THEY HAD
SOME IF THEY WERE ASSURED OF A
OF A CONSTANT.
OVER ONE TO MY MAKING SENSE OVER
ONE AND TWO AND FINANCE IS
LOOKING AT ME LIKE I'M NOT BUT
OVER ONE AND TWO AND THREE YEAR
PERIOD THEN THEY COULD.
THEY THEY KNEW THAT THEY WOULD
KNOW HOW TO PLAN AND IT'S NOT
THE WAY WE BUDGET.
GET OVER THEM WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO HAVING A DISCUSSION
WITH WITH USING PARTICULAR
REGARDING LONG TERM BUDGETARY --
WORK AT MORGAN IN THE FUTURE AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE GONNA
PRIORITIZE THAT THE FINANCIAL
NEEDS OF OF OUR STUDENTS RIGHT
WE WILL SOLVE THAT TODAY.
DID I CATCH YOU OFFICER.
THAT'S THE END THANK YOU OKAY.
LOVE LOST WORRY YOU SEE --
WE ARE ON PAGE TWENTY TWO OF MY
PRESENTATION --
SO I WAS GOING TO JUST BRIEFLY
TALK ABOUT THE TYPES OF FEES YOU
SEE HAS --
AND YOU DID ASK IF CAL GRANTS GO
UP -- WIND
FEES INCREASE CURRENT POLICY IS
THAT CAL GRANTS ARE LINKED TO
THE FEES AT THE PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES.
SO EVERY TIME WE INCREASE OUR
TUITION CAL GRANT PAYMENTS OCT
DO GO UP AS WELL AND IN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN YOU SEE STUDENTS ARE
RECEIVING ABOUT. NINE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN CAL
GRANT ASSISTANCE FROM THE STATE.
SO SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT --
SO SYSTEM WIDE CHARGES OF THAT
ARE THE SAME ACROSS FOR ALL
CAMPUSES.
AND THESE ARE TUITION.
OF WHICH ALL STUDENTS PAY
REGARDLESS OF THEIR GRADUATE
STUDENTS UNDERGRADS RESIDENTS
NONRESIDENTS EVERYBODY PAYS THE
TUITION --
AND WE TAKE ABOUT ONE THIRD OF
OUR TUITION REVENUE AND SPEND IT
ON FINANCIAL AID.
OF STUDENT SERVICES FEE --
PAYS FOR THE SERVICES FOR
STUDENTS THAT ARE NOT PART OF
INSTRUCTION ON THE CAMPUSES --
AND STUDENT SERVICES FEE --
FOR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN IS ONE
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
EIGHT DOLLARS PER YEAR.
AND NON RESIDENT SUPPLEMENTAL
TUITION IS PAID ONLY BY OUR NON
RESIDENT STUDENTS --
THERE IS A WAIVER PROCESS FOR
OUR UNDOCUMENTED A. B. FIVE
FORTY STUDENTS.
BUT THAT WAIVER PROCESS DOES NOT
CAPTURE EVERY UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS IN THE SYSTEM --
PARTLY BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO HAVE
IT.
TENDED A CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL
FOR THREE YEARS I GRADUATED FROM
A CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL.
IN ORDER TO QUALIFY FOR THAT A.
B. FIVE FORTY WAIVER --
WHAT'S THE WHAT'S THE CAMPUS
BASED FEE A CAMPUS BASED FREE IS
A FEVER --
THAT CAN COME ABOUT IN TWO WAYS
MOSTLY VOTED IN BY THE STUDENTS
THEMSELVES.
THE STUDENTS CAN CHOOSE TO TAX
THEMSELVES FOR PARTICULAR
PURPOSES THEY CAN DO THIS.
FOR OF SOME.
PROGRAMS --
SERVICE PRO THAT THEY DO --
AND FOR EXAMPLE AS TO UC DAVIS --
THERE IS A US LET'S SEE THEY DO
CHARGE THEMSELVES A MEMORIAL
UNION FEE --
WHICH HELPS PAY FOR PARTICULAR
BUILDING ON THE CAMPUS --
UPGRADES TO THAT IT'S A STUDENT
MEETING PLACE WHERE THEY CAN
STUDY AND HAVE THEIR CLUBS AND
SUCH [inaudible]
SO OF THE CAMPUS BASED FEES ARE
VOTED IN EITHER BY THE STUDENTS
OR REQUESTED FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION APPROVED BY THE
REGENTS.
SO IF THE THERE'S TO PROCESS
THESE FOR THAT THEY VARY BY
CAMPUS SO THEY'RE NOT THE SAME
FOR ANY ANY TWO CAMPUSES.
WELL THE REASON I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS THE ANALYSIS OU MAY
HAVE SEEN REFERENCES CAMPUS
BASED FEES AND REFERRING TO
CAMPUS BASED FEES SET BY CHANCE
OR IS AN APPROVED BY THE REGENTS
THE ONE OF THE EXAMPLES WAS TO
HELP ENSURE THE SAFETY OF
STUDENTS SUCH AS THE SEISMIC.
RETROFIT OF A BUILDING I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT'S A CONCRETE
EXAMPLE WHEN THEY UC SYSTEM BUT
IF IT IS.
I WAS WONDERING WHY IN THE WORLD
WE WOULD USE A CAMPUS BASE FEE.
FOR THAT SERVER OF CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENT WE OUGHT TO BE.
WE OUGHT TO BE FUNDING THAT OUT
OF THE GENERAL FUND BUDGET OR
THROUGH A BOND --
AS OPPOSED TO CHARGING STUDENTS
TO SEISMICALLY RETROFIT THE
BUILDING --
IF THOSE THOSE CAMPUS BASED FEES
HAVE BEEN APPROVED BY THE
REGIONS IN THE PAST THE BEST WAY
TO FUND CAPITAL OUTLAY PROGRAMS
IS A DEAL BOND.
DEFINITELY --
WE ALSO HAVE AN INTERNAL CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROCESS NOW THAT ALLOWS
US. TO SEEK APPROVAL FROM THE
LEGISLATURE FOR SPECIFIC
PROJECTS.
AND THEN ONCE THAT APPROVAL IS
GAINED WE CAN USE OUR INTERNAL
OPERATING REVENUES --
AS COLLATERAL TOWARD.
A DEATH PROGRAM THAT ALLOWS US
TO WE HAVEN'T YOU SEE HAS NOT
HAD A COUPON SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND SIX SO WE'VE WE'VE
BEEN WITHOUT THOSE CONSTRUCTION
FUNDS FOR AWHILE YOU'LL LET US
KNOW HOWEVER IF CAN'T CAMPUS
BASED FEES TO USED TO DO.
WHAT I WOULD CONSIDER A CAPITAL
PROJECT THAT THEY ART THERE ARE
USED FOR CAPITAL PROJECTS ON
MULTIPLE CAMP WILL WELL?
OTHER THAN A STUDENT.
RED I REALIZE THE STUDENT BUILD
FOR YOUR SIR TALKING ABOUT THE
STATE OF AVAIL ELIGIBLE
BUILDINGS BEING ACADEMIC
BUILDINGS BEING RETROFITTED YES
I'LL LET YOU KNOW IF.
ANY OF THOSE X. RIGHT I
UNDERSTAND THE STUDENTS PAY FOR
THEIR BUILDINGS THAT THEY USE
FOR NON ACADEMIC.
ISSUES THROUGH STUDENT FEES OF
ONE SORT OR ANOTHER.
I READ THIS IS BEING --
AND AN ACADEMIC BUILDING.
I'LL HAVE TO GET YOU MORE
INFORMATION ON THAT PARTICULAR
FEE PERFECT YES.
I'M MORE BETTER VERSED
IN IN THE SYSTEM WIDE FEES.
AND ON SLIDE TWENTY THREE I
INCLUDED FOR YOUR CHARTS WITH
VERY SMALL PRINT I APOLOGIZE I
HOPE YOUR EYES CAN READ THAT --
ON THE LEFT THERE OF WHAT OUR
UNDERGRADUATE THE THE FEES HAVE
BEEN -- SO
IT SAYS UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT
TUITION BUT IT'S BEEN TUITION
THE SAME FOR ALL STUDENTS ALL
THOSE YEARS.
AND THEN THE STUDENT SERVICES
FEE AND WHAT IT IS ON OUR FOR
OUR RESIDENTS SO --
FOR NINETEEN TWENTY ARE UC
PRESIDENT JANET APOLLO TANO SAID
THAT SHE WOULD NOT SEEK A
TUITION INCREASE. FOR OUR FOR
THE SYSTEM WIDE FREE SO TOTAL
SYSTEM WIDE FEES TUITION AND
STUDENT SERVICES FEE WOULD BE
TWELVE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
SEVENTY DOLLARS. FOR OUR
STUDENTS NOW THIS MAKES --
MAKES IT SO THAT IN THE LAST.
SEVEN YEARS --
WE'VE ONLY HAD ONE TUITION
ACTUALLY SEEN A SMALL DECREASE
LAST YEAR OF SIXTY DOLLARS.
WHEN THE LIQUID A CHARGE ONE
AWAY?
OF THE REGION'S BUDGET PLAN
INCLUDED --
TUITION AND STUDENT SERVICES FEE
BY OUT FOR SIXTY THREE POINT
EIGHT MILLION THAT WOULD HELP BY --
IN THAT BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
INCREASING TUITION OURSELVES WE
ARE REQUESTING THATTHE STATE
PROVIDE US WITH MONEY BUT THAT
MONEY IS PART OF THE ENROLLMENT
REQUEST WE ALREADY WENT THROUGH
SO YOU DON'T.
YOU DON'T NEED.
TO CONTEMPLATE THAT.
AS A SEPARATE AMOUNT --
ONSITE TWENTY FOUR I WANTED TO
GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT OF AN IDEA
OF HOW DOES THE UNIVERSITY SPEND
OUR STUDENT FEE REVENUE THAT WE
RECEIVE --
AND YOU'LL SEE THERE THAT ABOUT --
STUDENT FEES TO REMIND YOUR
ABOUT 42% OF THE CORE FUNDS THIS
IS THE TUITION STUDENT SERVICES
FEE COMPONENT OF THESE FEES.
AND 61% GO TO INSTRUCTION SO
THIS IS TO PAY.
FOR A OT OF RANK FACULTY
LECTURERS ARE GRADUATE STUDENTS
DOCTORS --
ANOTHER 27% GOES TO FINANCIAL
AID AND THE REASON THE FINANCIAL
IS NOT THE FULL 33% IS BECAUSE
THERE'S A HISTORICAL --
BASELINE TO IT WHERE IT USED TO
BE A LITTLE BIT LESS THAN THIRD
AND THEN IT'S A THIRD ON THE
MARGINAL INCREASES.
SO IT'S A LITTLE BIT LESS BUT
WE'RE PUTTING 23% OF 27% OF OF
OUR FEES --
INTO FINANCIAL AID.
AND THE A LARGE AMOUNT OF THOSE
ARE SPENT ON TO VARIOUS STUDENT
SERVICES --
IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THE TUITION
AND STUDENT SERVICES BE A BUYOUT
AS I ALREADY DISCUSSED WAS
PROVIDERS ONE TIME FUNDING.
AND THEN NON RESIDENT FEES ARE
LISTED ON SLIDE. TWENTY FIVE YOU
WILL SEE THAT ARE NON RESIDENT
STUDENTS ARE NOW PAYING ABOUT
410-005-0060 TWO DOLLARS
ANNUALLY IN THE THREE MANDATORY
FEES THAT THEY HAVE TO PAY
THAT'S NOT INCLUDING CAMPUS
BASED FEES.
OF THE REGIONS HAVE A BUDGET
PLAN TO INCREASE --
NON RESIDENT TUITION BY TWO
POINT 6% HOWEVER THEY HAVE
TABLETOP FOR NOW THEY DID NOT
TAKE A VOTE ON IT AT THEIR LAST.
HEARING AND AB FIVE FORTY
STUDENTS.
HAVE THEIR NON RESIDENT
SUPPLEMENTAL TUITION WAVED.
ANY QUESTIONS ON OUR FEE
STRUCTURE --
NO QUESTION.
A ONE MORE COMMON SIR I JUST
WANTED TO NOTE THAT --
YOU SEE DOES HAVE A EXTENSIVE
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAM AND IN OF
THE LAST FISCAL YEAR THAT WE
HAVE THE DATA AVAILABLE 57% OF
OUR STUDENTS DID NOT PAY TUITION
BECAUSE FINANCIAL AID COVERED
FOR THAT FOR THEM.
THAT'S PRIMARILY THROUGH THE CAL
GRANT PROGRAMS.
PELL GRANT PROGRAM AND THE
UNIVERSITY'S OWN FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAM I NOTICED ON THE AGENDA
I THOUGHT THAT WAS VERY
IMPRESSIVE I WASN'T AWARE THAT
[inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
ARE WE ON THE NEXT TO BE READY
FOR ISSUE NUMBER.
FOUR YES WE'RE MOVING THROUGH
THIS IMPRESSED --
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
FORTY NINE POINT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS --
I'M GOING GENERAL FUND FOR
DEGREE TEAM IS TO INSERVICE
PROGRAMS THIS IS GOING TO ALLOW
THE CITY TO HIRE NEEDED FACULTY
AND OFFER SUPPORT SERVICES THAT
BETTER ENABLE.
NOW COMES.
AND IMPROVE TIME TO DEGREE AT
THE UC HAS BROAD DISCRETION USE
THESE FUNDS TO ACHIEVE THOSE
GOALS.
LA -- ANY
COMMENT.
UP UP ALREADY THREE ISSUES FOR
THE THE FIRST --
ISSUE FOR YOU TO CONSIDER IS THE
EXTENT TO WHICH OF THE THIS
FUNDING WOULD ADDRESS A PRIORITY
OF OF THE LEGISLATURE --
OBVIOUSLY THE STATE HAS AN
INTEREST IN ENSURING THAT
STUDENTS SUCCEED WHEN THEY GET
TO COLLEGE --
YOU SEE STUDENTS HAVE THE
HIGHEST GRADUATION RATES --
COMPARED TO THE STUDENTS AT CSUN
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN THE PAST
THE STATE HAS PRIORITIZED IN
SUCCESS RESOURCES FOR CS YOU IN
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
REALLY FOCUSED ITS POLICY
ATTENTION THAT YOU SEE ON OTHER
PRIORITIES LIKE CONTROLLING
COSTS INSURING ACCESS IMPROVING
BUDGET TRANSPARENCY.
THAT'S BEEN A REASONABLE WAY TO
APPROACH THE THE DIFF SEGMENTS
AND THEY'RE DIFFERENT --
POLICY ISSUES ONE THING WE WOULD
NOTE THOUGH --
IF YOU GO TO PAGE TWENTY OF YOUR
AGENDA AS WE RESEARCH THIS
PROPOSAL WE DID.
LEARN THAT YOU SEE IT HAS --
PRETTY PERSISTENT.
ACTUATION RATE GAPS BETWEEN US
DIFFERENT A GREAT RACE AND
ETHNICITY GROUPS.
ON THIS IS TRUE THE OTHER TWO
SEGMENTS TRUE BUT IT IS PRESENT
AT UC -- AND
THIS WEEK WE'VE THIS THIS VERY
WELL COULD BE A PRIORITY FOR THE
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER AS IT
SWINGS OTHER BUDGET.
IS OF DECISIONS.
THE SECOND ISSUE FOR THE
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER IS HOW
THESE FUNDS WOULD BE USED AS THE
ADMINISTRATION NOTED YOU SEE
WOULD HAVE.
A BROAD DISCRETION TO ALLOCATE
THESE FUNDS TWO CAMPUSES IN
KANSAS WITH A BROAD DISCRETION
TO USE THESE FUNDS TO ADDRESS
STUDENT SUCCESS ISSUES --
AND USUALLY HAS DEVELOPED A LONG
TERM PLAN WHICH YOU'LL HEAR
ABOUT -- TO
RICH AND IMPROVE FOR YOUR
GRADUATION RATES IMPROVE
GRADUATION RATES AT CERTAIN
CAMPUSES WHERE THEY ARE LOWER.
AND ALSO REDUCE A GRADUATION
RATE ETHNICITY AND THEY'VE ALSO --
SUGGESTED SOME HIGH LEVEL.
USERS OF THE FUNDS FOR NINETEEN
TWENTY THEY HAVEN'T DEVELOPED A
MORE DETAILED EXPENDITURE PLAN
AND HOW CAMPUSES WOULD USE THE
FUNDS.
NOT CONCERN HERE IS IT'S NOT AND
YOU SEE ALSO --
A IS HE ALSO SAYS THAT CAMPUSES
WILL HAVE A LOT OF OF
FLEXIBILITY DECIDE HOW THEY
ALLOCATE THE FUNDS SO OUR
CONCERN HERE.
IS THAT --
IT'S UNCLEAR HOW EXACTLY HOW THE
FUNDS WOULD BE USED AND IT'S
UNCLEAR EXACTLY WHAT THE FUNDS
WOULD ACCOMPLISH AND ALSO IT'S
UNCLEAR WHETHER THE PROPOSED
FUNDING LEVEL.
IS JUSTIFIED OR IF IT'S TOO HIGH
OR TOO LOW TO ACCOMPLISH THE
OBJECTIVES THAT YOU SEE WANTS TO
ACCOMPLISH.
AND SO WE RECOMMEND THAT AS YOU
CONSIDER THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL
THAT YOU DIRECT YOU SEE TO HAVE
A A TO DEVELOP AN EXPENDITURE
PLAN THAT YOU CAN REVIEW BEFORE
APPROPRIATING THE FUNDS.
AND THEN THE THIRD ISSUE --
WE FOR THE COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER
IS ACCOUNTABILITY THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL UP A DOZEN PROPOSE.
ANYTHING WITH REGARD TO
REPORTING ON HOW THE FUNDS WILL
BE SPENT AFTER THE APPROPRIATED
OR SHOULD ANY ACCOUNTABILITY
EXPECTATIONS RATES ARE
ADDRESSING ACHIEVEMENT GAPS.
AND WE THINK BOTH ARE ESSENTIAL
TO ENSURE LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
AND AND SURE THAT THE FUNDS ARE
USED ACCORDING TO LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITY WE HAVE A FEW THOUGHTS
ON HOW THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT
ADOPT REPORTING LANGUAGE.
AND ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES WERE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH STAFF ON THAT
AND ALSO HAPPY TO ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
WELCOME REPORTING IS A BIG THING
FOR ME.
FOLKS IN THE OTHER BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR SIX YEARS OF
LISTEN TO MY LECTURE BUT GOALS
AND OBJECTIVES AND METRIC SO.
I'M VERY INTERESTED IN THAT --
LET ME ASK A QUESTION AND THEN --
MA'AM I'M SURE YOU HAVE SOME
SLIDES.
DO WE KNOW WHAT ACCOUNTS FOR THE
DIFFERENCE IN THE SIX YEAR
GRADUATION RATES --
BY --
MINORITY GROUP --
OUR RESEARCH SHOWS THAT IT HAS A
LOT TO DO WITH ACADEMIC
PREPARATION.
WHEN THEY COME INTO THE
UNIVERSITY AND THEY'RE BEING
FEWER PROGRAMS TO HELP THEM WITH
TUTORING AND MENTORING AVAILABLE
IF YOU SEE --
RUBY APPS NOW IS A GOOD TIME FOR
ME TO GO INTO MY SLIDES AND TALK
ABOUT HOW I WOULD SPEND THESE
FUNDS AND THEN THE AND THEN OF
COURSE I WILL AT SOME POINT I
WANT.
TO MY RECOLLECTION IS THE C.
ISSUE SYSTEM --
CHESTER TIM WHITE TO IS
IMPLEMENTED A PROGRAM WITH
RESPECT TO REMEDIAL COURSES AND
AND ESSENTIALLY IS MAINSTREAMING.
STUDENTS INTO MAINSTREAM COURSES
WITH APPROPRIATE SUPPORT AND
ASSISTANCE I ASSUME THE JURY'S
STILL OUT ON WHETHER THAT WORKS
OR NOT.
AND MY QUESTION TO YOU AT SOME
POINT WILL BE AS YOU SEE
CONSIDERING --
SOMETHING SIMILAR WHERE WE'RE
CONSIDERING OUR OWN FORM OF OF
SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS NOT
REMEDIAL COURSES BUT OUT OF GO
INTO THAT IN A LITTLE BIT --
LET YOU GET BACK ON TRACK THAT
AND I'LL SHUT UP GREAT --
RATE THAT YOU LET ME GET BACK ON
TRACK -- OUR
REQUEST FOR NINETEEN TWENTY SIX
TWO MILLION DOLLARS FOR THESE
pSORTS OF DEGREE COMPLETION
EFFORTS WHAT WE'RE CALLING OUR
STUDENT SUCCESS INITIATIVE --
WE ONE OF THE REGIONS HAVE SET
THE OVERALL GOALS BY --
TWENTY THIRTY FOUR THE SYSTEM TO
ACHIEVE A 90% OVERALL SIX YOUR
<c.cyan>RESHMAN GRADUATION WEEK AND</c>
FOUR YEAR GRADUATION TRANSFER
STUDENTS GRADUATION RATES.
WE WANT TO CLOSE THE GRADUATION
GAPS WERE PELL GRANT RECIPIENTS
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS IN
FIRST GENERATION STUDENTS.
AND WE WANT TO CLOSE OVERALL
DEGREE AND AND GAPS FOR PELL
GRANT RECIPIENTS UNDER
REPRESENTS STUDENTS FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS AND WOMEN.
AS PART OF THESE GOALS CAMPUSES
IDENTIFIED A NETWORK OF OVER
ARCHING CAMPUS STRATEGY SOME
PROGRAMS TO HELP WITH
UNDERGRADUATE DEGREE ATTAINMENT
STRATEGIES.
INCLUDING PRE MATRICULATION
PROGRAMS TEACHING AND LEARNING
CENTER STUDENT ADVISING HOLISTIC
APPROACHES THE STUDENT SUCCESS
AND INTEGRATING CO CURRICULAR
SUPPORT IN THE CLASSROOM.
WHAT YOU SEE ON FLIGHT TWENTY
SIX IS OUR LATEST FOUR YEAR
GRADUATION RATES --
THIS IS FOR THOSE STUDENTS WHO
STARTED AS FRESHMAN IN FALL
TWENTY FOURTEEN SO THEY JUST
GRADUATED IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND YOU WILL SEE
THERE ON THE LEFT THE PELL GRANT
AND NO --
NON PELL GRANT RECIPIENTS --
GRADUATION RATES WE'RE ON SLIDE
TWENTY SIX AND FELL GRANTS ARE
OFTEN USES A METRIC FOR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS --
THAT WOULD BE ABOUT FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER RENTAL
INCOME AND YOU'LL SEE THAT THE
THERE IS STILL AN ELEVEN POINT
7% FOUR YEAR DEGREE ATTAINMENT
GAP BETWEEN THOSE STUDENTS.
WHEN STUDENTS STAY LONGER SOME
OF THE IMPACTS ARE THERE TAKING
UP A SEAT ANOTHER STUDENT CAN
COME INTO?
OF AND ALSO THEY'RE TAKING ON
MORE PERSONAL LOANS BECAUSE
AFTER CAL GRANT BEGINS TO RUN
OUT AFTER FOUR YEARS.
THE UNIVERSITY STEPS IN AND A
FIFTY YEAR TO PROVIDE THEM WITH
TUITION ASSISTANCE TO OUR
FINANCIAL AID.
BUT THEN --
THAT THIS THE FINANCIAL AID
BEGINS TO RUN OUT AND STUDENTS
BEGIN TO HAVE TO RELY ON LOANS --
SO WE WANT TO GET THEM GRADUATED
FASTER SO THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
TO TAKE OUT THOSE LOANS IF
THEY'RE STAYING LONGER BECAUSE
OF KNOWING WHICH COURSES TO TAKE.
TO DO THE REMEDIAL COURSES KEEP
THEM.
ON CAMPUS LONGER.
WE DON'T HAVE VERY MANY REMEDIAL
COURSES BUT YES IT'S OFTEN
REPEATING COURSES NOT REALIZING
WHAT THEY HAVE TO TAKE AND
THAT'S THERE IN LIES THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE C. ISSUE
SYSTEM AND THE ADMISSION.
PRACTICES THERE AND YOU SEIZE
YOUR STUDENTS GENERALLY COME TO
YOU BECAUSE OF A THROUGH G..
QUALIFIED TO STEP RIGHT INTO THE
ENGLISH ONE OH ONE OR MATH.
ONE SOON YES THAT'S CORRECT OUR
STUDENTS ARE THE TAPPED TOP
TWELVE AND A HALF PERCENT.
OF THE CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATE SO THERE ARE COME TO US
BETTER PREPARED.
SO THE SIX YEAR ISSUE.
IN PRT HAS TO DO WITH I GUESS
YOU MENTION REPEATING CHORUSES
AND NON AVAILABILITY OF COURSE
IS NOT A NON AVAILABILITY OF
COURSES THEY NEED FOR THEIR
MAJOR TO GRADUATE WHAT WE CALL
BOTTOM THE COURSES.
SO THOSE COURSES THAT END UP
HAVING A LONG WAIT LISTED THEN
STUDENTS.
AND OF NOT GETTING THE CLASS AND
THEY HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL THE NEXT
TERM IN ORDER TO TAKE IT
CONSUMER INTEREST IN ONLINE.
AND YOUR INTEREST AND PERHAPS
PERHAPS UTILIZING ONLINE.
COURSE WORK TO RELIEVE SOME OF
THE BOTTLE NECK WERE WHERE IT'S
APPROPRIATE OF WHERE WE ARE
DEVELOPING OUR ONLINE CURRICULA --
EXPANDING THE OFFERINGS TO
STUDENTS AND WE ARE INTERESTED
IN CONTINUING ON THAT ROUTE.
BUT WE DO BELIEVE THAT --
THE BEST KIND IN THE CLASSROOM
FACE TO FACE WITH THE FACULTY
MEMBER -- IF
WE CAN.
WE CAN AFFORD TO HERD OF FACULTY
MEMBERS.
IN PARTICULAR AND YOU CAN FIND
THEM IN PARTICULAR FIELDS TO
RELIEVE THE BOTTLENECK COURSES
OTHERWISE WE MAY HAVE.
TO SOMETIMES SECOND BEST IS.
GOOD ENOUGH OF WE DEFINITELY
WANT TO CONTINUE.
TO DEVELOP MORE ONLINE COURSES
AS WELL AND DO WE KNOW WHETHER
THE SIX YEAR PROBLEM OR BEYOND
IS IS CAUSED IN PART BY CHANGES
IN MAJORS.
SOME OF IT IS I DON'T HAVE THAT
DATA IN FRONT OF ME WE I'M NOT
CERTAIN HOW GRANULAR OUR DATA
GOES IF WE CAN SEE.
IF THE STUDENTS CHANGED MAJORS --
I'LL HAVE TO TALK TO OUR DATA
FOLKS TO FIND OUT TO WHAT EVEL%
OF DETAIL WE CAN GET ON THAT.
HENCE THE GOVERNOR'S INTEREST IN
THE LONGITUDINAL STATEWIDE DATA
SYSTEM OR WHATEVER IT'S A VERY
EXCITING PROPOSAL.
THE STRUCTURED CORRECTLY COULD
GIVE DEFINITELY GOOD DATA I'LL
LET YOU CONTINUE PLEASE.
THANK YOU ON THE RIGHT YOU SEE
THE FRESHMAN CORE HER TO ENTERED
IN FALL TWENTY FOURTEEN BROKEN
DOWN BY ETHNICITY.
AND YOU'LL NOTICE THAT THERE
REMAIN GAPS IN THE GRADUATION
CAPS --
GRADUATION RATES BETWEEN OOPS
WITHIN YOU SEE.
THE REGION'S WANT TO ADDRESS
THIS PROBLEM AND MAKE CERTAIN
THAT ALLOUR STUDENTS HAVE THE
ASSISTANCE THEY NEED TO HAVE AN
EXCELLENT EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE
AND GRADUATE IN A TIMELY MATTER.
GRADUATING FASTER USUALLY MEANS
LESS DEATH AND STUDENTS ARE THAT
THE STUDENTS ARE TAKING ON IN
NINETEEN TWENTY A PORTION OF THE
REQUESTED SIXTY MILLION WOULD BE
USED TO HIRE.
THIRTY SEVEN FACULTY THAT WERE
SHOWN ON SLIDE TWENTY ONE YOU
DON'T NEED TO GO BACK BUT THERE
WERE TWO ROWS AND AS THE STUDENT
SUCCESS INITIATIVES THIRTY SEVEN
FACULTY WOULD BE HIRED IN
NINETEEN TWENTY WITH THESE FUNDS
THE SIXTY MILLION.
OF THESE ADDITIONAL LOTTERING
FACULTY WILL BE NEEDED TO HELP
ACHIEVE THE GOALS OF GRADUATING
STUDENTS FASTER PARTICULAR WITH
FIRST YEAR PROGRAMMING
CURRICULAR INNOVATIONS.
pSUPPORT IN THE CLASSROOM.
THE REMAINDER OF THE FUNDS WILL
BE SPENT ON THE CAMPUS
STRATEGIES TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS.
STUDENT SERVICES AND ENSURE THAT
ACADEMICALLY STUDENTS STAY ON
TRACK -- SO
SLIDE TWENTY SEVEN INCLUDES A
BREAKDOWN OF HOW WE WOULD SPEND --
SPEND THE FUNDING FOR THE SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS AND YOU'LL SEE
WE HAVE VARIOUS PROGRAMS OF
WHERE.
SYSTEM WIDE INTENDING TO SPEND
THE FUNDS ON ADVISING AND HIRING
NEW FACULTY ARE THE LARGEST OF
THE TWO MAKING CERTAIN THAT
STUDENTS KNOW WHICH CLASSES THEY
NEED TO TAKE UNDERSTAND WHICH
CLASSES CAN BE SWAPPED OUT FOR
WHICH ONES.
AND SO FORTH.
AND THEN ON SLIDE TWENTY EIGHT I
GIVE YOUR KIND OF A BUSY SLIDE
BUT SAMPLING OF WHAT THE VARIOUS
CAMPUSES WOULD DO.
IF THEY RECEIVED THESE FINDS
THAT THEY TOLD US THAT ARE
WITHIN THEIR PLANS.
SOME OF THESE THINGS INCLUDE --
THING AND COHORTS WHERE YOU HAVE
A SMALLER GROUP OF STUDENTS WHO
SUPPORT EACH OTHER IN PEER TO
PEER MENTORING.
AND TAKE COURSES TOGETHER AND
WE'RE FINDINGTHAT THIS MAY BE
AN APPROACH --
TO HELP FIRST YEAR AND
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITY
STUDENTS FEEL MORE ACCEPTED IN
THE UNIVERSITY SETTING BY HAVING
THIS CALL HER TO HELP THEM.
TAKE CLASSES THEY WOULD STUDY
TOGETHER THEY WOULD BE IN THE
VARIOUS COURSES TOGETHER A MOVE
TO THE PROGRAMS --
AS A UNIT AND I WOULD HELP
CREATE SOME COHESION WITH THEM --
A LOT OF THE FUNDS WOULD BE
SPENT ON ADDITIONAL ADVISING.
ADDITIONAL DATA TRACKING TOOLS
THAT WOULD HELLO ADVISERS WHEN A
STUDENT STOPS TAKING THE COURSES
THEY NEED. FOR THEIR MAJOR --
THAT WOULD HELP THE ADVISER
IDENTIFY THAT STUDENT BEING
PERSONAL CONTACT AND LET THE
STUDENTS KNOW HOW TO GET BACK ON
TRACK ACADEMICALLY.
HOW ARE YOU --
WILL THERE BE A SEE IF I CAN ASK
A QUESTION.
WILL THERE BE A TALKING ABOUT
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS A
REPORTING REQUIREMENT AND AND
ANALYSIS.
PROCESS WHERE THESE VARIOUS NEW
PROGRAMS COULD BE ANALYZED IN
THE BEST OF THEM.
SORT OF RANKED IN DECISIONS MADE
AS TO WHICH SHOULD CONTINUE AND
WHICH SHOULD NOT.
I WOULD ASSUME THAT.
SOME OF THESE MAY BE MORE
SUCCESSFUL THAN OTHERS.
I WOULD ASSUME SO SIR SIR AS
WELL -- WE
WERE AT THE MOMENT LONG LOOK
INTO THE CAMPUSES TO DO THEIR
OWN INTERNAL ASSESSMENT ON
WHETHER OR NOT THE PROGRAMS ARE
SUCCESSFUL.
BUT I WOULD BE HAPPY TO WORK
WITH YOU AND YOUR STAFF ON
REPORTING LANGUAGE THAT THE
UNIVERSITY COULD COME BACK AND
TALK TO YOU ABOUT WHICH ONE OF
OUR PROGRAMS COULD BE REPLICATED
SYSTEM WIDE AND WHICH ONES HAD A
REAL IMPACT.
WELL -- THE
REASON I WOULD ASK THE QUESTION
IS I MEAN IT COULD VERY WELL BE
FOR EXAMPLE THAT [inaudible]
BERKELEY'S PROGRAM.
INCREASING ACADEMIC ADVISORS AND
CETERA AND THE WAY THE BERKELEY
IS STRUCTURES THAT ULTIMATELY --
IS BETTER THAN THE ONE THE
PROGRAM THAT SAN DIEGO PUT IN
PLAY IT PUTS IN PLACE FOR
STUDENT SUCCESS IN TERMS OF
OUTCOMES.
AND SAN DIEGO MAYBE NEEDS TO
TAKE A LOOK AT BERKELEY'S
PROGRAM.
OR VICE VERSA HEAVEN FORBID
RIVERSIDE MIGHT HAVE A BETTER
IDEA THAN BERKELEY WELL THEN WE
WOULD TAKE RIVERSIDE IS THAT
MAKES SENSE YES IT MAKES SENSE
TO DEVELOP BEST PRACTICES ACROSS
THE SYSTEM AND SEE WHICH HOW HOW
THE PROGRAMS ARE STRUCTURED.
THAT MAY HAVE MADE THE MORE
SUCCESSFUL THAN A DIFFERENT
MATTER OF STRUCTURING A SIMILAR
PROGRAM RIGHT IN THE MILITARY WE
CALL IT CROSS FEED BUT I DON'T
KNOW.
YOU YOU WOULD CROSS FEED YOUR
PROGRAMS AND SO PEOPLE COULD
CHERRY PICK THE BEST ONES AND
STEAL THEM AND PUT THEM IN PLACE
INSTEAD OF THE ONES THAT THEY
TRIED AND PERHAPS WEREN'T AS
SUCCESSFUL.
OF WE'D BE HAPPY TO COME BACK TO
THIS COMMITTEE WITH --
METRICS AND WITHIN A SOUTH WORK
GOOD IDEA THESE LOOK LIKE GOOD
IDEAS.
THANK YOU.
THE NET NEXT ITEM IS THE NEXT
ITEM ON THE AGENDA.
A LOOK THE FINANCE WHEN WE TAKE
A FIVE MINUTE BREAK AND THEN
COME BACK AND WE'LL PICK UP WITH
THE ISSUE NUMBER [inaudible]
FIVE EXTENDED EDUCATION
ENDED
EDUCATION.
YES THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROVIDES EASY WITH FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND TO EXPAND AND PILOT DEGREE
AND CERTIFICATE OR DEGREE
COMPLETION PROGRAMS AND EXPENSE
TICKET PROGRAMS EXTENSION
CENTERS.
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS HAVE
SOME CLLEGE BERNARD GREED.
AND THE MISSION ADMINISTRATION'S
GOALS TO CONNECT TO STUDENTS.
AND PROVIDE ADDITIONAL EDUCATION
SO THEY CAN RECEIVE A DEGREE
CERTIFICATE OR OTHER POTENTIAL
TO THRIVE ACCESS ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES ACHIEVE GREATER
SUCCESS.
THANK YOU.
WELL HOLD MY COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS ILIO.
WE HAD A NUMBER OF CONCERNS OF
THIS PROPOSAL AND ALL RACE THREE
CONCERNS FOR THE COMMITTEE.
THE FIRST IS THAT THIS PROPOSAL
LACKS A LOT OF SPECIFICS.
ON HOW THE FUND TO BE SPENT THE
ADMINISTRATION NOTES THAT THE
FRONT IS HERE AND IT SEEMS BASED
ON WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
INDICATED THAT THE KEY PRIORITY
FOR THE FUNDS WOULD BE TO CREATE
NEW BACK.
BACHELOR'S DEGREE COMPLETION
PROGRAMS FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE SOME COLLEGE BUT NO DEGREE
THE MISSION MINISTRATION NOTES
OTHER ACTIVITIES THOSE SUCH AS
OUT REACH.
AN EXPANDING CERTIFICATE
PROGRAMS AND THOSE ARE VERY ALL
DIFFERENT ACTIVITIES THAT
POTENTIALLY GO TO ADDRESS
DIFFERENT ISSUES.
WITHOUT MORE SPECIFICITY ON THE
USE OF THE FUNDS IT'S DIFFICULT
TO KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THE FUNDS
WOULD ACCOMPLISH AND ALSO IT'S
DIFFICULT.
TO UNDERSTAND WHETHER THE
PROPOSED FUNDING LEVELS EVEN IF
THE LEGISLATURE HAD MORE
SPECIFIC INFORMATION RIGHT
INFORMATION.
OF IT'S STILL UNCLEAR WHETHER
STATE FUNDING IS NEEDED TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS OBJECTIVE.
USE THE EXTENSION IS A SELF
SUPPORTING ENTERPRISE AND PART
OF A U. C. EXTENSION CENTERS.
OF REGULAR OPERATING ACTIVITIES
IS TO PLAN FOR AND DEVELOP NEW
PROGRAMS.
AND WE DON'T FEEL THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS MADE A
COMPELLING CASE THAT MORE STATE
FUNDING IS IS NEEDED.
TO CREATE THESE NEW PROGRAMS.
THIRD.
WE KNOW THAT CS YOU ALSO ALREADY
HAS A BACHELOR'S DEGREE
COMPLETION PROGRAMS OFFERED
THROUGH EXTENDED EDUCATION.
AND THAT RAISES ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS FOR US WITH THESE
PROPOSED NEW PROGRAMS BE
DUPLICATIVE WOULD THEY BE ADDING
SOMETHING DIFFERENT THAN WHAT IT
SEES YOU PROGRAMS OFFER.
AND WHAT IS THE ADVANTAGE OF
EXPANDING PROGRAMS THAT YOU SEE
INSTEAD OF CS YOU WHERE IS THAT
THERE ARE MORE --
NINE COMPUTERS FROM CS YOU GIVEN
THAT THEY ENROLL MORE STUDENTS
AND HAVE LOWER GRADUATION RATES.
GIVEN THESE QUESTIONS WE
RECOMMEND YOU REJECT THIS
PROPOSAL FOR THIS YEAR.
AND WHILE THE NEW ADMINISTRATION
TO COME BACK BY THE NEXT YEAR
AND LATER TIME WITH A MORE
FLESHED OUT PROPOSAL.
WHAT -- ME I
WILL HAVE SOME QUESTIONS IF
YOU'LL LET ME OF I WENT HAD
DIFFICULT --
FIRST I WANT TO COMMEND THE
MINISTRATION FOR GOT SOME VERY
VERY BOLD --
CONCEPTS AND IDEAS IN THIS
BUDGET I THINK IT'S REFRESHING
AND THEY'RE ALL AREAS THAT NEED.
TO NEED TO HAVE --
DISCUSSION AND FOCUS ON THIS
PARTICULAR --
ONE I WAS UNCLEAR AS TO WHAT THE
IN GAME.
IS OR IS TO BE IS IT IS IT TO
GET TO GET A A BACHELOR'S DEGREE
IS IT.
TO ATTAIN A SKILL LEVEL --
BECAUSE THE NOTE I MADE TO
MYSELF ON THE AGENDA.
ISN'T THIS REALLY THE MISSION OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM INDOOR.
C. T. E. N. THE EDUCATIONAL
CONSORTIA THAT WE'VE STRUCTURED
IN ANOTHER SETTING. TO FOCUS ON
THE DEMAND SIDE JOBS AND SKILLS
THAT ARE NEEDED AND DESIGN
TRAINING PROGRAMS TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF EMPLOYERS UP AND DOWN
THE STATE.
THE GOAL HERE IS THE OTHER MANY
STUDENTS THAT --
THAT BUT LEAVE THE SCENE THEY
HAVE QUITE A FEW AN INSTANT AND
FOR WHATEVER REASON THEY ARE NOW
OUT OF THE SYSTEM WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE PROGRAMS
THERE ARE ACCESSIBLE FOR
STUDENTS THAT. FOR EXAMPLE MIGHT
BE WORKING --
TO COME BACK AND COMPLETE THEIR
DEGREE I MEAN IT'S NO SECRET
THAT SETS THE WORKERS WITH
BACHELOR'S DEGREES SIR FOR
ASSISTANCE WITH OTHER
CERTIFICATES. FOR MORE THAN
STUDENTS WITHOUT THEM SO THE
GOAL IS TO CREATE THE GET THOSE
CREDENTIALS AND THEN SEEK HIGHER
PAIRED PLACEMENT.
SO THAT'S DOWN THE PASSAGE
GREECE SIDE THERE IS A LARGE
PROPORTION OF STUDENTS WHO HAVE
FIVE BELIEVE IT'S GREATER THAN A
IN TWO YEARS OF STEVE UNITS I
THINK HE SEES MENTION THAT
PREVIOUS HEARINGS OR OTHER
VENUES --
AND ON THE CERTIFICATE SIDE.
UC'S EXTENSION PRESENTERS OFFER
NUMBER CERTIFICATES --
THIS ISN'T PARTICULARLY --
AND A NEW ROUND FOR FREE SIX
TENSION CENTERS OF PERSONS WITH
PERHAPS WITH FEAR UNITS.
MIGHT BE ABLE TO FIND --
ANOTHER CREDENTIAL THAT MAYBE
NOT BE AS EXTENSIVE AS RASHES
DEGREE BUT THEY CERTAINLY HAVE
SKILLS AND EDUCATION THAT COULD
BE CAPTURED AND AND SORT OF
RECOGNIZE THROUGH CERTIFICATE
PROGRAM.
WELL I'LL BE INTERESTED TO HEAR --
UC'S PERSPECTIVE --
INCLUDING WHETHER OR NOT YOU SEE
HAS A SORT OF A WRIST RETURN TO
SCHOOL PROGRAM FOR SOMEONE WHO
FOR WHATEVER REASON.
IS IN UC DAVIS FOR TWO YEARS AND
THEN RUNS OUT OF MONEY OR HAS
FAMILY ISSUES.
CAUSES THEM.
TO LEAVE THE PROGRAM IN THE
CAMPUS IF THERE'S A IF THERE'S A
SYSTEM IN PLACE. TO TO BRING
THAT STUDENT BACK INTO THE UC
SYSTEM TO ALLOW.
DEGREE COMPLETION OF NUMBER ONE
IN IF THE YOU SEE EXTENSION.
PROGRAM WITH VARIOUS CAMPUSES IS
REALLY THE PROPER PLACE FOR THIS
SORT OF RETURN TO SCHOOL AND GET
YOUR DEGREE --
PROGRAM OUR CONCEPT OF THOSE ARE
MY TWO QUESTIONS.
HOPEFULLY THE ANSWERS ARE BURIED
IN YOUR PRESENTATION SO.
HOPEFULLY AND IF NOT I WILL
ADDRESS THEM --
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ON THIS ITEM --
WE'RE VERY PLEASED THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS RECOGNIZED THAT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA HAS A
ROLE -- IN
DEGREE COMPLETION FOR STUDENTS
WHO HAVE LEFT WITHOUT DEGREES
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY NINE OVER
SIXTY EIGHT THOUSAND STUDENTS
LEFT YOU SEE WITH NO DEGREE.
ONLY ABOUT ONE FOURTH OF THOSE
GO ON TO ANOTHER INSTITUTION
LATER TO COMPLETE A DEGREE.
SO THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY HERE
TO HELP THESE FORMER STUDENTS
COMPLETE THEIR DEGREES AND BEGIN
EARNING HIGHER SALARIES AFTER
ABOUT FIVE YEARS A GRADUATION --
UC STUDENTS ARE EARNING FAR
HIGHER SALARIES THAN THOSE WHO
NEVER GET A BACHELOR'S DEGREE --
WE'RE STILL DEVELOPING THE PLAN
FOR HOW WE WOULD.
EXACTLY RUN THIS PROGRAM THIS IS
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL DID NOT
ORIGINALLY ASSOC ORIGINATE WITH
OUR REGIONS BUT WE ARE.
DEBATING A PILE THE DESIGN FOR
DEGREE COMPLETION FOR UC
STUDENTS.
OF WITH POTENTIAL EXPANSION TO
OTHER INSTITUTE STUDENTS WHO
DROPPED OUT OF OTHER
INSTITUTIONS BUT WE WOULDFOCUS
ON YOU SEE STUDENTS INITIALLY --
WE WOULD DO A CROSSING THE
FINISH LINE PROGRAM FOR STUDENTS
WHO HAVE VERY FEW COURSES TO GO --
AND WE WOULD ALSO LIKE THE LA --
SENT OFF FOR EXPANDED
CERTIFICATE PROGRAMS FOR GREATER
EMPLOYEE ABILITY TO GO WITH A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE.
TOTE KIND OF PAIRED THE TWO UP
EITHER EX EXISTING OR NEW
CERTIFICATE STUFF WE WOULD
CREATE.
SO THAT PEOPLE --
WOULD FIND IT EASIER TO REENTER
THE WORKFORCE.
OF THIS FUNDING WOULD BE USED
FOR OUTREACH TO FORMER UC
STUDENTS WHO DO NOT HAVE WHO
HAVE NOT ATTAINED A DEGREE --
IT WILL BE USED FOR HIGH TOUCH
STUDENT ACADEMIC SUPPORT SO A
LOT OF BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN
THE ADVISER AND STUDENT --
AND FINANCIAL AID TO NEEDY
STUDENTS TO PAY FOR THESE YOU
SEE EXTENSION COURSES.
SO ON SLIDE ON THIRTY YOU SEE A
BIT ABOUT WHO THESE STUDENTS ARE
WHO LEAVE WITHOUT A DEGREE --
AND IT WAS QUITE SURPRISING TO
ME PERSONALLY TO SEE.
THAT 36% OF THOSE WHO DROP OUT
DROP OFF WITH A HUNDRED UNITS OR
MORE COMPLETED.
A YOU SEE YOU NEED USUALLY ABOUT
HUNDRED TWENTY DEGREE UNITS TO
COMPLETE A DEGREE SO THE
STUDENTS REPRESENT LOW HANGING
FRUIT TO BRING THEM BACK.
AND HAVE THEM COMPLETE THEIR
DEGREES AND START PAYING --
MORE TAXES A STATE GOT BETTER
PAYING JOBS.
UP IN TERMS OF YOU SEE HAVING
ALREADY A PROGRAM LIKE THIS WE
IF A STUDENT TAKES DROPS OUT AND
COMES BACK WITHIN A SHORT AMOUNT
OF TIME I BELIEVE IT'S TWO YEARS.
THEY CAN BE READMITTED THAT OUR
CAMPUS OF ORIGIN.
BUT WE DON'T HAVE A READMISSION
PROGRAM WHO HAVE BEEN GONE. FOR
FIVE YEARS TEN YEARS --
THEY WOULD NEED TO APPLY THE UC
CAMPUS AS A REGULAR
UNDERGRADUATE.
ADMIT WHICH IS HARDER FOR AN
OLDER STUDENT --
TO DO THAT [inaudible]
AND HARDER PARTLY BECAUSE
THERE'S NO FINANCIAL AID
ASSOCIATED AND ALSO WE WOULD
JUDGE THEM ON THEIR PRIOR GPA --
SO BY BRINGING THEM IN FOR
EXTENSION HAVING THEM TAKE --
EXTENSION COURSES --
AND SHOW THAT THEY CAN EARN.
GOOD GRADES WE WOULD THEN
TRANSFER THOSE UNITS ON TO THE
CAMPUS.
AND HAVE THE CAMPUS OF MAJOR
GRANT THEM THE DEGREE WAS AS I
SIT HERE.
I MEAN I CAN THINK OF SOME I WAS
WONDERING WHY YOU SEE EXTENSION
BUT I CAN THINK OF SOME.
DEFINITE ADVANTAGES FOR THE TYPE
OF STUDENT GROUP THAT YOU'RE.
HOPING TO HELP HERE.
THE COURSES ARE GENERALLY TAUGHT
IN THE EVENINGS.
SO FOR SOMEONE WHO'S WORKING.
FOR TAKING CARE OF A FAMILY
THERE MAY BE MORE OPPORTUNITY TO
GO BACK IN AND COMPLETE THE
COURSEBECAUSE OF THE EVENING
STRUCTURE OF UC EXTENSION.
BUT I'M WONDERING DO WE HAVE ANY
IDEA FOR THESE STUDENTS WHO
LEAVE.
I MEAN ARE THERE CERTAIN COMMON
COURSES THAT THEY LACK HOW HOW
WOULD YOU DESIGN A OF A PROGRAM
INSIDE OF YOU SEE EXTENSION TO
ADDRESS [inaudible]
VARIED [inaudible]
ACADEMIC NEEDS.
AM I MAKING YES YOU'RE MAKING
SENSOR -- WE
HAVE NOT YET CONSIDERED THIS I
HAVEN'T SEEN THE ANALYSIS OF
WHAT IS THE COMMON DENOMINATOR
AMONG THE STUDENTS.
OTHER THAN THE NUMBER OF UNITS
THEY COMPLETED PRIOR TO LEAVING
THE UNIVERSITY AND THEN IN TERMS
OF THE WELL I GUESS WE DON'T
HAVE THE PLAN YET BUT IN TERMS
OF THE THE COST STRUCTURE IN THE
THE FINANCES OF ALL OF THIS USE
THE EXTENSION IS.
MUCH DIFFERENT.
AND OPERATES IN A MUCH DIFFERENT
WAY.
OBLIQUE FROM A BUDGETARY
STANDPOINT INSIDE THE UC
ORGANIZATION.
FROM WHAT THE STUDENTS PAY TO
GET IN WHAT THEY PAY TO GET
THEIR CERTIFICATE OR THEIR
PROGRAM MUCH DIFFERENT THAN.
THE TRADITIONAL UC CAMPUS COURSE
THINK YES USUALLY THE EXTENSION
COURSES ARE SELF SUPPORTING
MEANING THATTHEY HAVE TO THE
FEES CHARGED THE STUDENTS HAVE
TO COVER ALL OF THE EXPENDITURES
OF RUNNING THAT EXTENSION
PROGRAM.
THE REASON YOU SEE EXTENSION WAS
SELECTED AS THAT THEY DO A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF OUTREACH
CURRENTLY. TO TRY AND PULL IN
STUDENTS INTO THESE EVENING
PROGRAMS TO IDENTIFY WHO IS A
STUDENT POPULATION WHO WOULD
BENEFIT FROM THIS --
THE CAMPUS DEPARTMENTS TWO
STUDENTS WHO MIGHT BE STATEWIDE
AND HAVE DROPPED OUT ALSO USE
THE EXTENSION IS WHERE WE RUN A
LOT OF ONLINE COURSES OUT OF SO
MAKING THOSE AVAILABLE.
THE DATE THEY RUN THEY OPERATE A
LOT OF THE PLATFORMS THEY DO A
LOT OF THE CONTRACTING TO
DEVELOP THE COURSES.
AND THE MAINTENANCE --
IS DONE.
BY EXTENSION FOR VARIOUS.
PROGRAMS ALREADY FOR ONLINE SO
IF WE WERE TO USE ONLINE
PLATFORMS TO OFFER THE STUDENTS
OF WAY TO COMPLETE THEIR COURSES.
EXTENSION WOULD ALREADY HAVE
SOME OF THAT INFRASTRUCTURE IN
PLACE.
AND IT'S A MUCH MORE USER
FRIENDLY ENVIRONMENT FOR SOMEONE
WHO IS.
NO LONGER CUSTOM TO TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET ON A
CAMPUS AND FIND A PARKING SPACE
AND THAT'S CORRECT IFSOMEBODY --
HAS A FULL TIME DAY JOB IN A
COUPLE OF KIDS THEY'RE PROBABLY
NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO TAKE.
THREE HOURS OFF ON A TUESDAY IN
ORDER TO COME AND ATTEND A
COURSE.
IN CONVINCING MYSELF.
WE WE WILL BRING YOU UP A
REVISED PROPOSAL AS AS IT.
BECOMES MORE DEVELOPED WHERE
REQUESTING YOUR CONSIDERATION I
LOOK FORWARD TO IS TO SEEING
THIS I MEAN I SEE THE NEED AND
I'M I'M NOW.
TALKING MYSELF INTO THE THE WHY
OF UC EXTENSION I CAN SEE SOME
DEFINITE ADVANTAGES FOR USING
THAT -- THAT
TYPE OF PROGRAM AND FACILITY TO
TRY TO BRING PEOPLE BACK WHO.
MAY BE RELUCTANT TO COME BACK
INTO CAMPUS EXPERIENCE I ASSUME
RIVERSIDE FOR EXAMPLE IS OFTEN
IS OFF CAMPUS.
AND I ASSUMES OTHER CAMPUSES MAY
BE OFF CAMPUS AS WELL SO IT'S A
MUCH MORE FRIENDLY ENVIRONMENT --
FOR THE OCCASIONAL STUDENT.
THAT'S CORRECT SIR.
OKAY ANYTHING ELSE ON ISSUE
NUMBER.
FIVE LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE
SEVEN YES THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
ON GOING GENERAL FUND TO ADDRESS
STUDENT HUNGER AND HOMELESSNESS
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA --
THE UC'S BUDGET PROPOSAL CALLED
SPECIFICALLY FOR NET FOR
FINANCIAL AID.
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL IS
BROADER ALIGN THE YOUSIF --
THE ABILITY TO USE THESE FUNDS
TO SUPPORT EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE CREATED FOR THE
HUNGER FOR CAMPUS INITIATIVES
THAT THAT IS FOOD PANTRIES --
MILL SHARING PROGRAMS CAL FRESH
TOWARD NATION TO GET STUDENTS
ENROLLED IN BENEFITS --
AS WELL AS EFFORTS TO HOUSE
HOMELESS STUDENTS AND HOUSING
AND SECURE STUDENTS.
I AM AS WELL AS THEIR INITIAL
PROPOSAL.
AS YOU HERE FOR A MINUTE FROM
YOU SEE THE UNIVERSITY IS
CURRENTLY DECIDING HOW TO
ALLOCATE THESE FUNDS IS IT AS
THE ADMINISTRATION NOTED YOU SEE
WHAT I HAVE SOME.
FLEXIBILITY TO DECIDE WHETHER
THIS WOULD SUPPORT FINANCIAL
LATER FOOD AND HOUSING
INITIATIVES OR A MIX OF THE TWO
AND YOU KNOW THE UNIVERSITY.
GENERALLY WILL PROVIDE MORE
INFORMATION ON ON WHERE THEY'RE
AT IN THOSE DISCUSSIONS.
IN TERMS OF THINKING ABOUT THIS
ISSUE WE HAVE SOME ISSUES FOR
THE COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER AS
IT'S REVIEWING THIS PROPOSAL.
THE FIRST IS TO THINK ABOUT THE
UNDERLYING CAUSES OF FOOD AND
HOUSING AND SECURITY --
IF YOU LOOK AT THE RATES OF EACH
EACH OF OUR FOOD SECURITY AT UC
OTHER ROUGHLY COMPARABLE TO
RATES THAT ARE REPORTED BY THE
OTHER TWO SEGMENTS YES YOU
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
BUT THEY'RE MUCH HIGHER THAN UP
INSECURITY FOR THE STATE
POPULATION FOR EXAMPLE.
ENDED ACCORDING TO YOU SEE
BETWEEN SECURITIES VERY
PERVASIVE THROUGHOUT THE STUDENT
BODY FOR EXAMPLE STUDENTS WHO
COME FROM HOUSEHOLDS EARNING A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
OR MORE A YEAR ALSO REPORT FOOD
SECURITY ABOUT A QUARTER OF THEM
REPORT THAT.
SO IF YOU APPEAR TO BE VERY
PERVASIVE THROUGHOUT --
THE STUDENT BODY.
THERE COULD BE A NUMBER OF
CAUSES BEHIND THIS WOULDN'T
SECURITY COULD RANGE FROM.
LACK OF RESOURCES TO PERHAPS
LACK OF AWARENESS OF VARIOUS
FINANCIAL AID AND PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO COVER COSTS.
STUDENTS IN THEIR HOUSEHOLD
COULD ALSO BEHAVE DIFFERENTLY
THAN WHAT'S ASSUMED AND YOU SEE
IS A MODEL FOR EXAMPLE THEY MAY --
BAR LESSER WORK LAST WERE --
PREFER TO CONTRIBUTE CLASS --
ARE ARE HAVE HIGHER COSTS THAN
MOTORISTS SOON WHO IS WE WE KNOW
THE PERCENTAGES BUT WE DON'T
KNOW WHY RIGHT EXACTLY THE
UNDERLYING CAUSES.
IS IT STILL A BIT OF A BLACK BOX
AT LEAST IN OUR REVIEW OF THE
DATA.
PERHAPS YOU SEE WILL HAVE --
SOME BETTER INFORMATION ON THAT
AND HOW TO ADDRESS THE SITUATION
DO YOU PROVIDE MORE FINANCIALLY
DO YOU EXPAND FOOD AND HOUSING.
AN INITIATIVE DO YOU PROVIDE
FINANCIAL LITERACY COURSES ALL
THESE ADDRESS KIND OF DIFFERENT
CAUSES AND SO WITHOUT REALLY
HAVING A FULLER PICTURE OF THAT
IT'S IT'S DIFFICULT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO ASSESS --
THAT DISCUSSION BETWEEN
FINANCIAL AID AND FOOD AND
HOUSING INITIATIVES ON THE
CAMPUSES.
THE SECOND ISSUE TO CONSIDER IS --
KIND OF THE INTERACTION BETWEEN
FINANCIAL AID IN PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE.
USUALLY DOESN'T HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE DATA ON SOON
PARTICIPATION IN CAL FRESH FOR
EXAMPLE BUT SOME EVIDENCE
SUGGESTS THAT THERE THERE COULD
BE OTHER STUDENTS WHO COULD
BENEFIT FROM PUBLIC ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS AND ARE CURRENTLY DOING
SO. FOR EXAMPLE IN THE AND THE
FIRST OF HALF OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
YOU SEE REPORTS THAT IT AND
ROLLED OVER TEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS ON THE CAL FRESH.
NOT SUGGEST THAT THERE THERE
COULD HAVE BEEN A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF STUDENTS WHO MAYBE
WEREN'T AWARE THAT THEY COULD
ACCESS THOSE BENEFITS AND SO.
GETTING MORE INFORMATION ON THAT
COULD HELP THE LEGISLATURE
ASSESS WHETHER IT SHOULD ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES THROUGH FINANCIAL
LATER PUBLIC ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS
OR SOME MIX OF THAT.
THE THIRD ISSUE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER IS
INEQUITIES BETWEEN THE DIFFERENT
SEGMENTS --
RIGHT NOW YOU SEE PROVIDES --
SUBSTANTIALLY MORE AMOUNT OF AID
FOR LIVING COSTS THAN US YES YOU
IN COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AND THAT MEANS THAT STUDENTS TO
GO TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND SEE
IF YOU MIGHT HAVE TO BORROW MORE
OR WORKING LONGER HOURS TO COVER
COSTS.
AND IN RECENT YEARS THE
LEGISLATURE HAS TRIED TO ADDRESS
THE GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING TO
PROVIDE ONGOING FUNDS.
FOR FOOD AND HOUSING AND
SECURITY AT UC BUT ONE TIME
FUNDS FOR C. AS YOU AND DOESN'T
HAVE AN ASSOCIATED PROPOSAL FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
ALTHOUGH IT IS AS YOU'LL HEAR IN
A LATER SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING
THERE IS A PROPOSAL --
REGARDING --
CAL GRANTS THAT LARGELY AFFECTS
A PORTION OF STUDENTS AT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AT THAT
ADDRESS THE FUNDS MOVE GREATER
LIVING COSTS THROUGH FINANCIAL
AID.
AND THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT
TO CONSIDER WHETHER IT SHOULD
PRIORITIZE ON GOING.
WHERE THEY'RE?
FINANCIALLY AS GREAT AS FOR
EXAMPLE AT CSU AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND ONE WAY THE
LEGISLATURE WHEN ONE TOOL JUST
LIKE YOUR HOUSE IS AT ITS
DISPOSABLE DISPOSAL FUSE ME.
IS THE CAL GRANT BE AXIS AWARD
WHICH COVERS LIVING COSTS
PRIMARILY FOR STUDENTS AT CSUN
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SO THERE'S
SOME ISSUES TO CONSIDER IS
REVIEWING THIS PROPOSAL.
AND THEN OF COURSE.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS IN AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEVEL FOR FOR
EXAMPLE IF YOUR OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL FOR A FEW YEARS YOU DON'T
QUALIFY FOR THE KELLGREN
ENTITLEMENT IN YOUR IN THE
COMPETITIVE POOL IN THEIR THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND OR SO.
APPLICANTS IN. TWENTY FIVE OR
THIRTY THOUSAND PEOPLE ACTUALLY
GET IT SO SUGGESTS THAT THERE
ARE A COUPLE ON A COUPLE HUNDRED
THOUSAND FOLKS IF THEY ALL GO.
EVEN THOUGH THEY DIDN'T GET
KELLGREN ASSISTANTS WHO WERE
FLOATING AROUND WITH IT WITHOUT
ANY FINANCIAL AID.
I GUESS.
THAT THAT IS TRUE THAT --
IF YOU WHICH IF YOU DON'T
QUALIFY FOR AN ENTITLEMENT AND
YOU HAVE TO YOU'RE SORT OF LEFT
IN THAT COMPETITIVE POOL THERE
IS A PROPOSAL TO TELL.
EXPAND THAT A LIMIT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S MAKING BUT YES --
THERE MANY STUDENTS WHO DON'T
QUALIFY FOR ENTITLEMENT ARE LEFT.
TO WITH THOSE ARE LIMITED NUMBER
OF COMPETITIVE WORDS WHICH
UNDOUBTEDLY.
CONTRIBUTES TO FOOD AND SECURITY.
IF YOU THOUGHT OF FINANCIAL AID
AND YOU NEED.
OKAY THANK YOU THANKS FOR THE
HOPEFULLY WE CAN DRILL DOWN AND
GET SOME DATA AS TO WHY.
I WAS SHOCKED BY THE NUMBERS
ACTUALLY THE PERCENTAGES --
OF THOSE STUDENTS EXPERIENCING
FOOD IN SECURITY AND OF THE 26%
OF FRESHMEN WITH FAMILY INCOMES
ABOVE A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
EXPERIENCING FOOD INSECURITY
REALLY SHOCKED ME SO.
IT WOULD BE INTERESTING TO FIND
OUT WHY.
YOU SEE.
OF WE REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL --
I WANTED TO GO LITTLE BIT OVER
HOW WE CAME UP WITH THIS FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLAR.
AMOUNT.
IF WE HAD RAISED TUITION THE
FIFTEEN MILLION IS THE AMOUNT OF
WOULD HAVE GONE TO FINANCIAL AID
OUT OF THAT AMOUNT SO THAT'S HOW
WE CAME UP WITH THE NUMBER.
FIFTEEN A MILLION AND YOU'LL
HEAR PEOPLE REFER TO IT AS
SOMETIMES A FINANCIAL AID
PROPOSAL.
SINCE WE SUBMIT THAT PROPOSAL
THE GOVERNOR WE HAVE HEARD FROM
MANY OF OUR STUDENTS AND THE ODD
THE REGIONS HAVE ALSO CONSIDERED
THIS.
ITEM THIS AMOUNT OF FUNDING AND
HAVE WANTED.
TO HAVE IT AND HAVE IT INSTEAD
BE DISTRIBUTED ON THE CAMPUSES
AS DIRECT AID TO STUDENTS EITHER.
AS EMERGENCY HOUSING ASSISTANCE
OR FOOD BANKS STOCKING TO FOOD
BANKS FOR THE CAMPUSES --
TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT THE
STUDENTS WHO ARE REQUESTING --
EMERGENCY AID RECEIVE IT AT THE
MOMENT SO.
THAT'S THE THAT'S DIRECTION
WE'RE HEADED IN WITHTHOSE PLANS
A LIKE A GOOD PLAN --
WE WE WANT TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT
THE STUDENTS BENEFIT DIRECTLY
FROM THESE FUNDS THAT'S WHAT THE
UNIVERSITY ONCE --
AS DEALIO --
ALREADY REVIEWED IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN WE HAD THIS STUDENT
EXPERIENCE SURVEY THAT FOUND A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT.
OF STUDENT HUNGER WHERE FOR
SYNDICATED OR SKIPPING A MEAL AT
LEAST ONCE A MONTH SOME ANYMORE --
BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T AFFORD TO
PURCHASE FOOD.
SOME OF THAT HAS TO DO WITH --
THE AMOUNT OF FINANCIAL AID
AVAILABLE WE HAVE YOU SEE HAS A
VERY GENEROUS FINANCIAL AID
PACKAGE WHERE FROM FOREST
STUDENTS WE ALSO PROVIDE THEM
WITH LIVING ALLOWANCE --
LIVING ALONE LIVING AID.
HOWEVER --
THERE'S ONLY SO MUCH MONEY TO GO
AROUND SO --
STUDENTS ARE STILL REQUIRED TO
WORK OR BORROW.
FOR AT LEAST TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS OF THEIR OWN EDUCATIONAL
COSTS.
AND THAT CREATES A BURDEN FOR
SOME STUDENTS WHO.
STRUGGLE WITH --
BALANCING WORK AND SCHOOL AND
WHO DON'T WANT TO BORROW SO SO
WE DO KNOW WE DO KNOW THE BASIS
FOR THE THE ROOT CAUSE OF THE
FOOD AND SECURITY IS LACK OF
LACK OF MONEY.
THAT'S WHAT THE STUDENTS
INDICATED THEMSELVES YES.
AND WHILE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS N MANY PLACES
WOULD SEEM LIKE EXTREMELY
WEALTHY PARENTS.
IN CALIFORNIA AND MANY LIVING
AREAS.
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND IS ODD
NOT.
CONSIDERED CALLS WILL HAVE THEIR
INCOME LOCKED UP IN PAYING OFF A
MORTGAGE.
AND THEN GIVING A CHILD THIRTY
FOUR THOUSAND A YEAR TO GO TO UC
THIRTY FOUR BEING --
THE FEES AND LIVING COSTS TO
GATHER.
ODD THAT OUR PARENT OF WITH
MAKING A HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
MAY BE ASKED TO CONTRIBUTE THEY
MAY BE A LITTLE LATE ELIGIBLE
FOR SOME OF THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP AS WELL.
WHICH WOULD ALLEVIATE THAT COST
BUT THEY'RE STILL A SIGNIFICANT
COST FOR THE FAMILY.
AND SO PERHAPS THE STUDENT IS
NOT WANTING TO ASK THEIR PARENTS
FOR THE FULL AMOUNT IF THERE ARE
OTHER THINGS GOING ON LIKE THE
PARENTS ARE SUPPORTING MULTIPLE
KIDS AT THE SAME TIME OR SO.
SO ABSOLUTELY I WAS IN
MINIMIZING THE ISSUE I THINK
IT'S A VERY REAL ISSUE AND IT'S
AN ISSUE WE NEED TO ADDRESS.
SO WE'RE VERY HAPPY THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WOULD PROVIDE
US WITH FIFTEEN MILLION ON GOING
TO CONTINUE TO ADDRESS STUDENT
BASIC NEEDS --
WE ALL HAVE NOW TAKEN A LOT OF
ACTIONS TO START ADDRESSING
THESE ISSUES BUT THE ACTIONS
HAVE PREVIOUSLY BEEN TAKEN WITH
ONE TIME FUNDS --
THE PRESIDENT ALLOCATED ABOUT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS SYSTEM WIDE
STARTING IN TWENTY FIFTEEN BUT
THAT WAS ONE TIME MONEY THAT'S
BEEN SPENT.
AND THE LEGISLATURE PROVIDED US
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
WITH TWO POINT FIVE MILLION AND
IN THE CURRENT YEAR EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN WITH A ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION.
BUT THOSE HAVE BEEN ONE TIME
FUNDS WE USE THEM TO BUY --
FOOD BANKS ON CAMPUSES TO SET UP
A STUDENT FOOD BANKS WE SET UP A
PROCESS WHERE STUDENTS ARE WHO
HAVE A MEAL PLAN CAN DONATE
THEIR UNUSED MEALS. TO STUDENTS
WHO EXPRESS NEED AND THE STUDENT
WHO THEN CAN'T AFFORD TO PAY FOR
A MEAL JUST COASTER GOES TO THE
CAFE AND ARE THE COSTS OF THE OF
STUDENT --
DORMITORY EATERY AND WITH THEIR
VERIFIED PAPERWORK GTS GETS
DOES FREE MEALS.
IT'S AN EXCELLENT PROGRAM HOW'S
THAT WORKING WE HAVE HAD --
LAST YEAR FORTY THOUSAND MEALS
WERE DONATED.
SO THAT THAT'S HELPED.
ALLEVIATE HUNGER TREMENDOUSLY.
RESTORES MY FAITH IN.
SOCIETY YES IT'S OUR STUDENTS
ARE VERY IS ALIVE YES.
YES EVEN AMONG OUR POOR STUDENTS
WHO.
WHO ARE STRUGGLING --
THAT THEY ARE LOOKING OUT FOR
EACH OTHER AND IT'S VERY
ENCOURAGING --
NOT ONLY ARE WE PLANNING ON
ADDRESSING STUDENT HUNGER --
BUT WE'RE ALSO TRYING TO TACKLE
STUDENT HOMELESSNESS
DISTURBINGLY OUR STUDENT SURVEY
FOUND A 5% OF STUDENTS SAID THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN HOMELESS AT SOME
POINT DURING THEIR UNDERGRADUATE
TIMES.
THAT'S A LOT OF STUDENTS 5% MAY
NOT SEEM LIKE A LOT BUT WE HAVE.
A TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS THE 5% OUT.
DOESN'T UP BEING A LOT.
AND WE HAVE A PLAN TO SOME
SLIGHT THIRTY TWO YOU WILL SEE
HOW MANY OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
HOUSED IN OUR DORMITORIES ON ON
CAMPUS HOUSING --
WHILE WE ARE HOUSING 37% OF OUR
UNDERGRADUATES CURRENTLY WE ALSO --
BEFORE FALL TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THERE WERE THIRTEEN THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS ON A WAIT
LIST TO GET INTO A DORMITORY.
THAT'S A LOT OF STUDENTS --
SOME OF THIS HAS TO DO WITH THE
FACT THAT THE COST OF LIVING
NEAR MANY OF OUR CAMPUSES IS
EXTREMELY HIGH. FOR EXAMPLE UCLA
BORDERS ELLIS ANGELUS
NEIGHBORHOOD CALLED BELLAIRE
WHERE THE AVERAGE HOUSE PRICES
THIRTY MILLION OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS ARE NOT LOOKING
DIFFERENT A SPARE BEDROOM TO A
UNIVERSITY STUDENT THAT
RESTRICTS THE AVAILABLE FAR MORE
EXPENSIVE FOR STUDENTS --
ON SLIDE THIRTY THREE YOU WILL
SEE OUR STUDENT HOUSING
INITIATIVE.
WHICH BY TWENTY THREE WE HAVE
NOW EXPANDED AND BY. TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE BETWEEN NOW AND SO
BETWEEN FALL TWENTY SIXTEEN AND
FALL.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WE ARE
PLANNING AND HAVE ALREADY
CONSTRUCTED SOME BUT ARE
PLANNING ON CONSTRUCTING THIRTY
THOUSAND ADDITIONAL STUDENT BEDS
FOR OUR STUDENTS.
SO THE LET THAT ENTIRE WAITLIST
INTO STUDENT HOUSING AND THEN.
MAKE CERTAIN THAT STUDENTS WHO
ARE COMING INTO THE SYSTEM HAVE
AFFORDABLE SAFE HOUSING WHERE
THEY CAN LIVE WITH THEIR PEERS
AND BE CLOSE TO THE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT [inaudible]
SHOW.
IS ACCESS TO STUDENT HOUSING.
PRIOR BASED ON NEED.
CURRENTLY I IT'S PRIORITIZED
BASED ON FRESHMAN STATUS SO
UNDERGRADUATES FRESHMAN GOT
ACCESS FIRST AND SOFT MOORE'S.
AND THAT BUT IT'S NOT A IT'S NOT
BASED ON NEED AS FAR AS I KNOW.
I WAS JUST CURIOUS.
IF THERE'S A LIMITED NUMBER AND
SOME FOLKS MIGHT NEED.
UNIVERSITY HOUSING MORE THAN
OTHER FOLKS --
BUT BUT WE ARE PLANNING ON
EXPANDING CAPACITY DOUBLE ALSO
PULL STUDENTS OUT OF THE NEARBY
COMMUNITIES INTO THE STUDENT
HOUSING --
AND HOPEFULLY KEEP THE RENT
PRICES FROM RISING TOO MUCH NEAR
THE CAMPUS.
I HAVE NO QUESTIONS THAT IS
THAT'S THAT'S MY PRESENTATION ON
BASICALLY.
TALK ABOUT THE STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES RESEARCH IS
ISSUE NUMBER.
EIGHT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES FIVE POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING GENERAL
FUND TO HIRE ADDITIONAL
CLINICIANS TO CARE FOR STUDENTS
WITH MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS AT THE
UC -- THESE
FUNDS WILL SUPPORT A LONG TERM
USE INITIATIVE TO ACHIEVE
RECOMMENDING STASHING MET
RECOMMENDED STAFFING RATIOS AND
DECREASE WAIT TIME PATIENCE.
THIS IS AN ISSUE OUR OFFICES
STILL REVEALING WE'RE WORKING
WITH THE UNIVERSITY TO GET
BETTER DATA ON KIND OF WORKLOAD
ESTIMATES THIS IS ULTIMATELY A
STAFFING REQUEST WITH THE
FUNDING WOULD BE USED FOR IS TO
HIRE MORE STAFF COUNSELORS AND
PSYCHOLOGIST SO WE'RE TRYING TO
GET MORE INFORMATION BOTH.
ON RISING DEMAND WHICH YOU SEE
HAS PROVIDED SOME IN FOR
EXISTING STAFFING CAPACITY --
AND YOU KNOW WHAT HOW MUCH MORE
STAFF WOULD BE FUNDED THROUGH
THE WHAT WAS PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET --
IN ADDITION THERE ARE TWO OTHER --
ISSUES FOR CONSIDERATION THAT
THE COMMITTEE COULD CONSIDER --
FIRST WORDS WERE STILL REVIEWING
THIS OURSELVES BUT AT UC
REQUIRES ALL STUDENTS AS A
CONDITION OF RED REGISTERING TO
HAVE HEALTH INSURANCE AND AS
PART OF THEIR HEALTH INSURANCE
TO ITS AND SUPPOSED TO COVER.
MENTAL AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
AND THEN AN ADDITIONAL CHARGE
STUDENTS --
OF CAMPUS BASED FEES AND ALSO
SYSTEM WIDE FEES TO COVER.
ON CAMPUS HEALTH SERVICES AND
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THE THE
POSITIVES AND NEGATIVES OF
NEGATIVES OF THIS APPROACH ON
THE ONE HAND IT LOOKS LIKE THAT.
BECAUSE DUNES ARE PAUL
PURCHASING INSURANCE AND THEY'RE
PAYING FOR FEES THERE COULD BE
SOME DOUBLE CHARGING HERE ON THE
OTHER HAND THE UNIVERSITY HAS
SOME ARGUMENTS AS TO WHY IT.
DOES IT THIS WAY FOR EXAMPLE IT
ENTER STUDENT PRIVACY --
IT BECAUSE THEY'RE THEY'RE KIND
OF PREPAYING IT THROUGH THEIR
FEES I DON'T HAVE TO GO THROUGH
INSURANCE --
ALSO THERE MIGHT BE SOME
SERVICES THAT AREN'T COVERED.
AND THEN THIRD --
JUSTIN'S AS YOU HEARD OF BASIC
NEEDS MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
THERE'S A AN EQUITY THERE
BETWEEN YOU CCS YOUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
I DON'T HAVE THE DATA IN FRONT
OF ME UNFORTUNATELY BUT WE'RE
HAPPY TO PROVIDE IT TO THE THE
CALIFORNIA RESEARCH BUREAU DID
SOME --
ESTIMATE ACROSS THE THREE
SEGMENTS.
ON BUT USUALLY DOES HAVE A
HIGHER COUNSELOR TO STUDENT
RATIO THAN THE OTHER TWO
SEGMENTS AND IT RAISES QUESTIONS
AS TO WHETHER THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD LIKE TO FOCUS ITS EFFORTS
FIRST ON KIND OF HOW MANY LIVES
EQUITIES OR IF THERE'S A
RATIONALE FOR EXAMPLE.
YOU SEE CAMPUSES HAVE MORE.
STUDENTS TO LIVE ON CAMPUS SO
PERHAPS THERE'S A RATIONAL TO
PROVIDE IT MORE IT YOU SEE THE
NEWS USING COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE
JUST RAISE IT AS AN ISSUE FOR
YOU TO CONSIDER.
WE'LL SEE ISSUE DOESN'T PROVIDE
THE EQUIVALENT OF SHIP
[inaudible]
EITHER.
YES MY UNDERSTANDING I'M NOT I'M
NOT AS KNOWLEDGEABLE ABOUT --
HEALTH INSURANCE IT'S YES YOU MY
UNDERSTANDING IS AGED THE ISSUE
DOES NOT PROVIDE A C. ISSUE --
HEALTH INSURANCE PROGRAM AS YOU
SEE DOES SO THAT'S THAT'S
CERTAINLY ONE DIFFERENCE.
WELL I'D BE INTERESTED IN I'D BE
INTERESTED TO HEAR FROM YOU SEE
ABOUT THIS --
I ASSUME THE CAPS CENTERS DO NOT
BILL AGAINST SHIP WHEN SERVICES
ARE PROVIDED.
UGH THAT'S THAT'S CORRECT THAT
THE THAT STUDENT HEALTH
INSURANCE IS NOT BILLED FOR THE
OF REGULAR MENTAL HEALTH.
OF THIS HAS TO DO A LOT WITH
STUDENT PRIVACY CONCERNS --
BECAUSE THE PARENTS ARE INFORMED
SOMETIMES WHEN --
WHEN THERE IS SUCH BILLING
AGAINST AN INSURANCE BUT IT HAS
A LOT TO DO WITH THE KINDS OF
SERVICES THAT ARE BUILD ARE NOT
BILLABLE? TO INSURANCE OFTEN
BECAUSE THEY ARE --
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT --
SIR THAT.
ANGST RELATED TO BEING AWAY FROM
PARENTS BEING IN A NEW
ENVIRONMENT --
THAT'S NOT USUALLY INSURANCE
COVER FULL BECAUSE THE STUDENTS.
ARE WHILE THEY MAY BE SEEKING
MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELING
SERVICES OFTEN DON'T HAVE A
DIAGNOSABLE DISORDER.
SO IT CANNOT ALWAYS BE BUILT
BACK TO INSURANCE --
ALSO THERE ARE SOME ISSUES WITH
IF WE STARTED BILLING FOR
INSURANCE FOR THE REGULAR.
OF MENTAL HEALTH OF COUNSELING
VISITS.
WE WOULD HAVE TO TAKE MEDICARE
ALL INSURANCE FOR THAT AS WELL
AND IF WE DO THAT WE WOULD HAVE
TO OPEN OUR STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH CLINICS.
TO MEDIC CAL PATIENTS REGARDLESS
OF THEIR STUDENT STATUS.
AND WE WANT TO KEEP THOSE
CLINICS FOR OUR STUDENTS ONLY --
BUT I CAN LOOK INTO --
INTO HOW WHICH DEVELOP OUR SHIP
RATES WHETHER OR NOT.
THERE IS ANY OVERLAP IN THAT.
I HAVE NO CLUE IN THE QUESTION I
THIS IS A VERY VERY --
SERIOUS ISSUE SOME OF YOU MAY
HAVE HEARD ME TALK ABOUT IT AND
IN CASE YOU TWELVE K..
TWO FOURTEEN AND IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE STRESSORS
OUR STUDENT POPULATION TODAY AT
ALL LEVELS ARE.
GREAT AND AND INCREASING --
BY THE DAY IN THE MONTH SO WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
THE APPROPRIATE.
A PROPERLY TRAINED PROFESSIONALS
ON CAMPUS TO TRY TO HELP IN
WHATEVER WAY WE WE CAN'T WHETHER
IT'S ON THE CAP CENTERS OR
THROUGH THE STUDENT HEALTH
PROGRAM.
AND WHAT WE'RE REQUESTING TODAY
SERVICE ARE YOUR APPROVAL OF THE
FIVE POINT THREE MILLION AN
ONGOING FUNDING IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
BUT WE'RE ALSO REQUESTING --
FOUR POINT EIGHT MILLION IN ONE
TIME FUNDING FROM CURRENT YEAR
BE MADE PERMANENT ANOTHER STEP
FOUR POINT EIGHT MILLION AS PART
OF THAT NINETY FIVE MILLION WE
DISCUSSED EARLIER AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS HEARING.%
SO WAS EMBEDDED IN THAT CURRENT
YEAR ONE TIME FUNDS WE RECEIVED.
THAT --
WE'RE NOT RECEIVING AS AS AS CAN
WE BE PROVIDED.
THOSE FUNDS ARE CRITICAL FOR US
TO CONTINUE OUR EMPLOYING THE
MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELORS THAT WE
HAVE ALREADY HIRED ON OUR
CAMPUSES.
ON SLIDE THIRTY FIVE I HAVE SOME
DATA ON HOW MANY STUDENTS HAVE
BEEN REQUESTING --
APPOINTMENTS.
AT AT OUR MENTAL HEALTH CLINICS
AND YOU'LL SEE THAT IN THE OVER
THE LAST DECADE FROM
200-072-2017 --
THERE WAS AN INCREASE OF 78% IN
UNIQUE REQUEST FOR MENTAL HEALTH
APPOINTMENTS OR MENTAL HEALTH
CLIENTS THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO
ACTUALLY CAME IN FOR AN
APPOINTMENT --
BACK IN. 27200079% OF STUDENTS --
REQUESTED A MENTAL HEALTH
APPOINTMENT AND I WAS ABOUT
TWENTY THOUSAND STUDENTS.
REQUEST AN APPOINTMENT NOW IT'S
13% OF OF STUDENTS.
AND OF 13% IS ABOUT.
OF IS ABOUT THIRTY SIX THOUSAND
STUDENTS WRIST REQUESTING AN
APPOINTMENT SAYING THEY NEED TO
COME IN.
FOR THE C. SOMEBODY.
THE AVERAGE AMOUNT OF TIME TO
STUDENTS WAIT TO SEE A COUNSELOR
IS NINE DAYS BUT THAT'S AN
AVERAGE IF IT'S A CRITICAL
EMERGENCY IF THEY THINK THE
STUDENTS SUICIDAL ORDER
SOMETHING HORRIBLE HAPPENING --
THEY WILL SEE THAT STUDENT IN
THE SAME DAY SO THOSE WHO --
ARE FEELING DEPRESSED AND
REQUESTING A CONCERT BUT DON'T
SEEMTO BE IN CRISIS I HAVE TO
WAIT A LITTLE BIT LONGER SO THE
NINE DAYS AS AN AVERAGE --
AND ALSO THE AVERAGE STUDENT
COMES IN FOR AT LEAST FOUR
VISITS OB THAT VARIES BY CAMPUS
HOW MANY THE COMMON FOR AND HOW
MANY --
VISITS THE CAMPUS MENTAL HEALTH
COUNSELING CLINIC WILL SEE THEM
FOR BEFORE AN OUTSIDE REFERRAL.
THE SHIP THE STUDENTS PARENTS
PAGE PROGRAM MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ONCE THEY'RE BEING
PROVIDED OUTSIDE THE CAMPUS
SERVICE STUDENT REQUIRES LONG
TERM CARE --
THAT'S WHEN THE SHIP IS BEING
BILLED.
ANON SLIDE --
THIRTY SIX YOU WILL SEE A LITTLE
BIT MORE DATA ABOUT --
UC'S MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELOR
RATIO SON ACCOUNTS WERE RATIO WE
ARE STARTING TO DO BETTER --
NOTICED IN THE LAST FEW YEARS
ARE HIRING OF SEVENTY NEW
COUNSELORS.
TOOK US DOWN FROM --
THIRTEEN OF ONE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED NINETY FOUR STUDENTS PER
COUNSELOR. 210-001-0060 EIGHT
STUDENTS PER COUNSELOR --
WE THINK THAT RATIO IS STILL A
LITTLE BIT HIGH BUT WHERE THE
RATIO SEEMS TO BE --
TOO HIGH FOR US IS THE
PSYCHIATRIST TO STUDENTS WHERE
WE WE STILL STRUGGLE WITH --
NOT HAVING ENOUGH.
THOUGHT TRAIN PSYCHIATRISTS WHO
CAN PRESCRIBE MEDICATIONS.
AND OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS --
BACK IN TWENTY FIFTEEN WE
STARTED RAISING THE STUDENT
SERVICES FEE.
OF THE REGION'S HAD A POLICY
THAT WE WOULDN'T B. FIVE FEET BY
5% ANNUALLY AND THEN HALF OF THE
INCREASE AFTER FINANCIAL AID
WOULD GO TO MENTAL HEALTH
COUNSELORS.
TO GET MORE MENTAL HEALTH
COUNSELORS THE CAMPUSES.
AND THAT HAS YIELDED --
LAST YEAR THAT WAS BOUGHT OUT BY
THE LEGISLATURE US YOU SEE THE
FOUR POINT EIGHT MILLION THERE
ON THE FAR RIGHT COLUMN OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH INCREMENTAL
REVENUE.
THAT WAS THE FOUR POINT EIGHT
WAS -- STATE
GENERAL FUND BUT ALL TOGETHER
THE INVESTMENT HAS BEEN EIGHTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS SINCE TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH.
CONSULAR HIRINGS YOU SAW IN THE
AGENDA.
THERE WAS A HIS CHART HAVING TO
DO WITH THE CAMPUS SPECIFIC
PROVIDER TO STUDENT RATIOS
HAVING TO DO WITH WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HOUSES AND
PSYCHIATRIST --
WHAT IS THE VACANCY RATE SO HIGH?
IRVINE FOR EXAMPLE OR A
RIVERSIDE.
MAYBE MAYBE FOLKS CAN'T GET TO
SANTA CRUZ BUT I'M JUST CURIOUS
I MEAN YOU WOULD THINK THAT
WOULD BE ABLE.
TO FIND PROVIDERS TO FILL
VACANCIES ON THOSE CAMPUSES.
IS THAT OUR PRESENT WAITING
SORRY STRUCTURES STATE
GOVERNMENT THAT CAN'T BE.
I'LL HAVE TO LOOK INTO THAT FOR
YOU A LITTLE BIT MORE ARE --
MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELORS ARE
PART OF OUR OF THE BARGAINING
UNIT AND WE ARE CURRENTLY
NEGOTIATING WITH THEM ON THE
SALARIES OKAY [inaudible]
GOT IT. ONE OF THE QUESTION
LOOKING AT THE CHURCH IN THE
AGENDA ON THE CAP CENTERS AND
FEES AND LINKS LINKS OF SERVICES.
THERE'S A VERY ATION --
AMONG CAMPUSES THE SET BECAUSE
THIS LOCAL CONTROL ON THE
CAMPUSES CONSIDERS.
POLICIES. FOR THESE CAPS CENTERS.
YES WE ALLOW THE CAMPUSES
CONTROL THAT.
WELL I THINK THOSE ARE MY
QUESTIONS.
ANYTHING FURTHER ON THIS ISSUE
MA'AM.
JUST FOR YOUR REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE FULL OF PROPOSAL
FROM THE UNIVERSITY CLOSE THE
CENTRAL ISSUE SO I'M SURE WE'LL
HAVE CONTINUED DISCUSSION I
SHOULD HAVE SAID AT THE
BEGINNING WERE HOLDING ALL THESE
OPEN.
WHICH IS A GOOD THING --
GIVEN MY DYESS BUT WE'RE HOLDING
ALL THESE OPEN WE WILL REVISIT
THESE I GUARANTEE YOU --
AT A LATER DATE WHAT COVERS YOU
NUMBER NINE WHICH IS CAPITAL
OUTLAY AND DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
THANK YOU SIR [inaudible]
GREAT WORK.
HELLO --
THANK YOU SENATOR OFF A MAJOR
EDDIE CASTLETON APART OF FINANCE
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
THANK YOU --
CONSISTENT WITH AUTHORITY
PROVIDED IN EDUCATION CODE
SECTION 924-932-9249 SIX YOU
SEEM A USE THAT SUPPORT
APPROPRIATION FOR CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS ADDRESSING THE NEED OF
FACILITIES THAT SERVE ACADEMIC
PROGRAMS.
IN ADDITION THIS ABILITY ALLOWS
YOU SEE TO FINANCE THE COST OF
THE FURRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS
AT ACADEMIC FACILITIES AND
RELATED INFRASTRUCTURE.
HOWEVER AND NO MORE THAN 15% OF
YOU SEE SUPPORT APPROPRIATION
THAT OF THAT SERVICE CAN BE USED
FOR CAPITAL EXPENDITURES. TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY YOU SEE
SUBMITTED ONE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS AND SIX
CAPITAL OUTLAY REQUEST.
ALL ARE QUALIFYING PROJECTS THAT
WERE INCLUDED IN OUR LIMIT AND
FINANCES PRELIMINARY APPROVAL
LETTER -- IF
FUNDED IT'LL RAISE THE MAXIMUM
PERCENTAGE OF PROJECTED.
THAT TO SIX POINT 8% WHICH IS
WELL BELOW THE 15% THRESHOLD --
IN ADDITION TO THE CAP OUT LATE
PROJECTS THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES A HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT
MILLION AND ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND TO SUPPORT DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE --
JUST A FEW COMMENTS REGARDING
THE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS --
THAT ARE BEING SUGGESTED WE ARE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH LEGISLATIVE
STAFF TO PROVIDE INFORMATION
REGARDING THE PROPOSED DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FUNDING.
ASSOCIATED PROJECTS AND SURE
THAT SPENDING.
IT USES THAT OUTCOMES.
OF OUR FROM THE DEPARTMENT SPACE
BUDGET DEPARTMENT DO NOT
TYPICALLY PROVIDE SUPPLEMENTAL%
REPORTING ON THESE PROJECTS AND
RELATED EXPENDITURES --
IT MAY BE MORE BENEFICIAL AND
INFORMATIVE FOR STAFF AND THE
LEGISLATURE REQUESTED AND THE
INFORMATION FROM DEPARTMENTS ON
AN AS NEEDED BASIS.
AND WITH REGARDS TO DEPARTMENT
OR PROJECTS WHERE THEY WITH A
MAYBE A SPECIFIC INTEREST OR
CONCERN.
RATHER THAN IMPOSING A BROAD
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENT AS PROPOSED IN THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION.
WHAT IS THE FUNDING LEVEL
PROVIDED?
FOR THIS TYPE OF WORK.
SUFFICIENT TO AT LEAST.
KEEP THE FOUR POINT FOUR BILLION.
DOLLAR FIGURE LEVEL AND NOT.
HAVE IT INCREASING IT SEEMS TO
ME THAT IS WE DO WORK IT IS YOU
DO WORK ON BUILDING A BUILDING
SEE MAY FALL ON THE LIST SO IS
THAT A FAIR QUESTION.
ABSOLUTELY AND WILL ALSO BE
RESPONSIBLE ON TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON ANY QUESTIONS
THAT ARE SPECIFIC TO THE OVERALL
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG AND HOW TO
PREVENT IT FROM GROWING.
OR OR NOT YEAH HOW TO PREVENT
FROM GROWING HOWEVER DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE IT IS THE DAY THAT
DYNAMIC PROCESS.
IT CAN DEPEND ON THE POINT TIME
ESTIMATES AS THE AND OR OR EVEN
WHAT --
CROSSES A SPECIAL FROM DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE INTO CAPITAL OUTLAY.
BUT WE WOULD KNOW THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS MAKING
TARGETED EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
THESE DEPARTMENTS ONGOING
FACILITY NEEDS BUT THIS GOAL OF
PREVENTING AN INCREASE IN
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE --
BUT AS AS FUNDING IS AVAILABLE
AND IT IS AN ALLIANCE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PAL.
IS BALANCING ONE TIME AN ONGOING
NEEDS WELL IT OCCURS TO ME WE'RE
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO I MEAN
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS.
SEEMS FINE TO ME WE NEED TO
PROVIDE THE MONEY NECESSARY FOR
THE INSTITUTION TO KEEP ITS
FACILITIES --
IN GOOD SHAPE.
BUT WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO HAVE A
BROADER CONVERSATION ON HOW WE
HOW WE FUND.
THE THESE CAPITAL FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE WE'VE GOT
THIS ONE'S FOUR POINT FOUR
BILLION I THINK SEE ISSUE.
THE ISSUE SYSTEM HAS SOMETHING
SIMILAR SOMETHING AROUND FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS IN NEEDS --
SO THE TOTAL SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
EIGHT AND NINE BILLION DOLLARS --
AND IT'S NOT GOING DOWN ON ITS
OWN ACCORD.
SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO HAVE A
LARGER CONVERSATION HOW WE
POSSIBLY AS A STATE CAN CAN FUND.
THESE PROJECTS ON SOME REGULAR
RECURRING BASIS SO WE WHITTLE
THAT. NINE BILLION DOLLARS TOTAL
OR WHATEVER IT IS.
DOWN OVER TIME I THINK THE WAY.
YEAH I'M I'M IS CERTAINLY A GOAL
IT WOULD JUST HAVE TO BE WEIGHED
IN TOO WITH ALL THE OTHER
PRIORITIES THAT YOU SEE OR OR
SINCE YOU ARE ANY DEPARTMENT. TO
ADDRESS I'M NOT BEING CRITICAL
I'M JUST I'M JUST BAFFLED BY HOW
WE GET OUR ARMS AROUND THIS.
THE SCOPE OF THIS PROBLEM AND
BEGIN.
TO ADDRESS IT IN A IN A
MEANINGFUL WAY INSTEAD OF
INSTEAD OF A HUNDRED MILLION
THERE WHEN THE THE WOMEN NOT TO
IS. EIGHT TO NINE BILLION BUT WE
WE APPRECIATE ALL THAT YOU WERE
DOING TO HELP --
YOU SEE AND THEY'RE NOT HERE BUT
SEE ISSUE AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TO ADDRESS.
SOME OF THESE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE NEEDS HELLO.
YOU HAVE THREE ISSUES BEFORE YOU
WHEN THIS ITEM THE FIRST AS DEBT
SERVICE COSTS THE SECOND IS --
PROPOSED CONSTRUCTION AND
RENOVATION PROJECTS AND TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY AND IN THE
THIRTIES DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
SOLVED ADDRESS EACH ISSUE ONE AT
A TIME.
REGARDING DEBT SERVICE COSTS
VERY QUICKLY YOU SEE DEBT
SERVICE COSTS ARE ANTICIPATED
TURN INCREASED BY ABOUT FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS AND TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY AND THESE ARE
THIS DEBT SERVICE ASSOCIATED
WITH PROJECTS THAT WERE APPROVED
IN IN PREVIOUS YEARS BUT YOU SEE
IS NOW BEGINNING TO FINANCE THEM --
AND SO THIS IS A COST IT'S NOT
IDENTIFIED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AND IT MAY BE A COST THAT
THE LEGISLATURE WANTS --
TO FACTOR INTO ITS BUDGETS FINAL
BUDGET DECISIONS FOR THE
UNIVERSITY WHY DID WE CAP AT 15%
CAN YOU REFRESH ME --
ALSO THE ENGINE AND MAY I JUST
MAKE SURE I DIDN'T MISS SPEAK
THE FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IS A
JUST A INCREASE IN THE COST BUT
YOU'RE ASKING ABOUT THE 15% SO
WE KEPT THERE YEAH.
OKAY JUST MAKE SURE MAKING
JORDAN TO SPEAK ON THAT --
BECAUSE THEY BOTH HAVE THE
NUMBER FIFTEEN AND THEN --
YOU WOULD BE ME WHO IT WOULD
MISSPOKE YEAH SO THE THE IDEA
BEHIND AND I DON'T HAVE
INFORMATION AS TO WHY EXACTLY
15% IT'S A IT'S A A 12% AT C. S.
U. 15% IT YOU SEE SO IT'S A
DIFFERENT PERCENTAGE SEGMENT --
WHAT I WHAT I DO KNOW IS THAT --
IT IN FACTORING IN ROLLING IN
DEBT SERVICE COSTS TO THE
UNIVERSITY SUPPORT BUDGET --
THE IDEA WAS THAT TH UNIVERSITY
WOULD HAVE TWO WAY TRADE OFF
EACH YEAR BETWEEN.
A REGULARS ARE OPERATING COSTS
AND ROMAN I CAPITAL OUTLAY AND
SO THAT THE PURPOSE OF THAT WAS.
TO PROVIDE A GREATER INCENTIVE
FOR THAT THE CAP IS INTENDED I
THINK.
TO PROTECT --
THE RECORD RAIN REMAINING
PRIORITIES AND USE HIS BUDGET SO
IT TO ENSURE IT DOESN'T GO ABOVE
THAT PERCENT AND IT TAKES AWAY
RESOURCES AWAY FROM THE MOMENT
GROWTH OR COMPENSATION COSTS OR
OTHER SORT OF OPERATING
PRIORITIES I THINK THAT WAS THE
INTENTION BEHIND THAT CAP BUT
AGAIN I DON'T.
HAVE ANY INFORMATION AS TO WHY
THE C. LANDED ON THAT EXACT
PERCENT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THAT'S THE FIRST ISSUE THE
SECOND ISSUE IS THE PROPOSED
PROJECTS FOR NINETEEN TWENTY AND
YOU CAN SEE THOSE PROJECTS ON
PAGE FORTY OF YOUR AGENDA.
AND YOU'LL SEE THAT THERE IS A
THE FIRST ITEM THERE'S DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE I'M GONNA SAVE THAT
FOR THE THIRD.
ISSUE THAT I RAISE SO THAT KEEP
THE REMAINING SIX ARE IN OUR
PROJECTS THEY GO TO CONSTRUCT
NEW PROJECTS ON THE OR THE
RENOVATION PROJECTS.
AND WE RAISED ISSUES WITH WITH
THE TWO OF THE PROJECTS --
AT SANTA BARBARA AND SANTA CRUZ
THEY'RE BOTH PROJECTS BROADLY --
THEY'RE INTENDED THEIR THEIR
INTENTION IS TO ADD MORE --
CLASSROOM SPACE ACROSS THE
CAMPUSES.
A NEW BUILDINGS --
WE HAVE SOME PROJECT LEVEL
CONCERNS AS WELL BUT ARC ARE
CROSS CUTTING CONCERN WITH BOTH
PROJECTS IS THAT THEY FOCUS
HEAVILY ON LARGE LECTURE SPACE
AND THE REASON FOR THAT IS IF
YOU LOOK AT CLASSROOM USE THAT
YOU SEE AT THAT.
VIRTUALLY ALL CAMPUSES --
LARD LARGE LECTURE SPACE IS.
IT USED MUCH MORE THAN SMALL
CLASSROOM SPACE FOR EXAMPLE ON
THAT.
LINES OF OTHER INFORMATION YOU
FOR TODAY FOR EXAMPLE --
INCREASING CLASS SIZES FOR
EXAMPLE THAT'S THAT'S FOR MANY
YEARS HOW YOU SEE IS DELIVERED
UNDER LARGE LECTURES STUDENTS
ABOVE A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
STUDENTS IN A CLASS.
OUR CONCERN HERE IS THAT THE
STATE IN RECENT YEARS HAS
PROVIDED ONGOING FUNDING TO
EXPAND ONLINE EDUCATION.
AND YOU SEE NOTED THAT THERE IS --
SOME POLICY DEBATE BETWEEN THE
MERITS OF ONLINE VERSES IN FACE
TO FACE INSTRUCTION IN OUR VIEW
OF THE THAT DEBATE PROBABLY
MAKES LESS SENSE ONCE THE CLASS
I STARTS HITTING A HUNDRED FIFTY
STUDENTS --
IS PROBABLY NOT THE SAME LEVEL
OF PERSONAL CONNECTION AS AS
OPPOSED TO SAY --
A CLASS THAT HAS MAYBE FORTY
STUDENTS FOR EXAMPLE.
AND GIVEN THAT THE STATE IS.
PROVIDING FUNDING TO EXPAND
ONLINE EDUCATION.
ARE WE RAISE THE CONCERN THAT
WHETHER YOU SEE IS ADEQUATELY
USING ONLINE EDUCATION. TO A
KIND OF MEAT AND ROMAN DEMAND AN
END USER TO HAVE AS AN
ALTERNATIVE TO NEW CAMPUS
CONTINUED --
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION.
AND ONE OTHER THING TO POINT OUT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS MANY
FACILITY OF PRIORITIES INCLUDING
AS YOU NOTED DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE LIFE SAFETY OF
PROJECTS.
AND SO THAT'S ANOTHER REASON WHY
WE QUESTION WHETHER THE
UNIVERSITY COULD DO MORE TO FIND
ALTERNATIVES TO ACCOMMODATE
ENROLLMENT GROWTH AND TO EASE --
CAPACITY ISSUES IN LARGE LECTURE
HALLS THAT'S OUR CONCERN THERE
WELL IT YOU KNOW FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE I I I I DO ENCOURAGE.
IN THINK OUR UNIVERSITIES SHOULD
LOOK AT ONLINE EDUCATION
COMMUNITY COLLEGE OF ISSUES
DUKE'S SYSTEMS DOING THAT I
THINK WE SHOULD.
UTILIZE MORE ONLINE EDUCATION
WERE APPROPRIATE CERTAINLY
TAKING A LOOK AT THAT FOR
BOTTLENECK COURSES AS WE
DISCUSSED EARLIER.
BUT I ALSO THINK IT SHOULD BE AN
OPTION --
FOR THE STUDENTS BECAUSE SOME
STUDENTS ARE NOT GOING TO
FUNCTION VERY WELL ON THE ONLINE
ENVIRONMENT AND SOME.
SOME WILL AND I JUST WONDER
ADDING A LARGE LECTURE HALL FOR
EXAMPLE THEY'RE PROBABLY MORE
THAN ENOUGH STUDENTS.
TO FILL THAT WHO WOULD OPT OUT
OF ONLINE EDUCATION THAT WOULD
YOU KNOW BE MY RESPONSE BUT I
GUESS WE CAN TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ON AND THEN THE THE THIRD
CONCERN A THIRD ISSUE WAS
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND EGGS AT
THIS IS A LITTLE CONFUSING
BECAUSE THEY'RE IN TWO DIFFERENT
AREAS BUT YOU HAVE TWO DIFFERENT
MEANINGS PROPOSALS.
THE FIRST IS A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND A ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND FOR DEFERMENTS PROJECTS.
AND THEN SECONDLY THE UNIVERSITY --
IS ALSO PROPOSING A THIRTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN BOND FUNDS
FOR ADDITIONAL DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS OF BOTH OF
THOSE COMBINED OUR OUR IS WHAT'S
BEFORE YOU IN TERMS OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROPOSALS.
WHAT ABOUT WHAT ABOUT THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE CONDITIONS
ASSESSMENT AND I'LL GET TO THAT
IN MY TESTIMONY?
A TOP I'LL BE SURETO TOUCH ON
THAT -- AND
I ACTUALLY THOUGHT I SHOULD
ACTUALLY ANSWER THAT QUESTION
NOW TO FIND THAT OUT OF THE BOND
FUND SO THAT THIRTY FIVE MILLION
FIVE OF THAT WOULD GO FOR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE CONDITION
ASSESSMENT.
THE REMAINING THIRTY WOULD BE
FOR PROJECTS.
IS THAT NORMAL.
WHAT WE WRITE WE RAISE CONCERN
WITH THAT WE THINK THAT'S AN
INAPPROPRIATE USE OF BOND FUNDS
THE BOND FUNDS CARRY THE COST OF
A?
PROJECT OVER MANY YEARS THIS
WOULD BE A ONE TIME STUDY.
I WILL NOTE THAT THE UNIVERSITY
IS CURRENTLY DOING A FACILITY
CONDITION ASSESSMENT THIS IS
ASSESSING THE CONDITION OF ITS
EXISTING FACILITIES AND SO YOU
KNOW TO THE FOUR POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLAR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG.
OF THE UNIVERSITY --
IS HOPING TO GET A MORE REFINED
ESTIMATE FROM THE STUDY IT USED
BOND FUNDS FOR THAT STUDY RAISE
THE SAME CONCERNS NONE THE LESS
OF THE ADMINISTRATION PROVIDED A
UP A FORTY FOR THAT AND SO YOU
KNOW DO YOU SEE WHAT I HAD AND
FUNDED THAT'S THEIR BOND FUNDS.
SO THEY THEY'VE DONE THAT IN THE
IN THE PREVIOUS YEAR WE WE WE
RAISE THE SAME CONCERNS WITH THE
INFRASTRUCTURE CONDITION
ASSESSMENT AND AND JUST TO
SPECIFY THAT INFRASTRUCTURE
CONDITION ASSESSMENT IT'S
LOOKING AT ROADWAYS UTILITIES
OTHER THINGS THAT THAT ARE
SEPARATE ROM THE FACILITIES AND
THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN.
THOSE TWO STUDIES FOR THE FIVE
MILLION.
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION I CAN GET
I CAN GET BACK TO THEY THEY GAVE
US A OF AN ESTIMATE OF DEBT
SERVICE COSTS I DON'T HAVE IT IN
FRONT OF ME BUT THEY THEY DID
INCLUDE THE COST OF INTEREST I
CAN I CAN GET BACK TO YOU ON
THAT.
BUT THERE IS A COST OF INTEREST
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT.
I MEAN I THINK THIS IS WE NEED
TO STUDY I MEAN I THINK THE
STUDY IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL I'M
JUST WONDERING WHY WE DON'T FIND
IT -- THE
GENERAL FUND.
IN AND PRESERVE.
THAT SMALL RELATIVELY SMALL
PIECE OF YOU SEES BONDING
CAPACITY ANOTHER ISSUE TO
CONSIDER IS THAT THIS IS --
ONE TIME FUNDING LONG TERM YOU
SEE WILL LIKELY HAVE TO
OPERATIONALIZE THE STUDIES TO
CONTINUE TO KEEP THAT ESTIMATE
RELEVANT IN FUTURE YEARS.
AND IT DOESN'T ADDRESS THE
QUESTION OF HOW YOU CIVIL --
FUNDED IN AN ONGOING BASIS ONCE
THE INITIAL STUDIES COMPLETED.
NEEDS TO BE PART OF THE BUDGET.
RIGHT UP IN THAT THAT'S ONE
OPTION YES.
BUT A MINIATURE OF TRUCK NOT
SURE --
SOMEONE THING WE WE NOTED WITH
THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
PROJECTS --
WRIT LARGE IS THAT --
THERE WEREN'T PROPOSE PROJECTS
AT THE TIME WE RETURN ELSE'S WE
RECOMMEND TO THE LEGISLATURE GET
A LIST OF PROJECTS BEFORE
APPROPRIATING FUNDS.
I WILL NOTE THAT THE UNIVERSITY
SUBMITTED TO OUR OFFICE --
A LIST OF PROJECTS THAT INTENSE
I IT APPEARS FOR BOTH THE ONE
TIME FUNDING IN THE BOND FUNDING
WE'RE STILL REVIEWING THAT LIST
WE RECEIVED AT MONDAY AFTERNOON
BUT THE UNIVERSITY WAS WORKING
WITH US TO PROVIDE.
MORE INFORMATION TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON ON THE USE OF
THOSE FUNDS.
THE OTHER THING WE RECOMMENDED
AND I THINK THIS GETS AT SOME OF
THE BROADER QUESTION THAT YOU
RAISE ABOUT --
HAVING A LONG TERM PLAN TO
ADDRESS DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
CURLY THAT'S LACKING ACROSS ALL
OF OUR HIGHER EDUCATION SEGMENTS.
AND THAT DOESN'T GIVE THE
LEGISLATURE MUCH --
SENSE OF HOW IT THE THESE ONE
TIME FUNDS EACH YEAR ARE REALLY
GOING TO PAY DOWN THAT BACKLOG
WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECT THE EACH
SEGMENT TO INCLUDING YOU SEE.
A LONG TERM PLAN TO RETIRE THIS
BACKLOG AND THAT SUCH A PLAN
WOULD IDENTIFY THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY EACH YEAR NEEDED.
TO RETIRE THAT BACK GLAD THAT
GIVE THE LEGISLATURE A BETTER A
RATIONALE TO MAKE THESE SORT OF
ONE TIME FUNDING DECISIONS.
IN ADDITION TO THAT THE THAT
PLAN WOULD ALSO INCLUDE A PLAN
MOVING FORWARD AND HOW TO
IMPROVE MAINTENANCE PRACTICES
SUCH THAT A BACKLOG DOESN'T
CONTINUE EACH YEAR AND ALL
MAINTENANCE IS.
PART OF THE REGULAR ONGOING
OPERATIONS.
MAYBE YOU SAID THIS DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE HELP ME UNDERSTAND.
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT MAINTENANCE
THAT.
THAT REQUIRES CONSTRUCTION SO
YOU'RE IMPROVING --
CAPITAL FACILITY FOR EXAMPLE AS
OPPOSED --
TO REPLACING AN AIR CONDITIONING
SYSTEM OR HEATING SYSTEM OR
SOMETHING ELSE THAT.
I WOULD THINK THAT LONG TERM
BOND MONEY WOULD BE --
IT WOULD BE QUESTIONABLE USE OF
THAT SORT OF FUNDING STREAM.
THAT'S RIGHT SO --
TECHNICALLY DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
REFERS TO THE LATTER OF WHICH
YOU DESCRIBE IT REFERS.
TO H. FAQ REPLACEMENTS OTHER
SERVER IN --
FACILITY REPLACEMENTS THAT
MAINTAIN THE USEFUL LIFE IT
TYPICALLY DOESN'T INCLUDE
CONSTRUCTION.
OUR RENOVATIONS OR CORRECTIONS
ARE THINGS THAT THAT CHANGE THE
NATURE OF THE BUILDING.
WE DID RAISE CONCERNS WITH.
ADDING DEFERRED MAINTENANCE TO
AN ALLOWABLE USE A BOND FUNDS
AND OF I THINK WHAT WAS ADDED IN
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN RAISE THE
CONCERN THEN.
I'M WE WE THOUGHT THERE COULD BE
EVEN A RATIONAL FOR SOME
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS OF
MIGHT HAVE A LONG USEFUL LIFE
BUT WE WANTED SOME MORE WE
RECOMMENDED THERE IS THERE BE
MORE DEFINITION AS TO WHAT.
CONSTITUTED DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
AND WOULD BE ALLOWABLE USE FOR
BOND FUNDS --
YOU LOST THAT ARGUMENT
[inaudible]
CORRECTION GOTCHA.
OKAY I WAS JUST WONDERING IT
WOULD BE YOU KNOW.
THAT'S A REAL THAT'S A
REASONABLE CONCERN TO RAISE.
WE WOULD PROBABLY GET A HOME BUT
I GUESS WE DO IT HERE.
ON THE NET AND THOSE ARE THOSE
ARE THE THREE ISSUES I THAT
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS
[inaudible]
YOU SEE.
I THANK YOU SENATOR WE REQUEST --
YOUR APPROVAL OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED HUNDRED AND THIRTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE YOU SEE
CURRENTLY HAS THE FOUR POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLAR BACKLOG THAT
YOU HEARD ABOUT --
THIS WOULD ALLOW US TO ADDRESS
THE MOST CRITICALPROJECTS AND
WERE.
WERE VERY VERY GRATEFUL TO BE
RECEIVING THESE FUNDS --
WE'RE WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH YOU ABOUT A
LONG TERM PLAN.
ON ADDRESSING THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE ISSUES AT UC --
I THINK OUR INFRASTRUCTURE STUDY
WILL HELP WITH THAT ONCE WE HAVE
AN IDEA OF OF WHAT.
NEEDS TO GET FIXED OUR OR SURE --
TO MAINTENANCE PROJECTS SO THAT
WE MAXIMIZE --
SOME OF THE SOME OF THE
EFFICIENCIES GREAT TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF SOME OF THE
EFFICIENCIES WE CAN TAKE FOR
EXAMPLE --
IF WE HAVE AN AIR CONDITIONING
SYSTEM THAT'S ABOUT TO FAIL WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO LOOK AND SEE
THAT MAYBE THERE'S TWENTY SUCH
AIR CONDITIONING SYSTEMS ON ALL
OUR CAMPUSES.
AND THEN WE COULD NEGOTIATE A
BETTER RATE WITH --
WITH A PROVIDER FOR FOR THOSE
ARE TWO UNITS THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
HOPING TO DO THIS ONE OF THE
WHERE WE GET IT WE COULD HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH YOU IN THE
ADMINISTRATION ON WHY WE WOULD
BORROW.
LET'S SAY I DON'T KNOW THE
LENGTH OF THE BONDS BUT WHY WE
WOULD BORROW AND USE THIRTY YOUR
MONEY.
BUY A PIECE OF EQUIPMENT THAT
HAS A SEVEN YEAR USEFUL LIFE AND
MAYBE THERE'S A DIFFERENT WAY.
TO TO FINANCE THAT.
OUT OF THE GENERAL FUND.
TO CREATE A POOL FOR THAT SORT
OF EQUIPMENT PURCHASES OPPOSED.
TO YOU'RE GOING TO THE MARKET TO
BORROW.
X. AMOUNT OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FOR THIRTY YEARS TO BUY THAT
PIECE OF EQUIPMENT THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO BUY. THREE OR
FOUR TIMES FOR OR TWO OR THREE
TIMES DURING MY MAKING SENSE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OR DO I
NOT UNDERSTAND HOW THIS WORKS.
IN THE ARMY TO CRITICIZE.
THANK YOU SENATOR --
GENERALLY A LOT OF THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE THAT IS BEING FUNDED
WOULD BE SUCH AS BOILERS OR
EIGHT TRACK SYSTEMS THAT TEND TO
HAVE A USEFUL LIFE THAT WOULD BE
LONGER THAN THAT THE TERM OF THE
BOND.
ALSO A LITTLE WHILE THAT MAKES
OUR FALL GEO BONDS ARE OFTEN
THOUGHT OF AS TWENTY FIVE OR
THIRTY YEAR BONDS IT IS POSSIBLE
TO STILL SHORTER TERM BONDS SO
SAY.
IF IT IS A CHILLER SYSTEM THAT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE FIFTEEN YEARS.
THEN YOU CAN SELL BONDS THAT
WOULD BE PAID OFF IN ABOUT
FIFTEEN YEARS AND SO THERE IS AN
EFFORT TO MATCH THE LENGTH OF
THE BOND WITH THE USEFUL LIFE OF
THE OF THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
ITEM THAT YOU'RE WORKING NOW
CERTAINLY THE GOAL SIR --
BECAUSE THESE ARE YOU CEASE OWN
INTERNAL BORROWING CAPACITY WE
CAN CHANGE THE LENGTH OF THE PAY
BACK AMOUNT --
WE DO AGREE WITH THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT AND PALEO THAT --
IT MAY MAKE SENSE TO MOVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE STUDY OUT OF THE
BOND INTO THE ONE TIME FUNDS
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR SO IF
YOU WOULD PERMIT US TO DO THAT
WE'LL.
WE'RE HAPPY TO DO THAT SO THAT
THE BORROWING CAPACITY IS NOT
PAYING FOR THE STUDY.
OF BUT RATHER TO ONE TIME FUNDS
WE WOULD GET WOULD PAY FOR THAT
THE FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE STUDY THAT MAKES
A LOT OF SENSE AND THANK YOU
THAT THE LA ON TO THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT FOR THAT --
THE REASON WE HAVE DEVELOPED
THIS VERY LENGTHY SOME OF THE
REASONS WE HAVE DEVELOPED A VERY
LENGTHY DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
PROJECT LIST IS THAT.
YOU SEE UNDERWENT A LOT OF
CONSTRUCTION DURING THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES AND THESE BUILDINGS ARE
NOW GETTING TO THE POINT WHERE
THEY'RE STARTING TO FALL APART
AND EVERYTHING IS BREAKING --
AND WHILE [inaudible]
WE WERE.
HAVING OUR BUDGETS REDUCED OR
NOT GROWN ENOUGH TO MEET SOME OF
THE INSTRUCTIONAL DEMANDS OF OUR
STUDENTS --
WE SCALED BACK SOME OF THESE
MAKE THOSE FUNDS THAT WAS AND
THAT WAS ONE PLACE TO SCALE BACK.
SO REALLY DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
AND OF BEING A REFLECTION OF THE
UNIVERSITY'S ABILITY TO TAKE
CARE OF ALL ITS OBLIGATIONS
BECAUSE THAT'S ONE OF THE PLACES
WHERE.
OUR CUTBACKS WERE MADE WHEN
FUNDS WERE NEEDED TO BE SHIFTED
ELSEWHERE.
THAT HASN'T BEEN ARCTIC
ADEQUATELY FUNDED WELL I'M VERY
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM WE'RE FACING
YOU'RE FACING AN ADULT THE STUDY
IS IMPERATIVE AND HOWEVER WE
FINANCE IT.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THE
RESULTS ALL RIGHT --
I'D LIKE TO MAKE A FEW COMMENTS
ABOUT THE UC SANTA CRUZ AND UC
SANTA BARBARA PROJECTS THAT WERE
PRODUCT BY DE LA OKAY --
FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE TO POINT
OUT THAT UCSANTA BARBARA THE
LAST TIME THEY HAD A NEW TOTALLY
NEW CLASSROOM PROJECT.
COULDN'T --
GIVING THEM ADDITIONAL CAPACITY
WAS IN. NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN WE
THINK IT'S ABOUT TIME THEY
CAUGHT AN ADDITIONAL BUILDING
WITH NEW CAPACITY --
THIS BUILDING WOULD GIVE THEM
BRAND NEW CLASSROOMS ARE MORE
FLEXIBLE SPACE.
AND ALLOW THEM --
TO ALSO HAVE A LARGER ONE LARGER
CLASSROOM WHERE THEY COULD TEACH
ARE CURRENTLY ON THE SANTA
BARBARA CLASS --
CAMPUS THEIR CLASSROOMS THAT ARE
OVER TWO HUNDRED STUDENTS IN
CAPACITY ARE OVER 1100%.
UTILIZE WHAT THAT MEANS IS
BETWEEN THE HOURS OF EIGHT AM
AND FIVE PM MONDAY THROUGH
FRIDAY.
ARE TOTALLY BOOKED AND THEN
THEY'RE TEACHING IN THE EVENINGS
AND THOSE CLASSROOMS AS WELL
THEY REALLY NEED MORE MORE
CAPACITY --
ON THE SANTA CRUZ CAMPUS OUR
UTILIZATION OF CLASSROOM
CAPACITY SHOWS THAT FOR ALL
CLASSROOMS OVER ONE HUNDRED
SEATS.
THERE AGAIN 1100% OVER AT MORE
THAN 1100% CAPACITY THEY THEY
VERY MUCH NEED NEW CAPACITY ON
THE CAMPUS AS WELL.
AND THIS HAS BEEN IN THERE LONG
RANGE DEVELOPMENT AND AND WE'RE
REQUESTING THAT THESE PROJECTS
BE ALLOWED TO MOVE FORWARD.
AS REQUESTED WELL WE'RE PUSHING
YOU TO TAKE MORE STUDENTS.
EACH YEAR SO WHETHER WE PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR THE FOR IT OR NOT
AND FOR GOING TO PUSH YOU TO
TAKE MORE STUDENTS WE BETTER.
MAKES YOU SURE YOU HAVE
CLASSROOMS TO TEACH STUDENTS AND
SO.
I UNDERSTAND THE REQUEST.
THANK YOU OF IN ADDITION WE ARE
REQUESTING --
FOR FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
DEBT SERVICE TO HELP PAY FOR
PROJECTS THAT WERE ALREADY
APPROVED AND CONSTRUCTEDTHIS IS
TRUE THE PROCESS THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE.
OUTLINED FOR YOU EARLIER --
THE ALSO CALLED THE AB NINETY
FOUR THESE PROJECTS THAT ARE NOW
COMING DUE. FOR FOR THE DEBT
SERVICE WERE APPROVED --
ONE OF THEM WAS APPROVED IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN SEVERAL OF THEM
WERE APPROVED IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
AND TWO WERE APPROVED.
BACK IN TWENTY FIFTEEN THEY'VE
NOW BEEN FULLY CONSTRUCTED AND
WE ARE STARTING TO PAY THE DEBT
SERVICE ON THEM.
IF THIS ADDITIONAL REQUESTS FOR
THE DEBT SERVICE FUNDING IS NOT
APPROVED THEN THE MONEY COMES
OUT OF OUR EXISTING BASE
OPERATING BUDGET [inaudible]
I SEE.
ANYTHING FURTHER THAT CONCLUDES
MY PRESENTATION THANK YOU SIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY WELL LET'S YES SIR PLEASE I
JUST WANTED TO PROVIDE SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON THE
TWO PROJECTS --
THAT I RAISED CONCERNS WITH
EARLIER.
FIRST I I I DON'T THINK I
RESPONDED VERY WELL TO A
QUESTION THAT YOU RAISED AND I
JUST WANTED.
TO ELABORATE MORE ON I THINK THE
QUESTION YOU RAISED AS WELL
SHOULDN'T STUDENTS HAVE A CHOICE
BETWEEN.
FACE TO FACE AND ONLINE
INSTRUCTION AND ALL WE WERE
SUGGESTING IS THAT --
YOU SEE COULD GRADUALLY MOVE
TOWARDS USING INCORPORATING I'M
ONLINE INSTRUCTION MORE IT STILL
HAS A LECTURE HALLS THAT USES
FOR FACE TO FACE INSTRUCTION TO
STUDENTS STILL WOULD HAVE THAT
CHOICE IT WOULD JUST BE A
QUESTION OF YOU WANT TO CONTINUE
TO EXPAND THOSE KINDS OF SPACES
OR DO.
YOU WANT TO FOCUS MORE ON THE
LOWER --
SMALLER CLASSROOMS WHERE THAT
THERE'S MAYBE MORE OF THAT TRADE
OFF BETWEEN --
FACE TO FACE AND ONLINE
INSTRUCTION AND AND IN.
WELL IT AND AGAIN IT'S A
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE AND I'M SURE
WE'RE GONNA HAVE CONTINUED
DISCUSSION I WOULD AGREE WITH
YOU I THINK OF OUR INSTITUTIONS
OF OUR SYSTEMS ALL THREE COULD
DO MORE WITH ONLINE.
THIS IS A COMMUNITY COLLEGE --
UNDER THE PRIOR ADMINISTRATION
IS STEPPING OUT FAIRLY SMARTLY
ON AT THE BEGINNING STAGES BUT
SEE ISSUE AND YOU SEE --
HAVE BEEN LOOKING AT ONLINE IT'S
A DEBATE AND INTERNAL DEBATE --
I KNOW I THINK I KNOW WITH THE
ACADEMIC SENATE AND FACULTY AND
WHETHER ONLINE IS GOOD --
ONLINE IS BAD BUT I'M SURE YOU
SEAL CONTINUED TO ENGAGE IN
THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND AND WERE
APPROPRIATE TRY --
TO AND ONLINE PROGRAMS.
BUT IN THE INTERIM AS WE PUSH
THEM.
TO TAKE IN MORE STUDENTS WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE
CLASSROOMS TEACHING MEN AND SO
THAT'S WHY I MADE THE COMMENT
I'D I DID BUT I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON
ANSWER YOU DID A GREAT JOB.
THANK YOU JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE I GAVE YOU THAT INFORMATION
THE OTHER INFORMATION --
JUST TO MAKE SURE YOU'RE AWARE
OF IS -- AS
YOUR WEIGHING BETWEEN THE TWO
CAMPUSES SANTA CRUZ IN SANTA
BARBARA.
SANTA CRUZ DOES HAVE A LOT MORE
CAPACITY CONSTRAINTS THROUGH
LARGE LECTURE HALLS ARE ARE
HEAVILY UTILIZED AND THEIR LOOK
SMALLER CLASSROOMS ALSO HEAVILY
UTILIZED IN THE PROJECT WOULD DO
A MIX OF BOTH AND THERE WAS SOME
WE SAW SOME MERIT THERE WE HAD
SOME ADDITIONAL CONCERNS WITH.
SOME OF THE ADDITIONAL SPACE
WHICH I'M HAPPY TO ELABORATE ON
IF IF.
THAT'S OF INTEREST TO THE
COMMITTEE BUT THE SMALLER
CLASSROOM SPACE HAD SOME MERIT
[inaudible]
BARBER CAMPUS.
DOES HE WAS THERE A LARGE
LECTURES OVER A 100% THEY'RE
SMALLER CLASSROOMS ARE NOT USE
THAT CAPACITY AND THE PROJECT
CAN INCLUDE A MIX OF BOTH SMALL
AND LARGE SPACE AND SO THAT WAS
ONE RESULT.
THE SCOPE OF THE SMALLER
CLASSROOMS ALSO --
HAD MAYBE LESS AMERICAN SAY AT
THE SANTA CRUZ CAMPUS NOW GIVEN
THE EXISTING UP PROCESS THE
LEGISLATURE HAS A LOT LESS
ABILITY TO PROVE A REJECT
PROPOSALS HAVE EVEN LESS ABILITY.
TO CHANGE THE SCOPE OF PROJECTS
AND SO THAT THAT'S THE SORT OF
COMPLEXITY IS REVIEWING THESE
DIFFERENT SCOPES BUT THAT THAT
SOME ADDITIONAL INFORMATION FOR
THOSE PROJECTS AS REVIEWING THEM.
THANK YOU YES MA'AM.
IF I MAY JUST COMMENT ABOUT THE
WAY YOU.
YOU SEE COMES UP WITH THESE
PROJECTS IS THAT THERE IS A
LENGTHY.
OF APPROVAL AND REVIEW PROCESS
OFF THEM WHERE THEY CAMPUSES
DEVELOP A LONG RANGE DEVELOPMENT
PLAN.
OF THE CAPITAL OUTLAY FOLKS ON
THOSE CAMPUSES CAREFULLY
EXAMINED THE NEEDS AND WHAT IT
WOULD TAKE TO CONSTRUCT A
BUILDING.
IT GETS ON A TEN YEAR OF PLAN
FOR THE CAMPUS THAT GETS
APPROVED BY THE REGENTS.
THEN WHEN THE PROJECT IS COMING
UP FOR DEVELOPMENT.
OF THE REDO THOSE PLANS AGAIN
WERE MUCH MORE DETAIL SO IT'S NO
LONGER BACK OF THE ENVELOPE BUT
THEY'VE REALLY LOOK AT THE SITE
AND WHAT THE WHAT ARE THE WHAT
ARE THE BEST WAYS TO ADDRESS THE
CAMPUSES GROWING NEEDS.
AND THEN IT GOES IN FRONT OF THE
REGIONS FOR APPROVAL SO THERE'S
MULTIPLE LEVELS WHERE THESE
PROJECTS ARE BEING LOOKED AT TO
MAKE CERTAIN THAT THEY MATCH THE
CAMPUSES NEEDS.
HI BOB HELLO PERTINENT TO SEE
PROJECTS GO UP AND I THINK YOU
WILL DO A VERY FINE JOB IN
MANAGING YOUR CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS IN THE IN THE THE
RESULT IS QUITE SPECTACULAR SO.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
OKAY OF ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS KATHY VAN
AUSTIN I REPRESENT JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH WHICH
FOCUSES ON A FORMER BOSS YOUTH
TRANSITIONING INTO INDEPENDENT
LIVING.
AS WELL AS HOMELESSNESS AND I
WANT TO JUST JUST TAKE AN
OPPORTUNITY BRIEFLY TODAY. TWO
ONE THANK THE YOU SAY --
FOR ITS EFFORTS IN IN LOOKING
EXAMINING --
IT'S HOMELESSNESS ISSUES --
THEY'VE DONE A STUDY AS THEY
THEY HAVE DONE A SURVEY THAT
INDICATES ABOUT 5% OF THEIR
STUDENTS --
HAVE EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS WE
KNOW THAT ON OUR NUMBERS AND
THOSE NUMBERS AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND CS YOU'VE --
CAMPUSES ARE --
EIGHTEEN AND 13% RESPECTIVELY SO
WE'VE GOT A REAL PROBLEM HERE IN
THE STATE AND OF SENATOR PORTENT
TINO HOUSE --
SUBMITTED A MEMBER'S REQUEST.
THAT --
TOTALS TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
GO AMONG THE THREE SYSTEMS --
BASED ON NEED --
THAT IS --
LINKED TO SP FIVE SIXTY EIGHT
WHICH IS AUTHORED BY YOU SENATOR
AND SENATOR PORTENT TINO --
WHICH PROVIDES A IT'S AN
EVIDENTIARY BASE EXTREMELY WELL
LA AREA.
THAT PROVIDES RAPID RE HOUSING
IT'S BASED ON RAPID RE HOUSING
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT SERVICES
INCLUDING MAKING SURE THAT THE
STUDENTS AS THEY ARE --
ENTERING INTO HOUSING BUT THEY
ALSO REMAIN IN COLLEGE THAT'S
WHEN MOST IMPORTANT THINGS THAT
WE WANT TO DO IS KEEP KEEP THE
STUDENTS LEARN IN SCHOOL SO --
WE KNOW THAT SEE AS A YOU SEE
HAS REQUESTED --
FIFTEEN MILLION FOR THE BASIC
NEEDS.
WOULD CERTAINLY ENCOURAGE THE
UNIVERSITY TO LOOK AT THIS --
MEASURE.
AND THE THE PROJECT IN LA IT'S
RUN BY HOVHANESS --
YOU KNOW IT'S AN EXCELLENT
PROGRAM TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS
AND WE WOULD ENCOURAGE THE CITY
DO THAT BUT ALSO ENCOURAGE
APPROVAL OF THE FUNDING.
THANK YOU FOR COMING AND I WOULD
NOTE THAT --
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE WILL WILL HEAR
ALL MEMBER REQUESTS THAT FIT
WITHIN THE JURISDICTION OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE SO WE WILL BE
HEARING THAT --
MEASURE IT'LL REQUEST AT A LATER
DATE [inaudible]
YES SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON FOLKS WE SURE
LEARNED A LOT TODAY DIDN'T WAY --
MY NAME IS GABRIEL GARCIA AND
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALLS
FOR ALL COALITION WE ARE A MULTI
RACIAL STATEWIDE AND COMMUNITY
LED COALITION THAT REALLY SEEKS
TO PROMOTE SOCIAL JUSTICE.
AND OUR HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS I WAS SPECIFICALLY
REQUESTING REINVESTMENT IN OUR
INSTITUTIONS OF PUBLIC HIGHER ED
AROUND ACCESS AFFORDABILITY
DIVERSITY EQUITY --
TODAY I'M HERE TO REQUEST A
REINVESTMENT IN THE COLLEGE
READINESS BLOCK GRANT WHICH WAS
ORIGINALLY ALLOCATED FOR BY SB
TEN FIFTY AND TWENTY SIXTEEN THE
BLOCK GRANT WOULD PROVIDE CEASE.
TO OUTREACH TO LOW INCOME
ENGLISH LEARNER AND FOSTER YOUTH
ALL ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA --
AND ON TOP OF THAT OUT REACH
MAKING SURE THAT ONCE THEY
TRANSITION.
ONTO CAMPUS THEY HAVE THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO SUCCEED --
THAT WOULD REALLY ADDRESS A LOT
OF THE ISSUES THAT WERE TALKED
ABOUT HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR COMING
PROCEDURE COMMENTS YES MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON CATHERINE OCCUR
GOING ON BEHALF OF COPYING
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER WE WOULD
LIKE TO BRING TO YOUR ATTENTION
THE NEED FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR FACULTY FOR BILINGUAL
TEACHER PREPARATION PROGRAMS.
AT OUR UC AND CSU SYSTEMS IN OUR
PRIVATE UNIVERSITIES.
THERE IS A NEED TO EXPAND
EXISTING BILINGUAL TEACHER
PREPARATION PROGRAMS OR
ESTABLISH NEW ONES IF WE ARE TO
BUILD THE CAPACITY OF BILINGUAL
TEACHERS FOR BILINGUAL PROGRAMS.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN CALIFORNIA HAD
THIRTY STATE APPROVED BILINGUAL
TEACHER PREPARATION PROGRAMS AS
REFLECTED IN THE REPORT GLOBAL
CALIFORNIA TWENTY THIRTY SPEAK
LEARN LEAD PUBLISHED BY STATE
SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TOM TORE LEXAN.
INVESTING INTO AN ADDITIONAL
FACULTY WOULD ALLOW GREATER
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL STUDENTS
TO BECOME BY LITERATE AND
BILINGUAL AS PROMISED BY
PROPOSITION.
FIFTY EIGHT THAT CALIFORNIA MY
MULTI LINGUAL EDUCATION ACT AS
WELL AS INSURING THAT THEY'RE
QUALIFIED BILINGUAL TEACHERS FOR
E. L. STUDENTS.
WE ASK THAT YOU CONSIDER AB TEN
TWELVE BY A SEVEN MEMBER RAY HAS
INTRODUCED THIS YEAR THAT SEEK
SUCH AN INVESTMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANKS FOR COMING YES
SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN RESUME
BAYARDO WITH THIS HERE YOU
CALIFORNIA WE ACTUALLY OF A
SMALL ACTS THAT WILL BE MAKING
JUST FOR ONE AND A HALF MILLION
ONE TIME FOR THE BERKELEY LABOR
CENTER TO LOOK AT THE FUTURE
WORK.
IN THE CHANGING DYNAMICS IN THE
WORK FORCE WE THINK THAT A LOT
WHAT AID IS WE THINK WE CAN YOU
INFORMATION HELP US UNDERSTAND
POLICIES AS WE MOVE FORWARD WE
THINK IT'S A SMALL.
INVESTMENT ONE AND A HALF OVER
THREE YEARS TO GET HELP HAVE A
BIG IMPACT ON WORKERS AND AND
POWER FOR WORKERS A IN THE
FUTURE.
THANK YOU.
YES SIR GOOD MORNING MR ARM HI
MY NAME IS PUSH I'M WITH THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION.
I WANT TO FIRST START BY
HIGHLIGHTING WHAT MY FRIEND ALSO
MENTION ABOUT THE COLLEGE BLOCK
GRANT THE TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR
ON GOING THAT IS DEFINITELY
SOMETHING THAT --
WE THE SUPPORT WOULD LIKE TO SEE
ADDITIONALLY TO THAT --
I I DO ONE ALSO HIGHLIGHT THE
NEED FOR THE FUNDING FOR
ENROLLMENT GROWTH FOR NEXT YEAR
TO SEVEN TWO POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY.
IN ADDITION TO THE NINETY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR FUNDING --
THAT WOULD KEEP THE TUITION FLAT --
THE THE NINETY FIVE AND DIED
LAST YEAR WAS ON JUNE ONE TIME
FUNDING AND WITHOUT BECOMING ON
GOING WE WOULD BE A STRING IN
TUITION INCREASE WHICH WE WOULD
HOPE YOU'RE HOPING TO AVOID SO.
ARE THESE FINDINGS ARE REALLY
NECESSARY FOR STUDENTS AND AN
ORDER FOR THE TUITION TO REMAIN
FLAT SO WE HIGHLY ENCOURAGE --
EVERYBODY TO TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION TO SEE FINDING
THAT THE LEGISLATURE AS WELL
THANKS AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
COMING.
ANY OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEEING NONE.
THAT WAS THE ONE THANK YOU IS OF
EXTRAORDINARY PRESENTATION I
ENJOYED THE CONVERSATION AND
DISCUSSION LOOK FORWARD TO
FUTURE ONES THANK YOU GREAT JOB.
WE ARE ADJOURNED